thank you
[Music]
foreign
box
ES
[Music]
foreign
oh
[Music]
MS
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
laughs
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
it's day three in the AI cup and two
good old friends will face off in the
winners final Magnus Carlsen and maximum
fighting to go straight through to the
Grand Final but before that happens two
more players will be knocked out welcome
to the AI cup
pieces at the right
acute an attack and finish the game this
ish button that he's just pressed what
is this kid got in store he's so good
he's so good at thinking on the flight
Checkmate on the board
he is so stressed out I'm sure he knows
he's so close in this one this is a
game-ending move
we're mixing it up in the studio in here
to guide you through day three in the AI
cup as always with the analysis board
Grand Master David Howell and
international Master Tom Yum it's
actually so nice to see you guys so nice
to be in the studio here with you guys
what an action-packed day two you guys
had here in the studio we even saw David
a mate in three that Magnus Carlsen
didn't spot what happened there it was
just incredible Kaya so many twists and
turns in yesterday's action in all of
the matches actually but Magnus Carlson
missing a forced Checkmate
um that was a once in a lifetime and uh
the way he saved that game at the end
going for stalemate in some of his games
it was well it really had everything I
guess that was the biggest shock
yesterday Tanya but much more happened
what was some highlights for you so many
of them it's been a nerve-wracking event
so far and we had this dramatic match
between Maxine basharagov and chakra
mamaderov's fireworks from the start
before Mikaya was really impressive was
how Anish took down Hikaru nakamuraka a
two to O score line but not just that he
made it look easy really convincing and
Powerful play by Anish I think he has
become a bit of a favorite in this one
yeah he must be flying high with some
confidence now in East giri and well
yesterday day two was nice for uh
someone my level of Chess to actually
see a Grandmaster Miss a mate in three
this one's still anyone's game who will
recover oh my gosh what just
happened wow
you're five he can sacrifice his Queen
and win on the spots
oh my god when Magnus got some fun Queen
taste cheese incredible that's a Jack
made in tree he doesn't find it
that is Carson missed a Checkmate entry
he's seen it now
oh wow look at his reaction there that
isn't oh he's gone to have a little lay
down after that so uh I think the
practical decision the professional
decision would be to repeat here he's
one minute down after all on the clock
decision has been made Queen C7 on the
board big big trouble for Jan napomnushi
there's a Checkmate wow
takes porn now looks like the most
natural move took us a while but look at
this the black king finally caught
Magnus does know his checkmates everyone
that is it uh yeah does resign after age
three Magnus Carlson boxing up blacks
King there
he does it well done that is that's
amazing it's amazing stuff from Nepal oh
he finds Queen at seven but is it's a
different position but he has the idea
and look at Magnus Magnus reacts now
black is completely Frozen the black
Rook is stuck in front of the pool and
the Black Knight uh stuck preventing any
jerks oh look at that oh he missed
another chance as soon as they're
separated it will be game over oh what
oh whoa oh unbelievable and maybe now
unbelievable you cannot take the Rook
that's still mate again maybe now black
can hold long enough he's made the draw
unbelievable
glass from Jana ponyachi 2 Magnus Carl's
nepo is knocked down to the losers
bracket and today he will face off
against the youngster alireza fuja in
the losers quarterfinals and the other
match there is muhammadiarov against
Gary later today it's going to be Magnus
Carlsen against maximum in the winners
final and that's going to be an exciting
one these two have not played each other
so far this season on the mouth on the
Champions Chester so David what should
we expect when these two two good old
friends face off yeah it's always a
fight very rarely do we see kind of
quick exchanges and a draw between these
two Magnus tends to go for vashilograph
and of course freshly Grove Embraces the
challenge uh this one both plays in
really good form right now it's going to
be a lot of fun to watch the same
generation they know each other
extremely well and it's tactical yeah
what would it mean do you think Tanya
for Emil to to beat Magnus today and and
make it through to the Grand Final
that's gonna be huge right because for
maxim his one big shot to Toronto is to
win the whole thing a victory would seal
the deal yeah is that a big task ahead
of him but it's not just Maxime you've
got three players in the elimination
bracket who are also looking at that
spot into the finals one step at a time
for maxim I mean I'm just thinking Kaya
if a two times World Championship
Challenger could not beat Magnus Carlsen
up a queen versus a rook What's it gonna
take yeah what is it gonna take David
what will mvl have to do to be minus
well he'll have to show you that Killer
Instinct that he has displayed over the
past couple of days but he'll also
needed a bit of luck he'll need magnets
to miss a few things he'll need Magnus
to not quite be in top form and of
course you'll need to be in topform
himself he has beaten Magnus he beat him
in the speed Chess Championship last
season uh so he's got some form he
should take Confidence from that yeah
and let's hear what Magna said yesterday
about now facing Emil for the first time
this season
yeah it's exciting to get to play um
like Sim
um he did tremendously well in the speed
Chess Championship
um
crushing
uh gurukash was was sort of expected but
also
um the way he won against nihal was a
little bit unexpected for me and not
that he won but the way he won and
um
sound very impressive
um and also like he was leading against
zikari with um with the bullets
um when the bullet started and I feel
like
even before that he had many chances to
leave lead even more and of course he
beats two very very strong players to to
get there so yeah it's good to get a
crack at him again it's been it's been a
while I feel
um and um yeah I I just I think I gotta
show up with the
a little bit more energy than I did
today because yeah today was
not good
magnets law and energy and in sweatpants
yesterday he is sitting in Oslo actually
all six players left in the tournament
are all sitting in Europe that's unusual
with India and the US flying high but
these six players are still in AI cup
fighting to go through and four of them
actually fighting to uh to bank a spot
to go across the Atlantic and to Toronto
do you think that is something that will
be in the back of their minds Tanya it's
got to be right it's a 500 000 season
and a final and they all know that it is
their only shot tour points they would
need so much to go that way for that but
again Kaya with this field and every
match being so incredibly difficult I
think that thought has to just wait for
for now it's one game at a time and for
those in the elimination bracket it's
all about surviving exactly and in the
elimination bracket we do have Mom and
yarov against Anish giri both of them as
Tanya mentions now fighting to Banker
spots in Toronto they well the easiest
path is to win the tournament and one of
them will be knocked out today so uh
David what should we expect with the
always entertaining mom jarov against
Geary well I expect the unexpected I
would say with Mama jarov these two do
have a track record and my major offers
played some of his most beautiful games
against Anish giri in the past so Anish
with a score to settle and as he said
himself in the interview yesterday
getting to those tour finals is a huge
goal and uh yeah it's going to be cage I
think but in just a two-game match
he also said he needs a miracle for that
to happen but miracles do happen they do
they do and then we also have Jana
pomyachi knocked down from the winners
bracket yesterday to face alireza faruza
today and what do you expect from that
one Tonya that's going to be a fun fun
battle from the very start again their
Styles both intuitive players aggressive
players really like to take those
decisions that bring on the dynamic play
a lot on the line especially for Jana
Palmer Street alireza is already through
to Toronto so there's a little less
pressure on him yeah but of course he's
looking for a tournament Victory I think
it's more uh more on the line more at
stake foreign
foreign
[Music]
most of his peers at a young age
including Magnus Carlson Napoleon
actually is also one of the few players
in World Chess who keeps a positive
score against the world champion the
pontiacci is extremely aggressive and
ambitious he's always seeking the
maximum from every position he also
plays incredibly fast that can scare his
opponents but
occasionally it can backfire sometimes
he rushes a bit too much and misses some
key details in positions a very
dangerous player but one who's yet to
prove himself right at the top level
this position is from one of Napoleon's
games when he was only 13 years old
it does showcase his style perfectly
actually now won the game with a very
elegant tactic
first he decided to sacrifice his Knight
The White Knight capturing a pawn near
the enemy King
felt compelled to capture this Knight
and rather than recapture The Rook which
would lead to a balanced position Napoli
actually Unleashed a hidden detail he
brought his Queen up giving check to the
black king sacrificing the White Queen
and after Black's King took this
final
very pretty detail white took this Rook
giving Fork to the black king and the
black queen and
after Black's King retreated
he captured the queen and he emerged
with a material advantage white is now a
rook for a night ahead naponyachi he's a
dangerous tactician
[Music]
born in that golden year 1990 same age
as for example Magnus Carlson he has
played two World Championship matches
but he still is not a world champion but
what a player he is and what would you
say is his biggest strength Sonia
there are so many he's one of the best
players in the world and right now he's
got a lot working from him he's uh fresh
from a victory at the levitar week made
some fantastic chests there uh the one
thing that we've seen in the Champions
Chester from Jana Pana she has been his
speed as David said in that profile
video that he's a tactical genius he's
never shy of going into aggressive
positions he loves the Dynamics he plays
them out confidently and he always is up
on the clock but I'm still trying to
think David what was it that didn't work
for nepo yesterday well it's just when
it comes to crunch time those kind of
moments that decide games occasionally
he gets a bit nervous we saw in that
world championship match against Magnus
where after falling to his first defeat
he just collapsed and yesterday again
against Magnus we saw firstly blundering
the Checkmate the final game on the
brink of Victory letting it slip uh I
think just having that self-confidence
to push and yeah he can do it he's
capable he just needs everything to fall
into place yep and uh he is a fun guy
yeah he's played on the Champions chess
Tour all seasons and I want to bring
back a memory from I think it's the
first season when Jana Paul miyachi was
bothered by mosquitoes
that is so funny I think he's gonna fly
or something bothering him sorry you
were saying
um I mean he's not just being bothered
by Wesley he's been bothered by the
flyer I guess that's ideal stop White's
King Advantage oh did he catch it in the
end oh maybe but it's a oh Wesley's
laughing as well do you think he's
watching the web oh did you get it the
white Bishop about to be trapped does he
resign yes he does it was some kind of
shamanic ritual because you know during
the last game I mean I didn't care about
the game at all I was like uh only
wanted not to get uh you know eaten down
by mosquitoes I mean this was completely
I mean it's not incredible like I I I
have never seen such a big amount in one
place and I was still here so okay
probably I would offer a draw but I mean
it was too late and you know even now it
continues
[Music]
I can just feel the frustration for
Neville they're playing a whole day of
chess with just a bunch of mosquitoes in
his room hopefully they will not be
there today as he faces
with uh just pressure on him to go
through to uh tomorrow's losers
semi-finals and uh it's it's a special
match up here for him against he did
Magnus did say before uh his last World
Championship match that he would only
play after his last World Championship
match he would only play alirez of Rouge
and then nepo ends up winning the
candidates tournament and Magnus decides
not to play
is that sort of
do you think that was just a little bit
disrespectful to Jana punyachi uh
possibly I don't think Magnus means it
that way I think Magnus is just Keen to
take on the Next Generation but uh
janaponishi grav in the winners bracket
we see all of these players around
magnus's age still there it's still up
to that Young Generation to come through
and kind of take their place rise up and
usurp the throne
um so yeah it's fascinating to see this
Clash of generations uh face off now
yeah
he is
with potential Armageddon to decide the
loser is quarterfinals and what do you
expect from alireza today Tanya
while he's been playing really well so
far here so I think he's going to
continue that momentum I think the clock
is going to be a huge factor in this
matchup we've been talking about Yan's
one of his biggest strength being speed
and his ability to take really critical
combative decisions very quickly alireza
meanwhile does struggle to struggle a
little bit on the clock uh so I feel
like that would be a battle that alireza
will have to take control of and we've
got an opening which already promises to
be a really fun battle guys nice what
are we seeing here it started as the
Italian game it was the two knights
defense by black and white tried to go
for something we called the fried liver
attack which would have involved
sacrifices bringing out the black king
early instead black is sacrificed upon a
quick flurry of moves this is a very
popular opening at all levels especially
Club level I would say and white are
Pawn up here but black will most likely
get a lead in development this last move
the pawn push to H4 ambitious but not
White's most common uh Tanya any
experience here
with H4 not and exactly what you said
that there are other moves uh that
definitely alireza was prepared for he's
gone into a thing after that uh it makes
Yan's intentions really clear he's well
prepared he knows what he's doing he's
testing alireza in the opening knowledge
and right now alireza with a 30-second
think he's not feeling really
comfortable and it's the kind of opening
David where you can go wrong and it can
be really bad if you go wrong one one
bad move and you're stuck with a with a
terrible position yeah for both sides
yeah high stakes chess really direct
chess none of this slow maneuvering uh
kind of strategic play that we sometimes
talk about here in napoleonishi he's
grabbed the material he's a pull-up he's
going to try and click onto it and
farusha is the one with the burden of
seeking counter play
I just love it this position suits both
players Styles actually so it's going to
be really interesting to see who comes
out on top clearly at the moment though
it is Yan who's better prepared he was
the one who chose this opening predicted
this opening Borussia has to uh kind of
just acclimatize
all right this game has started looks
like it's gonna be a super entertaining
one but the other first game in the
losers quarter finals is also about to
start between Anish giri and Shakira and
mamiyar who will have the white pieces
in this game one remember best out of
two rapid games potentially Armageddon
to decide the match and what are we
seeing here wow okay my major are
starting with the ready opening usually
he's very predictable usually he plays
one D4 pushes the Queen's Pawn nearly
without fail but uh Anish girida
offering a transposition into a bunch of
openings including the Sicilian mamajoro
it feels like he's freestyling already
Pawn to E3 he's just playing against uh
Anish giri's theoretical knowledge here
I think he's trying to take the game
into Uncharted Territory as early as
possible is that sensible makes a lot of
sense guys especially when you're
playing against the player who's so well
prepared and for shock I think he just
wants to position not only a surprise
with the one Knight F3 but the second
move as well pushing that pawn in front
of the King instead of the instead of
trying to Fan cattle his King side
Bishop so a really interesting opening
approach uh Bioshock playing against
well not just uh what he has on the
board but the opponent that he's
fighting today
yeah it seems like it takes a lot of
time to move your two pounds already
only one square when you can move them
two squares and maybe he's forgotten
that rule Kaya maybe it's forgotten that
pawns do move two squares on the first
turn uh and each giri he has actually
had something very similar against
Hikaru Nakamura yesterday uh but there
Hikaru went for a slightly different
setup also involving Pawn to B3 and the
fiancato and Hikaru was punished so
clearly managerov had been watching that
game he's trying to set up slightly
differently now and the game will take a
slower turn this is far less direct than
the other encounter but
um still it shows ambition from my major
if he doesn't want to just go into
opening Theory test the nishikiri there
he wants to play a game from move one
it's just about who the better player is
on the day yeah and the one good thing
about keeping it flexible with white is
that you've got all these uh plans that
can later on occur on the board with a
deep on advancing forward and
challenging at the center and it's black
it's Anish who actually does that first
D5 it was time he's castled he's
developed the pieces and he asks uh
shakuria about the intentions in the
middle of the but
we see trades the Knight develops with a
tempo
mm-hmm and how do we feel about uh
Black's uh Queen up on the board early
on usually I'd be skeptical Tanya
Black's Queen coming out very early it's
going to get kicked about a bit we don't
normally recommend that right but uh it
is Anish giri I do trust his opening
preparation and the fact that he played
these last two moves really quickly uh
means that he does know what he's doing
and I think he just paused a bit Anish
giri in the early stages in the first
five moves because often play can
transpose to different openings
depending on your move order depending
on how your opponent reacts and suddenly
we've transposed back into something
he knows pretty well
unless white can somehow step forward as
you mentioned earlier Kaya with pawns
two squares forward open up lines or
maybe get at this black queen then and
he shows a very healthy position with
black I think it will be a big success
okay we are definitely going to follow
the action in both of the matches on the
losers quarter finals today but you guys
did say that you were expecting a lot of
drama and like game one with alireza and
Jan so we're jumping back to that game
as anything happened since we last saw
this position a lot yeah it's weird
wacky a really rare position White's
still a pawn up remember but there are
Knights on the edge of the board for
black uh White Queen has done a little
dance Black's Queen looks like it's on
an odd Square
um I already see threats tactics in the
air Tanya yeah and it's the kind of
position where white down upon sorry
white up a pawn but black has a lot of
Peace activity and it's all about trying
to get that momentum going which is why
Ali Reza does not slow down kicking that
night out from the center of the board I
like this approach by him with F5 and as
you're pointing out uh uh David here E4
Knight F4 to very attractive options
which put in some direct threats into
White's position
yeah really tempting Knights on F4 we
talk about Knights and F5 from the white
side this is kind of uh the dream Square
for a black piece you're hitting the
queen hitting the bishop hitting uh the
bishop here and hitting the pawn on G2
and how does white defend you might be
forced back to some really ugly squares
as white and look at the white pieces
pretty much retreated all the way back
to square one and this is on the board
uh Queen to F1 has just been played and
I'm expecting furuja to be tempted to
push this Pawn forward potentially maybe
it developed his Bishop to attacking
posts
better know what he's doing otherwise he
might get punished I mean just look at
the position it's so weird that Knight
on B1 is the one that's supposed to land
on C3 but it's the other night that has
taken that spot so you really can't
finish your development easily the queen
is coming in the way of the king in The
Rook there's no castling in a sight to
me it looks like a lot of compensation
with black I would like to play this
position uh playing for the initiative
David there are all these ideas of even
developing fan shattering the light
Squad Bishop to B7 and I'm eyeing that
G2 Pawn I want to go C5 next and uh
I would be scared as Whitetail I would
be be terrified but then again she still
has more time than he started the game
with it's move 15. he still has over 15
minutes on the clock and look how he's
playing every move instantly this looks
terrifying I would be looking at moves
like a check already uh for black uh
sacrificing but he's got everything
under control he wants to start the
kickback start removing the black knight
from his Camp next and he still is a
pawn up if the white Bishop can move
Knight can move and the white king can
Castle later on it takes three turns to
do that then white will be doing very
well indeed so farouza with only nine
minutes on the clock has to act quickly
you said it was going to be about speed
on the clock today Tanya in this matchup
and already you're right I don't think
we can be surprised anymore we are
having more time on the clock but yes in
this kind of position you really want to
show that confidence to your opponent
because otherwise you get into a lot of
trouble your pieces are not developed
your king is still in the center of the
board things could go wrong really
quickly but he's sending out a signal
that he knows exactly what he's doing
and for alireza that can be a bit of a
mental pressure to deal with yeah I just
want to ask a question Tanya do you
think he's still in opening preparation
or is he bluffing because he has been
known to Bluff occasionally in his
career again upon issue we've seen it
actually in World Championship matches
he continues to play very fast even once
his preparation ends sometimes going
astray there but the speed with which
he's going out now alireza is definitely
not I think we can come to that
conclusion with the amount of time that
he's taken but despite that it feels
like he has combated the position really
well he's taken some good decisions and
kept the momentum up Jana banoshi is
this some crazy world championship prep
is this something that he hasn't used
before David it's so hard to say I'll
tell you one thing it's a position that
I have never seen wow in my chess career
and we're in move 17 so how long will
opening prep usually last how many moves
will it you know on average your opening
prep be yeah I mean if if you're made
opening prep ends will move three or
four then you're on your own freestyling
but these top players especially in very
forcing lines we would call this quite a
direct opening attempt because already
back on move I have six white was
creating threats white one upon and both
sides need to know what to do if you're
sacrificing a pawn in the opening you
want to have looked deeply into the
ideas the plans the exact move orders if
you're grabbing a pawn and if you're
putting your pieces on ugly squares like
White's Queen then you need to know and
that's a check it's a sacrifice
it's a big check David it's one that you
need to recapture because it's not just
a check it's a fork on the board and
it's all uh based on the black queen on
E6 lined up against that white King on
E1 if white does Recapture with that
pawn on C2 black simply takes it back
and uh wins the bishop but the entire
tactical Skirmish and the sequence of
winning the material back it might just
ease off the pressure for white uh less
pieces on the board less pieces to
develop this is true for example now if
white develops I'm not sure exactly how
uh whoa I was gonna say the most natural
move on the board would be to move the
Knight just to get uh the opportunity to
Castle next but black does not take this
bishop this is for Asia's trick he will
not take this bishop and go for a queen
trade where the pressure would dissipate
as Tanya points out once the Queens come
off uh it's just going to be roughly
level white still upper Pawn but black
with the bishop pair instead he would up
the ante up the pressure by bringing his
Bishop out piling on to this poor pinned
piece and wow I think this could be high
stakes already this would work out in
Black tax favor white would be utterly
paralyzed here so I thought we might
have to ask the engine what is White's
move to survive the most natural move
developing would backfire instantly he's
walking a tightrope he really is and the
idea that you pointed out of black
actually not just recapturing
immediately but doubling down on that
pain with that bishop move to A6 is what
needs to be combated here uh yeah with
twice the amount of time on the clock
and David this might be just we'll see
the bar maybe just shoot right down but
what if I sidestepped the pin I go King
to D1 and what I what I really want to
do is force you to take that Bishop now
and then the idea of taking it back with
the queen Queens come off the board I'm
feeling happy
yeah it's on the botanya you called it
you predicted it uh we did briefly see
the engine moves and it did say if we
backtrack that Knight to A4 was actually
White's best with an advantage but that
is counter-intuitive not obvious the
idea would have been to trade off these
dark squared Bishops instead he goes for
your uh more natural move there Tanya
King to D1 uh very logical and black
will be forced to take alireza debating
whether he can go for something else but
no he does Recapture the piece White's
still a pawn up that was just a
temporary kind of uh sacrifice there
from black but the Queens are coming off
and that's the main factor in this
position we will head towards a
queenless middle game where black has
open Bishops still looks very pleasant
at least in Practical terms but white
does have something to suffer for
something to cling on to the extra pawn
and what you really want to do is now
continue with the idea of developing
that Queen side Knight to A3 bring the
Rook to C1 uh try to finish development
connect your Rooks and hope that your
extra Pawn will count but with the
double Bishop I think time is of the
ascent and Jana Bangla is sensing that
do not have to make these natural
looking move instead goes Full Throttle
he wants to land that night on C5
threatening the bishop not just the
bishop the Knight will also jump on
further on the board on E6 and
eventually destroy the bishop bear that
we that's a big compensation for black
yeah I think that's a really logical
move just getting rid of the bishop pair
immediately and often that's just what
you need to do sometimes the kind of
play gets wild gets crazy once the dust
settles then you look at the Strategic
factors and now napoleonishi he's just
simply doing a bit of uh counting he's
saying I'm one Pawn up I'm going to
trade as many pieces as possible long
term uh that pawn will make uh well it
will count
yeah who do you think is Happy of the
two right now it's got to be yarn right
uh he's got this extra Pawn the Queens
are off the board he is neutralizing
Black's Bishop Bear right now and there
we see it it comes off it's just all
about one more move for white David get
that night out get that route to the C
line get the other route to the e-line
uh I think it's the kind of position
where white is playing for two results
or am I being too harsh for a blonde
Black's position I think you might be
right unless we see niponishi go really
astray uh kind of play some inaccurate
moves it does feel like he's the one
playing for a win like just fighting for
the draw if black can win a pawn back
for example this game might fizzle out
um I did see a moment ago as well on the
chat we uh saying that the fried liver
is not a world championship opening but
I think it might be something he's had
obviously for a while uh often these top
players in the world we've seen Magnus
do it they have slightly unsound
openings or openings that are slightly
dubious for must win situations and this
is just a tune game match it's not must
win yet but napometry clearly taking
risks and also let's not forget that in
the world championship you always want
to have these options in Your Arsenal
the match can often go into tie breaks
into faster time formats and to be able
to surprise your opponent even if you
don't end up using it you've definitely
looked at these ideas and we often see
that happen at top level chess you
prepare it for one event and then end up
playing 10 years later yeah and then
you've forgotten everything all the
details I've had that many times in my
career I once played a novelty I'd been
saving up for six years the problem was
I couldn't remember I knew that was the
right move like three moves later I was
like oh what did my notes say what have
I studied before and it went a bit wrong
so that's how chess works that is how
chess works but the speed with whichiana
is playing it looks like he is familiar
and remembers a little bit but I also
really like how Ali Reza is uh coming
out for that compensation we've been
talking about white having to finish
development but we're doubling up on the
d-line he makes sure that that doesn't
happen now the Knight on B1 is stuck
defending that D2 Pawn the Rook on H1 is
stock defending the H4 Pawn so not that
easy for Yan to detangle and he goes for
a very direct approach yeah I think
Tanya it uh it's linked to this second
idea you mentioned he just wants to free
up his Rook black now of course blocks
the king side he doesn't want to allow
this Rook to get active uh vertically so
it's going to activate itself across the
board there we go Rook to E1 now he's
freed up his piece very logical and he's
also created and fixed a Target this is
why the players just in the last few
years kind of since the dawn of alpha
zero they've been pushing their Rook
spawns they realize that these are
potential Queens watch out for white
spawn to become really strong later in
the game if its counterpart disappears
but stupid question why didn't they take
the Palm why did he yeah one step ahead
instead not a stupid question to talk
higher uh I guess just dynamically here
after Pawn takes Pawn Rook takes the
white Rook is suddenly active and it's a
double attack you can't save both so the
only way to keep material intact was to
kind of bypass but you're right it's
always a dilemma whether to allow allow
this Pawn to live and now he might
regret that later on so a big decision
there actually Pawn takes porn would
have been
objectively fine too and here we see
the Black Knight drop back he's trying
to come in to the heart of White's
position but still takes a couple of
moves it
takes and it really does invite white to
jump in with that Rook to E6
and only hitting that eight six Pawn but
the other one that you're highlighting
as well David and this might Force black
in order to defend both of them to
actually trade off one pair of Rooks but
as white you'd be super happy to get
that because then you're freed up on the
queen side to develop the Knight but
instead of that
Yan has another approach he doesn't go
for Rook to E6 but just Falls a little
shot with Rook to E5 and he's targeting
the F5 Pawn instead once again I think a
move like Rook D5 if you trade a pair of
Rooks white is really happy because it
eases off the pressure on the d-line on
the D2 Pawn yeah exactly for example if
you push this Pawn now white is unable
to bring the Knight forward as Tanya's
mentioning because of Rook take spawn so
keeping both Rooks as a battery is
essential right now
and uh okay he's thinking what else
could he try he tries Rook to F4 instead
of Pawn to F4 attacking this straggler
and suddenly the threat to building
feels like Black's active pieces more
than compensate the deficit and uh yeah
still just really accurate play from
both sides do you think rookie five was
a mouse slip and he intended to go to E6
possible whoa nice move diving in Behind
Enemy Lines with the black Bishop here
actually lots of Pawns on light squares
Kaya you mentioned earlier why not take
that white Pawn off the board maybe he
wants to go round and win a kind of
zigzag with the black Bishop when all
these pawns on light squares now really
clever move I think the publishing
missed this one I did
but I I'm still thinking about it David
because rookie five Rook F4 is a move
that you do look at and I'm still
wondering if Yan actually intended to
put that Rook to the more natural Square
which is one step ahead on E6 because
now black has all these direct threats
uh it looks like white is actually going
to end up losing one Pawn on the king
side you can't hold four to that at
least one pawn and suddenly it's kind of
swung so earlier we were talking about a
two result game white with the win or
maybe a draw if things go wrong Suddenly
It's black who's getting optimistic and
white has to be really accurate to keep
the balance
I'm not seeing it and you can see in the
body language and I promise you as well
struggling a bit kind of confused after
this last few moves what a game and uh
Fairuza he is about to take under five
minutes on the clock I do have an update
on uh stuff going on in division two in
the Champions chess or some really
important games happening there Federal
save is now up by two points in the
Winner's semi-final against Serana and
note that if he wins that match it means
Levon aronian is eliminated from the
contention to qualify for Toronto so
he's probably following that match the
vonoronian
looks like it's going to be a great day
for fedsev wow he's been a top form fair
to say if of course he was heartbroken
not to make it to division one he was
really close but Anish uh kind of pipped
him to the post just got that spot and
pressure on plays like napoleonishi now
they might need to win division one in
order to make it to those finals if
fedes keeps his run going yeah that's a
big fish he's playing in a big pond
right now and he's playing big chess
right now because he did take down
Vincent kaima yesterday as well but his
path is clear for any shot to make it to
Toronto Fantasia now has to win division
too wow he needs those 50 tour points to
have a chance uh but for that he also
needs results to go his way in division
one yeah
this is the final tournament before the
tour finals that will happen in Toronto
in December a lot of players are still
fighting to bank their spots in those
tour finals and what's happening with
the yarn is like oh it's a room service
again mosquitoes or mosquitoes
I bet he's just unhappy with his
position in the last couple of moves and
how this is turned around uh it's
definitely frustrating because he gets
the kind of opening prep that you're
hoping for in this format you get your
opponent to burn the clock you get them
into unfamiliar territory you're
blitzing out your moves you're putting
on that pressure mentally and again I
know I keep saying this David but I am
still very unsure about what we just saw
in the last move with rookie 5 or rookie
six chat get invested what do you think
was that a mouse slip did he mean to go
with the Rook uh on that more dangerous
and more natural looking spot yeah I
think we might have to ask him later
Tanya uh it could have been a turning
point because suddenly we see the bar
drop it's going in Black's favor and it
might continue to do that it's the type
of position that could spiral out of
control if uh Jan here isn't careful and
he plays Pawn to G4 he's just trying to
trade off
oh I'm not happy and the polls are
starting to disappear look how weak they
are white king side pawns now on those
light squares easy pickings for the
black Bishop to take with a rook now do
you go hunting with your Bishop
so many attempting options and and what
you pointed out earlier right Gaia with
white fixing that King side H Bond on H5
it looked really strong when he did it
but with the turnarounds of the last few
moves these two pawns are going to
become clear targets for alireza it's
the kind of position that's now a lot
easier to play as black than it is for
white notice how White's Knight and Rook
on the Queen's side still haven't made a
single move in the entire game uh things
have gone wrong for a while very wrong
and the problem is for example after
maybe the most natural move Bishop to H3
I mean once One Drops the other one's
guaranteed to fall and while you're
ready uh kind of while you're trying to
make amends for your lack of development
okay he does play it bringing the Knight
out black can just Feast black and snack
and look at this there's actually checks
against the white king as well this King
not safe despite the fact it's an end
game
I think this one
okay the bar is still almost in the
middle slightly on black side but this
one could really go wrong uh if no
problem she's not careful he brings his
Knight forward and the question is do
you go back with a check do you take the
spawn he's fighting at least white has
two proud Knights now on outposts uh at
least two good pieces do somewhat save
the position
94 was really required because you need
to defend that D2 Pawn so that when when
this check arises you can actually move
with your king to that B2 Square which
has been navigated by that night jump
also defending that critical Pawn uh the
reason Jan did not decide to uh the
reason that alireza decided not to take
that H5 Bond David I think was because
the Rook could shift up and you end up
winning one of the 8-6 or the C6 Pawn
but I think alireza is getting ambitious
now uh he feels it he feels the shift in
momentum and I think he's going for more
than just a draw yeah he has to shift up
the pace at least with which he's been
playing three minutes against eight
minutes and this I this other idea you
alluded to there Tanya Rook to E6 it's a
double attack chess is sometimes simple
like one of my first coaches said chess
is just double attacks it's just tricks
and tactics and uh I don't agree with
that I agree that's more but uh when it
comes down to it those are the kind of
most Elementary tactics that often
decide games when you just go for a fork
for example pins skewers those types of
things and white did have this double
attack temporarily sacrificing a piece
gave a check won a pawn and now it's
level material yet again and black has
the more active Rooks that's the one
thing in his favor but a bit less time
on the clock and material disappearing
very fast and black also has to watch
out for that 8-6 weakness do not let
whites Rook to actually get to that King
Side Pawn because uh once again uh that
white Pawn on H5 can become a Target so
you have to be careful but Jan's Rook on
A1 still trying to get into the game
yeah but now under three minutes for
alireza
how do you sort of uh put those two up
against each other yarn with uh just an
inactive Rook
alireza with that very little time on
his clock
so I would take the better position
rather than the time just because I'm a
time travel addict and alireza he's
super fast on the clock anyway but uh
yeah it's definitely been a case of uh
the clock haunting him in past events
alireza farouza we've seen him struggle
in positions where the clock has been
ticking down here just because of the
lack of pieces means that he's unlikely
to blunder
so that's one thing
that he's he can feel optimistic about
black snake can come in now maybe the
Black Knight can come in now and the and
it does David as you pointed out he does
start with a check and white King has to
stay connected not only to the C3 Knight
but the C4 Pawn as well so expecting him
to step that up to B4 and then black
will have the option to give another
check with the Knight getting it towards
the center of the board I've been
talking about the big Target but before
I say anything Jan decides a completely
different approach yeah and uh those
double attacks strike again both of
White's pawns now Black's not attacking
one Pawn blacks Rook attacking another
Pawn one of them is doomed how is Yan
gonna compensate here you cannot go
passive you have to go active there we
go he finally brings that Rook to life
party in the corner is over as a
Firebird is uh writing on the twitch
chat yeah and you made a really good
point Kaya about balancing the clock
versus the position but I think I agree
with David on this one that because
there are such few pieces and the play
is easier that actually for black to
have this active rook and to win that
age five Bond I think we'd all want to
be black right now any day all day okay
so that phrase again it's a two result
game if white plays really well uh
probably it's going to be a draw but
black shouldn't really lose this unless
something crazy happens two result game
we all know what happened last time we
used that phrase
commentators cast
and uh okay he is a pawn up and two
connected past pawns are extremely
valuable you always want your pawns
connected not split so if the Rooks ever
disappear black is just guaranteed to
win this game uh those two black H uh h
g pawns will just March down the board
happily so white keeping his remaining
hope alive he's got a pass point of his
own it's uh so did that potentially win
him in the game yeah it could but it is
going to be blockaded by the Black
Knight so uh White would love for
example that a pawn to just shift over
and uh connect but here we go white is
getting active it's a race I want
predictions here guys because this is
such a it's sort of like the ending
where you've got few pieces but to me
draw is the least likely outcome uh
White has got to try to create Chances
with that c Pawn as you pointed out Kaya
with the G and the H1 also looking
dangerous uh David if you have to
predict right now what's the end in this
one I'll say draw did I steal your
answer
I'll say that just because I'm slightly
nervous about the clock I've got half an
eye on the clock here and uh for faruga
it's not so easy White's got this
perfect centralization White Knight
Superior to its counterpart Black's
night stuck on the edge uh on a limb
there white king is coming towards the
middle and Black's Pawn still take a
while to run without the support of
Black's Knight it's not gonna be easy
how about you Tanya oh my gosh I really
like the extra Pawn I like the connected
passes on the king side and I would I
would think this would be decisive in
alireza's favor but I look at that one
and a half minute on his clock and of
course we all know what can happen in
time scramble including the world number
one missing a mid in three so crazier
things have happened I'm expecting a
decisive result in this one okay just
don't ask me who's favored anymore
yeah King C6 he's forced the opponent's
king to a better Square here in
napoleonishi
um earlier we talked about his strengths
and weaknesses he's very intuitive of
course he's so naturally gifted and
talented but occasionally he rushes in
six and a half minutes this feels like
the moment to just sit on your hands
calculate and kind of force your kind of
use uh just kind of calculation here to
force the draw force the issue yeah and
that's so interesting what you say it
because very often Yan's biggest Trend
which is his speed often becomes his
biggest weakness as well sometimes he
just rushes those critical moments and
those critical decisions and those are
the ones that separate a draw from a win
or a draw from A Loss so he's got to be
a little careful on using time at the
right moment as well yeah and I think he
used his time wisely there he's going
hunting for Black's g-pawn uh the more
pawns he can remove the closer he gets
to that draw I think your point is
really uh kind of important there Tanya
everyone's biggest strength can
occasionally be their weakness I know
that my strengths may be uh kind of they
accentuate my weaknesses because I love
end games too much I forget that
sometimes middle games you can go for it
you can go for an attack and I know a
lot of the top players alireza maybe
just being so Dynamic so kind of gifted
at attacking sometimes he forgets that
he needs to do other things too often
it's a double-edged sword yeah I think
David's biggest strength is every
commentator's biggest weakness because
that's 200 games
happening
like a Grandmaster exactly it is a check
and well it was a check it's another
check now and the problem here for black
is where to run where to hide the king
your temporarily two pawns up but white
does have the opportunity to come and
take black g-pawn with his Rook
do you take it now you really have to
evaluate these Rook component games
Tanya that's the hardest thing to do
often but at this point do you want to
keep your king safe or do you want to
actually use it for attacking I think
black is happy to use it it's been kind
of pushed to the edge of the board which
isn't great the black king kind of wants
to be over near the other side because
the only potential winner is Black's H
porn that's still a pawn up but with
your king kind of on the opposite flank
does look like this shouldn't be enough
to win
yeah if black could kind of magically
teleport his King over uh to kind of
swap the black king and Rook round then
good winning chances
yeah there is this traditional chess
wisdom right King is a piece in the end
game and you've got to use it like one
uh for new newer chess audience uh
opening middle game is all about keeping
your king safe but when the pieces are
off the board you have to assist your
pawns you have to assist your other
pieces uh for that activity and right
now alireza is the one with the active
King but it feels like it's not going to
be enough with that white Rook on the
fourth rank the black pawn will not be
able to march uh too much ahead right
now he gets in with even more activity
probably The Rook will slide too
what's happening here what's happened
here that's the most natural move in the
position Rooks belong behind past bonds
maybe that was a chance for Black's King
to get active now the white king blocks
off the black king I think far Asia with
more time would have brought the black
king in and uh we'll see him try to do
that now let's just jump back there was
one critical moment and it was here a
big blunder by napometry rushing with
still six minutes on his clock and here
at furusia with more time would have
found the move King to A4 hiding from
the from the checks this Pawn acts as
good shelter and next move you're
guaranteed pretty much to come and win
this white Pawn if white tries to block
off with the King now it's just checked
away and the black king will make
inroads and will win suddenly you'll
have two extra pawns as black and he
would have won this game but no time on
the clock he gave a check and suddenly
White's King was able to block off and
we call this the opposition where a king
kind of shoulders off uh its opponent's
king and yeah suddenly no way in look at
the current position Black's King's
still all the way here back passive on
B5 wow you said it on our clocks would
be decisive in this matchup it already
is and not only from Oliver's outside
but also from yand right where we spoke
about his biggest Trend becoming his
biggest weakness rushing in with Rook at
7 which is actually the move that I was
suggesting as well because it's just
such a human move on the board and Jan
played it in less than two seconds and
immediately we saw it was the biggest
and probably the only losing move in the
situation wow yeah that can happen
it's such a hard game you can't play by
general rules all the time normally we
say we preach Brook's behind passports
just do it but you have to time it
correctly and yeah with more time on the
clock for Asia for sure would have found
that
he's also going for a logical plan here
alireza he's pushed the black pawn the
black apron as far as it can go he's
fixed a weakness White's a pawn will
mean that the white king is kind of
stuck on this side of the board and
Black's King is going to slowly try it
and go the other direction
still an uphill struggle here Tanya
still far from a draw it's not going to
be easy and I think one of the defensive
ideas that you have to have is the rank
checks with the Rook once a black skin
and I don't know if you can show it with
arrows but once the black king assists
the h-bond let's say lands on the G line
uh you've got to start giving checks
from the third rank the second Rank and
the and the first rank if Black's King
finds safety on that H1 square and can
assist the H4 Bond things can get really
nasty for white yeah you have to check
from the side here and he's going to try
and do that he's keeping the BlackRock
honest meanwhile but oh he's keeping the
black Rook on the third rank but the
Black Brook now has got out of the way
of the H Pawn
I think he's gonna win this version yeah
I just have a feeling it's momentum
black seconds just with seven seconds
the key is his plan is so simple it's
not clear what white can do in the
meantime but black is just going to
bring there we go he makes a mistake and
now the a pawn is dropping black can
just give a check why didn't he go and
take the other white Pawn
I'm the clock is used maybe it is the
clock Wow Let's just show this black did
have an opportunity just for a move and
it was the most natural reply white
played King to D2 black could have just
given a check it's a skewer the king
moves out the way you take another pawn
and uh here you're just winning you're
gonna March down the board and whites
Rook cannot keep an eye on both of these
two black horns instead let's catch up
with the game
still looks very very scary for white in
the current position but
okay some drawing chances because the
white king now has made its way I was
going to say over towards the uh black H
Pawn
so many twists and turns here and I
think we're gonna continue uh but the
good news for Jan is that he's managed
to actually get his King all the way
across uh towards that H Pawn and now I
don't see a path for black skin to
actually roll down across the board and
assist that each his own H bond anymore
and we see white coming in attacking
that Rook eventually you can give up the
A2 Pawn as long as you're winning the H3
Pawn aha
yeah you need to keep an eye on both of
Black's pawns right now but he's done
everything correctly here in the
publishi kicking his head though he's
got to use these four minutes he's been
rushing he's been trying to hustle
Alaris on the clock and it's kind of
worked but he's taking huge risks and he
hasn't found a drawing plan yet he's
been playing like he's the one with 10
seconds on the clock
just so fast and the good news for him
is that alireza hasn't had enough time
to capitalize on the mistakes that he's
been making
now alireza is being clever with his
King he's actually looking the other
side of the board now he's looking at
that remaining white Pawn at some point
he's gonna he's gotta time it correctly
the black Rook is going to give up on
the H Pawn he's going to go for the a
pawn and run with the black king as fast
as possible to support uh his own Pawn
pushing there it might be the moment now
okay first he delays he inches closer
towards that white Pawn
I like that he's bringing the king
closer before taking the committal
decision of trading of these two pawns
because you need your king as close as
you can get to that A2 Pawn I still
think we're going to see some kind of
rank defense and rank checks uh by white
at the critical moment
he's got to keep pressure on that H3
Pawn just to make sure that blacks oh no
that is we call it the vancura position
it's well-known endgame Theory Tanya you
called it
reaction this was elementary right
you've got to make sure that Black's
Rook remains stuck on that Airline
defending the A3 Pawn now blacks Rook is
out of the way uh the pawn is no longer
uh kind of stifled and the pawn is just
gonna come down Black's King is going to
go across kick away the white rook and
game over white king is just too far
away it's off in Siberia somewhere not
able to participate in the defense David
how do you explain that again one of the
best players in the world with three
minutes on the clock
it's hard just complacency
it's not sensing the moment the critical
moment and like you said Tanya that is
endgame Theory that's end game 101
um in the Russian School of Chess they
would have taught this he knew this
position of course he did but three
minutes that was the moment to stop and
think and we'll show this uh a bit later
on where Yan could and should have been
able to force the draw in a very
well-known way
the vancura position search at anyone at
home if you're curious against these
Rook porns how to stop them from the
side but here Black's King is just
coming in Black's King is going to just
slowly walk its way to B1 next to the
black pawn and it will cost white his
Rook game over
yeah he had the draw in his grasp for so
long
but that wasn't the only moment he led
his lip that wasn't the only moment he
rushed it was kind of symptomatic of the
whole uh whole game here and I think it
was symptomatic of yesterday as well
what we saw against the Magnus Carlsen
missing his chances in that big uh game
three it was when he played this
fantastic Rook sacrifice got that queen
versus Rook but in the end it was enough
I think it was game four actually and
we're seeing sort of similar signs I
wonder if it's fatigue because he's just
fresh out of that levitov event where
he's played in Amsterdam it's been a
tough event and he's been fantastic
Chester but this is this is shocking
yeah this is a real surprise and the
white Rook has to stop the black porn
from marching but now the black king
slowly comes around and I think we'll
see Yan resign any moment now a simple
two move plan yeah
how impressed are you guys with doing
this with for such a long time seconds
on his clock in there we have it it's a
win in game one for veruga I lost four
Jan palmyachi they will have a little
bit of time now before game two starts
in the losers quarterfinals this is game
one between Geary and mom jaro I've been
seeing the bar going up and down up and
down and now it's up for a niche what's
happening uh wow we've jumped in a
dramatic moment and it looks like Anish
is going to take the win King opponent
game but black was ahead in the race won
a pawn next move whites King has to give
way again the opposition white is in zuk
Swang and black will just take the G4
pawn and uh soon make a new Queen Gary
using his endgame technique ah on fire
Anish Geary knocked out tikara Nakamura
yesterday and starting the day today
with a win against the entertaining Mama
diaro one more rapid game to go and the
losers scored finals for these two he
will have to make a comeback mom darov
and take it to Arma get on to have any
hope of saying in the AI cup we jumped
in when this game was ending David could
you just take us a little bit through
what happened there and how Anish got
that win yeah and I'll just highlight
one moment where the transition into
that King and Paul name game that Majora
didn't have time to calculate it and he
should have just kept pieces on the
board here white still has good drawing
chances in this position if he moves his
King towards the black pawn still an
uphill struggle the Black Knight might
get active jumping around but uh good
drawing chances instead he gambled he
played Bishop takes Knight and here we
see the evaluation bar drop and this is
one for everyone at home King and porn
games are the trickiest the margin for
error is so small and look at what
happened to the white King was forced to
go and take a pawn but it was pushed to
the edge of the board and Black's King
just nearer the pawns it won the race
and soon it came in and uh there we go
here resigned King takes G4 is coming
next and one no longer stem the tide
all right and it uh gives Anish giri the
lead in this match against the mama Jara
we did follow the first game between
otherwise of Russia and Jana pulmonachi
so much happening in that one and with
the seconds on the clock for a long uh
period of that game furuja saved the win
and could we take a look at that as well
David how did he get that win or maybe
how did Nepal lose it yeah and uh this
is going to be end game class with David
Howell because hey this is a well-known
theoretical position white actually
already has the perfect setup if you
just Retreat your Rook to F3 here you
keep an eye on the black pawn keep it
under lock and key more importantly you
paralyzed the Black Rock you do not let
the black Rook out from the front of
this pawn and as soon as the black king
moves over you start checking it as soon
as the black king defends this Pawn you
check from the side and you check
forever Black's King has nowhere good to
hide just keeping an eye on this Pawn
from the side would have clinched the
draw instead of retreating his rook and
upon Rishi moved his King and suddenly
after Rook to B2 there was nothing to be
done as we saw in the game the pawn was
too strong and more importantly Black's
King was just in time to block off the
white king making its way round and the
black pawn about to promote
and that's how you do it Ah that's how
you win the chess game now these are the
results from the first set of games and
losers quarterfinals a win for varuja
and a win for Anish Geary both of them
taking the lead in their matches
all right you guys
uh we have to tell you something we
don't want you guys to
sit on
through the end of this month claim up
to 30 on all new Subs on Twitch
subscribers gain access to exclusive
break time content during broadcast and
score an ad free experience on chess.com
so don't miss out on the deals this
September Please Subscribe now we're
gonna take a break and when we come back
well the action continues it's must win
situation for Mom diarov and for
napoleonchi thank you
foreign
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things hey everybody it's Danny here and
as you may know chess.com and chessable
are now one and I'm here to show you how
you can make your chest.com and
chessable one in just a few clicks to
start let's log in and connect our
chess.com account I just scroll right
here above the browser and click log in
scroll down and click continue with
chess.com now if you're already logged
into chess.com it's just gonna ask you
if you want to approve that connection
I'm going to say yes sir but after
approving it'll bring you right back to
the chessable home page now the puzzle
connect feature can be found under Tools
and you click puzzle Connect Now what
that does after you type in your
username is it's going to pull positions
from the games you've played on
chess.com create your very own
personalized chessable course and then
quiz you with the positions where you
may have missed the best move and the
more you play on chess.com the more
games it will have to quiz you as long
as your account stays connected it's
pretty sweet and it's going to help you
get better learning from the mistakes in
your games yes this is a pro feature
accessible but if you go to
chessable.com link you can get 30 days
of pro for free
all right we are getting ready for some
dramatic games here in the AI cup and uh
we're also excited to announce uh at
this tournament that chest.com is
partnering with the browser maker Opera
we're thrilled about the collaboration
it's something for chess lovers
everywhere it truly puts the game right
on your fingertips no matter where you
are it looks super cool this browser
this chess browser by Oprah and maybe
someone using it is uh Anish Gary he is
very much known for his opening
preparations he's known for his tweeting
which also happens online obviously but
let's get to know Anish giri a little
bit better
born in Russia Saint Petersburg to
father from Nepal and mother from Russia
my parents met in Russia because there
was a program where they would invite a
lot of foreign students from different
countries and Nepal was one of them so
it's not entirely accidental but my
father from Nepal I studied in Russia
living in Russia and with two
grandparents Who Loved chess and Niche
giri was bound to start playing chess
but it was a book that got him hooked on
the game my mother taught me when I was
little I didn't really learn it very not
immediately at least also I don't know
how patient she was at teaching me
but eventually I received a book as a
gift when I was six I believe and the
book was called how to become a
gentleman and there are many chapters uh
of course science those who know me well
no I skipped all the chapters and went
straight for the chest so I didn't
become a gentleman but I do know how to
play chess
when he became better than his mother
she did something clever and maybe that
is the reason Anish is known for his
confidence today my mother tricked my
chess club so I learned from from the
book and then I played a lot with my mom
and only when she thought it was too
much and she no longer could spend so
much time playing me then she gave me to
the club and by that point I was already
well perhaps stronger than her but what
she told to my club teacher was that I'm
a complete beginner I only know the
rules and they put me in the lower
section and I won everything
and it continued like this for a very
long time so I kind of had like a head
start and I just was reading everything
from the start yeah it's great so I know
exactly what Magnus feels like nothing
special but it's not all fun and games
for a niche he is one of the most
hard-working players in chess
if I had to do something which I
wouldn't love I don't think I would be
as hard working and as disciplined as I
am with chess so probably my passion for
the game is my main strength of course I
would love to become a world champion
but
you have to definitely be a fortunate
and well you have to do everything you
can and be fortunate so I'm doing my
part I hope the fortune will smile
a little bit of Fortune but also some
great chess playing in HQ is in the lead
here in the losers quarterfinals against
chakra and that means he will have to
win game two and he's definitely capable
we're gonna go down memory lane to the
last season of the Champions chess store
when Mama diaro played what he has
called the best game he has ever played
you know I heard rumors that was
incredible by Mom and you're winning
against Geary oh my God
WoW shark is having full fun here what a
game
not the game of the tournament this is
the game of the Champions Chester soccer
Rook I'm the queen in one game uh we'll
just show all the highlights just the
action where he made the sacrifices in
this position white is trying to attack
against the black king first he
sacrificed a rook for a night giving up
material here getting active with his
Queen if we fast forward a few more
moves we see Anish trying to attack and
uh this next sacrifice is here giving up
his Knight giving up his night just for
just a pawn to distract The Black Queen
away from defending the seventh Frank
next he sacrificed his Bishop giving up
his Bishop for a pawn and uh okay there
is a pin so this is just a temporary
sacrifice but the key detail was here
bringing his Rook across and now giving
a check with his Pawn I think this is
what Anish giri had missed because when
the king's sidesteps now white can give
up his Queen for the black Bishop if the
king inside step the other way this
would have been Checkmate trapped in the
corner and uh by giving his Queen up for
the bishop he simply ensures a new queen
and the Final Touch was this night check
hitting the black king the king can't
defend his Rook any longer if it steps
forward this is deadly a rook check and
let's just show the final few moves
capturing and simply stepping back with
his not securing his own king after all
of those sacrifices White's actually a
pawn up and next move there's going to
be a deadly check or two what a game
maybe
just kind of because really I sacrificed
his first form after that now again
after Queen I've taken foreign
that's just incredible you guys were
counting so five sacrifices in one game
that was incredible we were commentating
at that I think I've for me it's
probably the most beautiful game that I
have ever seen it's inspiring chess it's
one for the history books it reminded me
of all the mccarthal games that we've
grown up in and chakra just needs to
remember that for now before he also has
to forget what just happened yeah
definitely
it's going to be must win or
janapomyachi
in the game is about to start two
players will have to win here to take it
to Armageddon with a drawer when fuja is
through to tomorrow's losers semi-finals
here we go here we go it's a Sicilian
Defense both players in must win
situations will start with black so it's
going to be an uphill Challenge and
we've seen this various times throughout
the tour uh already or throughout this
tournament the AI Club Tanya Bishop B5
checks Sicilian and it's a great
approach right when you need just to
draw to wrap up the match you don't want
any fights in open Sicilian no long
theoretical battles of the night off
where you can come under Fire really
quickly so Bishop B5 a really uh
systematic approach here by alireza and
Ian shaking his head I think he was
hoping for a bigger fight a more open
opening I think for Yan it's not just
that he lost the last game David but
everything was going his way right he
gets the opening preparation that he's
looking for uh he gets the clock
advantage that he's looking for he's got
that extra Pawn and then even having a
draw in his hand it all falls flat and
in the end letting it all go with that
one more blunder and that's the thing
Jan can't be in his own head too much he
needs to let go of the past I know it's
difficult to do it's very natural to
dwell on those mistakes especially when
you're just one move away from a draw in
a kind of theoretically drawn position
but he needs to forget he it cannot be a
repeat of these World Championship
matches where he's uh somehow just stuck
and unable to be present in the moment
uh we see him shaking his head there and
that's a bad sign yeah game six of the
21 match it was a complete collapse so
after that and that's a really
interesting point you make do you think
Jan his personality and just his
competitive Spirit do you think that is
a challenge for him psychologically to
kind of just step away from what has
happened and not let it get into his
mind space I think that's his biggest
challenge psychologically
um I've known him from when we were very
young and yeah it's it's been a case
it's been a recurring theme and I know
he worked on that actually a lot his uh
mental state his psychology before the
20 21 World Championship but
unfortunately things went wrong for him
there as well and okay at least he has
all the pieces on the board he's
achieved step one in this game you can
never Bank on an Advantage with the
black pieces in the opening against such
Elite opposition but he's done step one
keep pieces on the board keep tension
hope for an imbalance or two later on
whether that's a different kind of
Bishop for knight uh imbalance whether
that's kind of a strange Pawn structure
and he might get chances later Alo razor
clearly spending a bit more time in the
opening what do you think Tanya of
course solid stuff by white but now
opening things up opening things up and
this also means that that bishop and G7
the fan cutter Bishop for black can
become a powerful piece in the middle
game so we are going to get some form of
an open Sicilian with a double fan
cutter for Jana Palmer she the Bishop
from C8 will at some point land on B7
and uh you're an advocate of these types
of positions I believe we've talked
about hedgehogs before and that type of
uh Pawn structure Tanya who would you
pick here or what would the plans be for
you decide I do like these positions
from black I think there's a lot to uh
play for as black a lot of plans uh
keeping the flexibility in the position
I would want to go shark Castle bring
that Bishop from C8 out to B7 bring that
Rook on the queen side to the Open Sea
line the knight from D7 can often jump
to C5 start targeting that Central E
Pawn and once again Jan's Back Against
The Wall a must-win situation I think it
is some sort of an opening success to
get this kind of a middle game yeah but
though again we saw him look off to the
side slightly shake his head Yan on the
camera does not look happy at all
despite the fact he's got everything he
had Hope For All from an opening in a
must-win situation but David that
doesn't have anything to do with this
game yeah true it's all about the last
game it's all about that last game and
that's what I was talking about he just
needs to
spicing things up he hits the black
queen and wow Hikaru would call it
rotates with the white knight he
Retreats the White Knight it's going
back into the center though it's a
really rare maneuver Tanya
rare maneuver important game here at
nepo has to make a comeback and so does
mama diaro in the match against Anish
Geary their game two is about to start
so we have to check out what's gonna
happen in this opening we did see in
that video mamadiro with five sacrifices
in one game was able to win the most
beautiful game he ever played and is
that what he needs to do now just play
that kind of Chess he needs to mount
majorov he can also take inspiration
from the fact that his opponent in that
beautiful game was none of them none
other than Anish giri so uh sometimes
whoa the Scandinavian defense in honor
of oh this looks strange it's bizarre if
you haven't played chess before but
there is some logic you've traded off a
set of central pawns uh shout out to
John Bartholomew team scandi this
opening has a cult following but it's
not that popular at the uh kind of top
upper echelons of World Chess just
because you're breaking some rules
you're moving the black queen several
times in the opening it's the scandi
candy and I love it when you're in a
must to win situation now you've got to
take these drastic measures of time
especially a player like shark you
mentioned trying to get the kind of
positions that he did where he had those
five incredible sacrifices to eventually
go on to beat anishkiri but he did have
the white pieces in that one uh here he
plays with black so it's not going to be
as easy a task but I like I like what he
started with already the queen out there
that looks so scary yeah it's a kind of
higher supercharged development here uh
hyperactive pieces here for black the
problem is the queen will lose a bit of
time because she is the most valuable
piece in chess anytime she gets hit by a
pawn a knight a bishop she'll be forced
to run away uh so you do lose a bit of
time later but look at the black pieces
uh unless Anish giri has prepared deeply
here it looks pretty active it does and
all the three pieces that you mentioned
the pawn Knight in Bishop can actually
potentially hit that Queen uh the black
Bishop it does captured the Knight on F3
the bishop jumps in on F3 and I think
that's a nice little tactic that we
should show why it might seem like the
default Pawn is hanging but it's really
not black captures on D4 but you
actually win upon but lose your queen
the bishop jumps in takes the Knight on
C6 and this would be the Intermezzo
tactic that exists so that would be the
bishop attack the queen is also
vulnerable to the other two pieces that
you mentioned David with the C4 Pawn
moving forward gaining more space
hitting the queen and also the knight
from B1 can jump to C3 attacking uh
yeah her highness will need to move at
some point but first anishigiri castles
and uh the big question is whether Shaq
is going to go the other way if he's all
in already he might be tempted to Castle
but first he okay uh shows up the Center
opens up his Bishop black is relatively
flexible here the fact that you've put
your knight on the C6 Square means
you're likely to cause a queen side and
I think we'd love to see that Tanya but
I'm not sure we would recommend it for
players on the black side of this
opening yeah I called it the scandi
candy and I said I love it I would never
play it myself it's one of those
openings that you really enjoy because
you know it's going to be fireworks on
the board but it's a bit terrifying to
play yeah it's terrifying Anish giri
does bring his Bishop out and the reason
it's terrifying is whoa okay I was gonna
say look at all the white pawns throw
themselves towards the black king
manager says okay I'm I'm tired I want
to sacrifice G5 already for black we
talked about five sacrifices in the
previous game against Anish giri from
last year he's already started one this
is a pawn sacrifice if White's bishop or
Knight take the spawn at least open
lines will start to appear against the
white king later it's Shack Attack time
but do you think Anisha is now second
thoughts about actually taking because
he remembers that game
a hundred percent I mean that's a pawn
which in chess we can call it the poison
Pawn in these kind of positions yes you
win upon and you attack Black's night so
you actually went with the temple but
once black simply develops the bishop to
E7 you're giving a clear Target to your
own king of opening up the G line and
whenever you have these opposite side
castling Dynamics you don't want to
allow that so that's just going to be
big danger and talking of that game
David in that one as well chakra versus
a niche shark started with the pawn
sacrifice it was the H Pawn in this one
he starts with a fawn sacrifice it's
Gary the Jeep on Wow and he's got a hook
as well we call it a hook this white
Pawn on H3 because no matter what if
black okay he takes it initial whoa if
black was given the time to push G4 open
lights would have appeared anyway so
giri is saying okay I'm gonna suffer for
something Bishop takes porn and we're
gonna get fire on the board The Rook is
gonna appear on G8 and Anish better
defend carefully he's playing one of the
most gifted attackers of the generation
wow but Kaya you were right because we
see the eval bar it seems to say that
you grabbed upon and you're actually
doing fine from a practical standpoint I
think it would be a very scary decision
but I think David you nailed it that if
you let the pawn stay on the board G4
would not make your life easy but now
there's a direct play for black and for
me I don't care what the valbar says I
would love to be black in this position
me too especially uh learning from mama
joro if this is going to be a real gem
this game uh I wonder whether Anish has
some ideas of trying to simplify in mind
in a situation where he just needs to
draw there we go he pushes his Pawn
forward to D5 it's maybe not the best
move the most principal move it's
actually often trying to give the pawn
back but he's hoping that for example
after a capture white will take back if
black now gets tempted to regain the
material then we'll see everything
disappear off the board the Queens will
disappear and all the attacking
ammunition would disappear from Black's
position this game would likely head
towards a draw
the very best here for black so Anish
just trying to go into defensive move uh
mode
it's a really good point to actually
give back material you give back the
extra Pawn that you have to actually
convert that into a strategic Advantage
the end game that you bought out after
that sequence of moves would just mean
that black sort of ends up in a worse
end game with a broken Pawn structure so
really nicely handled by Anish by
immediately returning the material
hoping uh to get into that advantages
end game where again playing for two
results with white and you only need one
for a niche he only needs a draw
of Tanya do you see any kind of uh
sprinkles of magic dust that Mama
giraffe could hope for here he keeps
pieces on the board but look at that bar
oh the risk he's taking here mama
giraffe in this situation it's huge
you've got to do it right because
otherwise if you trade off everything on
that d-line there is no hope for a win
and uh a loss is as good as a draw here
so shock just has to go all out night
before he's got he's got an idea now he
wants to recapture on D5 without trading
the queens and why is it why does the
bar hit this move so much is it
connected to some Bishop Johnson B5
hitting the queen on D7 David yeah I
think you might be right Tanya there's
various ways we talked about the scandi
queen uh her highness here getting
kicked around in this opening uh Bishop
B5 would Target her also Knight E5 would
Target her Target this Pawn as well
she's actually lacking squares and uh
here for example she cannot move forward
to D6 because white can simply pick up a
whole bunch of material this is a family
Fork here hitting three pieces uh
instead if she Retreats maybe then
you'll move Tanya uh I mean there's so
many attempting options suddenly it
doesn't look like black has any
attacking pieces whatsoever manager of
looking uncomfortable in the camera as
well I think he knows this is a gamble
that will not or should not pay off
suddenly The Black Queen forced okay to
the G file some hope but uh it doesn't
feel like it should be enough Gary
trying to calculate meanwhile so many
tempting moves I think shark is already
looking for a Swindle in this one Kaya
he's just hoping for a miracle he's
gonna take something he's gonna go for
the white king just kind of cross his
fingers and hope the second piece
sacrifice the second piece sacrifice
yeah this could be the be the start uh
we talk about Michael Tyler and all
these great attackers throughout history
there have been some dubious sacrifices
but uh sometimes the gamble pays off and
then it looks beautiful so genius only
with hindsight and obviously both of you
were commentating on that beautiful game
you played against a niche sacrificing
five uh pieces or uh and also a pawn uh
was it anything similar to this did the
bar also jump up for a niche in that one
but Mom Daryl was able to win or did it
always look good for him in that game I
think that was the one big difference in
that one even though the position
stylistically is similar where he did
give up a pawn for compensation against
the opponents against anisha's King but
in that one he was always under control
from the very start now a good opening
and a brilliant attack and uh an
absolutely inspiring finish so in that
aspect I think this one is slightly
different because we see unusual pieces
are more active but some inaccuracy is
there by white yeah a niche playing some
counting intuitive chess here Queen to
H4 putting in the queen the edge of the
board he is attacking Black's Knights uh
especially the knight in F6 now feels a
bit uncomfortable but I think Anish he's
just hoping for all these exchanges uh
something along the lines of what we
discussed earlier Tanya and uh I just
want to mention on that point of
attacking and taking big risks that's
the difference between white and black
when you're white you can choose your
type of position you can attack kind of
from a solid foundation here with black
you have to gamble if you want to go for
the opponent's king sometimes and okay
we see a trade of a couple of pieces
how fiery is this one's still Anish has
some calculation to do you can take back
this bishop in two ways
still feels promising for white because
if you actually compare the Kings
Black's King far far looser than whites
right now but this could turn you could
see a world where suddenly black gets a
move or two and starts going for the uh
white king
yeah it's really good and I think Anish
keeping up the momentum not giving black
the opportunity to take that Rook to the
G line and create all those pressures
with a potential second sacrifice uh
Anish does win a second Pawn but it's
not going to be about pawns this is not
a pawn game chakra is looking for a way
in through that g line Rook G8 is the
one move that he's waiting so time
really is after your stands for Anish he
needs to keep making threats on the ball
he has to make sure that shark doesn't
get enough time to execute that first he
did raise his eyebrows sir maybe he
missed this one Anish giri because it's
a double attack and white is
hard-pressed to actually hold both of
these pieces at the same time uh what's
the theme of the day all these sneaky
double attacks out of the blue sometimes
from nowhere and how does a niche hold
these two pieces I only see one move
David there's only the queen uh I was
gonna say queen C4 but then you can take
Queen G5 the line isn't over he goes for
another idea but similar concept because
it also hits the Knight on D5
centralizes the queen to D4 whichever
piece black takes whether the 9 all the
bishop white aims at picking up the
centralized D5 Knight yeah it's a
counter threat really nice move Gary
he's in the flow I've got to say he had
a really shocking day one where he lost
an apology 3-0 but uh ever since then
he's spotting these tactics quite fast
and he's still got just under nine
minutes uh in this position white is a
pawn up remember and still no attack
Brewing yet against the white king so
he's still in full control it feels like
yeah he's something's really clicked
with Gary usually when he's facing this
type of attack he would be burning a lot
of time on the clock but a sign of his
good form yeah really good form and
that's always uh Chess World is a better
place when Anish is playing like that
I've got to ask you the Toronto finals
are shaping up it's so beautiful I mean
the players who've made it through what
a field we have but there's one uh one
name left to be stand oh do you have a
favorite are you rooting for someone to
make it to Toronto well Anish Gary
obvious is always a fun person to have
around to interview to you know that
they wouldn't be cool if Anish was there
but then yeah the pubniaci is also a
name I could definitely like to see in
Toronto
um who else mom diaro I mean his
entertaining style wow mvl oh it's a
difficult one it's a difficult one but I
mean looking at a niche now I mean it
would be a lot of fun it would be a lot
of fun with him there not just fun on
the board but on Twitter as well if
Anish makes it yeah yeah
you're tweeting he'll be keeping us
entertained but that's the thing this
just only one spot we want all of them
no and also the fact that he actually uh
beat Hikaru in a match yesterday
I mean those two facing then off in
Toronto and Hikaru wanting some Revenge
that would be cool as well yeah how
about you guys
I mean you've named all the players who
can qualify apart from fedexv he's
another one yes yep the big fish but
yeah any of these guys I think would be
uh it would be a real honor to come and
take on their games it would and the
best part is the four names that you
took who are fighting in division right
one right now all of them have this
really entertaining brilliant style of
playing speaking of entertaining Berlin
style of play chakra has just sacrificed
The Rook he's stay tuned to his words
but it's not going to pay off I think he
might just wow he has resigned gave up a
rook it was a gamble but uh maybe just
missing the White Queen could recapture
and Gary takes the win Gary takes the
win he looks surprised there
Geary winning both games here to make it
through to the losers semi-finals
tomorrow what a match he has played now
against mom Daryl but what was up with
Shakira in that final game was he just
giving it his all in that one final
chance yeah he just went in hard he used
the Scandinavian defense and uh
unfortunately it did backfire he gambled
but uh giri just caught the bluff yeah
all right well this is game two with
Jana pomyachi against Alvarez of Russia
and Russia he won the first game nepo he
has to win this one to take it to
Armageddon and have any hope of going
through to tomorrow what are we looking
at here we're looking at a really tense
middle game but Tanya I like Black's
chances we're looking at a completely
different game from what was going on in
the other one and I think one of player
is in a must-win situation and how you
approach that kind of a game really
tells you a lot about their style and
while shock just went all in he went for
that gamble approach as you said David
what Yanda Mama she's doing he's just
wants a game he wants a long game he
wants to keep all the pieces on the
board and he's saying I'm gonna play on
the clock I'm going to try to wait for
my opportunity to present itself rather
than just uh completely gamble on a
tactical Miss I like that approach uh
better and I think it's paying off
yeah exactly sometimes in these must-win
situations you need to play on the
psychology and clearly ferrugia a bit
nervous here
um it's still a fine position for white
but look at the clock uh look at the
time difference again seven minutes down
for Russia in such a complicated
position
um this isn't like that last one where
he was able to keep control because
there were so few pieces left on the
board it was a rook end game so having
three five seconds on the clock was fine
here still most of the major pieces on
and black is threatening a Pawn on A5
white could easily lose control you
could easily lose control you could also
easily just want to give up that Bond
David I'm already thinking about the
F-bomb marching down the board and can
alireza try and get a little ambitious
on the king's side because notice how
all of Black's armies on one side of the
board and I was considering ideas of f4
F5 just breaking through but instead
alireza with a different approach he
does defend the A5 Pawn so he wants to
keep everything under control and not
take unnecessary risk now if black wants
to jump in with the queen let's just
point that out uh it's a simple but big
threat you Advanced upon B3 and because
of the pin you win the Knight yeah you
win a piece and I was going to say the
most valuable uh piece here the MVP of
the position is Black's night normally
we don't say that about Knights on the
edge of the board but it is in White's
camp and it's stuck here it's kind of
fixed here supported by a pawn and it
does mean that there's pressure
constantly against these two points
which are stuck forever kind of tying
down uh paralyzing the white pieces but
yeah farusha finding a nice way to
defend I think if he needed to win this
game for Russia he would have gone for
your idea Tanya he would have gone for
the black king but this one would have
been a gamble with three minutes on the
clock so he's playing solid chess but
will that backfire solidity in such a
kind of Rich position uh
often maybe not the name of the game
sometimes you just have to say Okay I'm
going for the opponent's king and here
how does black improve you want to break
out in the center you want to make sense
of these two black Rooks in the middle
of the board but white will of course
close down the board and this Square
unfortunately covered by two white
pieces so you cannot continue opening
things up Suddenly this black Bishop
would be staring at a wall of its own
pawns and not a happy piece so I don't
think black will Rush with this instead
he pushes the other Pawn maybe with a
view of pushing in the center in future
yeah that was really nicely timed by you
David because in Sicilian black really
wants to get this D5 break in but only
when you can open up your fan cutter
Bishop on B7 if you end up prisoning
itself on B7 then you never want to play
D5 this last move actually stops that
white Pawn from E4 moving forward to E5
D5 is always in the air now and once
that Bishop from B7 is able to come into
the game it's not a bishop it's a sniper
yeah the sniper was putting uh the white
king under so much pressure that the
white king actually moved back to G1 wow
really long distance Vision there but uh
napoleonishi he's keeping the tension
notice how he's playing kind of
non-committal moves he just plays Rook
to D7 very mysterious but he plays it
quickly upping the pace and this is
where the speed can really help him uh
unlike that last game where the speed
cost him the result cost him the whole
point
um here just plain quick moves puts
farooja back under psychological
pressure now it's getting really
dramatic on the clock he needs to speed
up but no planet in sight here for white
have to be really careful and fruition
not liking his position he did just
Grimace slightly and he's feeling
clearly visibly ah kind of uncomfortable
in his position
we were talking about who will make it
to the tour finals in Toronto in
December um I do have an update federal
has won his match against Serana that
means Levon aronian is eliminated from
contention to make it to the finals so
we are down to federal
mvl and giri obviously Shakira are now
knocked out by Gary he is out of
contention so nepo if he loses this much
it's over for him as well he will not
make it to Toronto he is fighting for
his life here he has to win this game do
you guys see chances for him to do just
that I actually do I think with the
black pieces and a must-win situation
the position that he's got the advantage
on the clock that he's got the pieces on
the board and alirez are forced to take
critical decision with less than two
minutes on the clock I think he's got
real chances yeah and upon achie I would
have said he had great chances but this
last move from farusha is a mark of
Genius he pushed his Pawn forward to a
square that was covered three times by
Black's pieces but now he's forcing a
series of Trades and we saw just under
the board there for a moment black only
had one move to keep the balance Jan
naponishi of course finds it but this
move the top engine move sacrificing
white tonight and going after the Black
Knight next he's just clearing the board
clearing the air trading everything off
I said that black knight was Black's
most valuable piece in for Asia I think
in one Fell Swoop there he's
pretty much saved the day it looks much
much more simple now to try and defend
this position than the tense middle game
we had earlier yeah I agree with you
with the trades it looks like the
pressure is neutralized when you're down
on the clock uh general advice try and
get as many pieces off the board as you
can but that said David it's still not
completely over white is threatening
that C4 Pawn white can get black can get
rid of this weakness instantly with the
move C3 forcing you to trade the beef
Pawn for the C Pawn uh and that's it
Queen C3 comes in I can also start
targeting your A5 Pawn at some point
ideas like Rook A5 ideas like Rook D2
still things to play for still yeah the
black queen is more uh active than the
White Queen the black Rooks clearly
better places than the white Rooks on
open files uh the white kind of Bishop
may be superior to the black Bishop
that's the only one downside here for
the end upon Rashi his Bishop not too
great so yeah still definitely some life
here especially this threat looks a bit
scary uh The Rook penetrating
infiltrating on the second rank I'm
expecting him to go for this in the
publishy if you don't push this Pawn
forward I guess the only other
alternative uh logical move would be to
defend the pawn with your Rook also
looks quite tempting but this would give
white time to activate this passive
piece and uh just gang up on Black's
isolated porn so yeah I like what
furridge has done still some hard work
of course ahead but at least now the
clock situation two minutes again seven
minutes slightly less drastic and the
more important thing pieces off the
board simpler position easier to handle
with no time but I'm glad that Nepal has
slowed down he hasn't just blitzed out
his decision uh because very often uh
that decision can go wrong in these
critical moments and it's a critical
moment not because of the position on
the board but the math situation and he
does decide to keep the pawns on the
board the line that you pointed out
David he defends the C4 Pawn the only
reason I didn't like this move was
because of what we're seeing being
played out and now I couldn't really
find the way for black to defend that C4
Pawn C3 runs into I think that might be
his problem Tanya I think he might be
trying to just uh create some chaos even
if it's not best I think he might be
about to should we show that voice is
Queen I I we've got to show that here
white is ganging up three times on this
Pawn with the bishop and with the Rooks
and you can't hold this Pawn much longer
so you either have to move the black
queen out the way or you can push your
Pawn the problem is uh I think that Jan
was banking on Rook takes here and where
he could give up the black queen and we
have this poor this kind of imbalance of
two Rooks for a queen the problem here
is that you don't have coordination
White Queen will jump into the position
hitting this black rook and suddenly
things are collapsing I think maybe Yan
has misevaluated this uh for example if
the black Rook moves and then yeah it's
just not quite enough time White Queen
this is really kind of reminiscent of
Magnus Carlson against janapomnishi from
the 2021 World Championship where it was
Queen versus two Rooks in game six and
the queen uh just not able to fight here
the queen is superior but he doesn't go
for this in the end instead he evaluated
that as strong for white team gives up a
pawn for Russia happy to take the C4
Pawn off the board and everything's
disappearing everything disappearing but
you need to watch out because if you
recapture this Rook with the bishop
trying to hold on to your A5 Bond the
black Rook uh jumps into D1 with a check
you're forced to block the check with
your bishop and David I think I can come
in with a lot of tempting moves but what
I want to do is go Bishop C6 Bishop B5 I
don't know what happens after Rook C4
but it looks really scary with the pin
along the eighth rank as you're pointing
out just move away from this pin and
Bishop B5 which is why white had to
recapture The Pawn With The Rook as Ali
Reza has done but in that bargain he
also gives up the A5 Pawn Yeah he has to
give back his uh extra report in here so
it's level material yet again but he's
just consistently trying to trade pieces
look at this just every move he's
offering a trade he's trying to just cut
out all of the fun kill the game here
for Russia is cynical stuff but it's
effective stuff and he's pure only
playing for the draw the problem is
black has to trade Queens otherwise at
this point in the center will drop with
check and this end game is hard to
imagine black ever winning it's so
symmetrical and uh if anything it's
white with the advantage attacking this
Pawn white ready to infiltrate on the
seventh rank farusha is just doing
everything right here it's very mature
from The Young Frenchman to play like
this to play on the match situation yeah
this is uh version top form
often he gets carried away with
attacking but this is kind of really
objective really kind of precise uh
chess very professional approaches uh
both of you are mentioning are just
trading the Queens right now enforcing a
queen trade it's too much for Yan to
give up that E5 Pawn with a check he
really doesn't want to and I think a
part of him is just not allowing him to
make the move Queen C5 because then
you're basically just giving up any
winning chances whatsoever it's the
white Rook that's more active in the end
game it's the white Bishop that's more
active in the end game and it's the
black ball on A6 that's a bigger
weakness in that end game
looks like a grim choice either way I
know what mama jarov would do here mama
jar of would gamble he'd give away his
Pawn just bring the black queen in uh
but yeah you have to weigh that one up
really carefully
from his black just needs two moves you
somehow need to get the black Rook all
the way down to the first Rank and you
need Black's Queen down there as well
but you don't have time to get both
Queen andrick attacking and therefore
we've seen the punishi shake his head
Lean Forward he's got a really
unpleasant decision right now trading
the Queens I think would obliterate his
chances of striking back in this match
so he might have to gamble here Tanya
what would you do
I think you have to you don't have a you
don't really have an option Queen C5
would be in a way just resigning
yourself to fit uh and it's time to go
all in so he does he does move the queen
so all he wants all yarn that partner
she wants is one move to get that Rook
to D1 which gives alireza a move to try
and stop that from happening what is the
most efficient way to build your own
attack with white hair David having just
one move to do so yeah it's not
immediately clear yeah black does have
this big threat and under one minute for
farrugia maybe you can just jump in for
example if you could jump in with the
Rook to C7 the point is that a Black's
Rook was to leave the eighth rank let's
say you go Rook D1 then white screen
comes in with a check on it and you're
the first to black skin yeah it's
important I love your move right C7
because now you hit this Pawn this is
more valuable of course than the black
Bishop uh Queen takes porn and you will
deliver Checkmate within a couple of
moves I am assuming I think you can give
a Checkmate here and oh wait Queen F6
was even quicker
I thought this black queen could take it
but look there's a pawn in the way uh so
yes this would lead to Checkmate so this
would force Black's Rook to stay on the
back Rank and play Titania nice spot
Bishop to C8 and he has to play Bishop
C8 because the Rook can't move you don't
have another Square for the bishop uh
but now that Rook on d8 is tied up
defending it so white just gets an extra
move to build the attack and he does it
fighting against the F7 pawn and
attacking The Rook on d8 yeah this
double attack forces the black Rook
passive and this is not good news for
janapon machine not only is he a pawn
down but look at this black Rook uh
forced to be a bystander here I'm
assuming farooza at some point we'll
just open up space for his King whoa he
goes marching with this King forward is
he going to do the famous Nigel short
King March March into the position and
try to Checkmate black using the king
and queen together wow that's an
incredible idea and that short game it
worked really well King came all the way
to 8-6 uh delivering a Checkmate on G7 I
it was a close position it was a blocked
position this one David hard to imagine
yeah I'm uh I'm mostly joking now I
don't think White's King is going to get
too far
whoa
come on Queen is out there keeping us on
the edge of our seats and now the black
Rook is free to roam uh neponishi
suddenly has been gifted sufficient time
to uh kind of shore up his King side now
the black Rook can come to B8 for
example
suddenly counter threats Tanya and David
Rook comes to be it and your opponent
has to answer that which is four seconds
on the clock oh yeah I'm surprised that
in the Punisher after playing so hastily
the whole day so far uh that he could
refrain from playing that move he does
go for it forcing the white Rook passive
this time and now the a pawn is Marching
for black white is suddenly a bit tied
up back in the game in this one and I
was about to say that the nepo is about
to get eliminated and I'm so glad I
didn't
Anything Could Happen Suddenly It's that
type of position and with eight seconds
against three minutes
Tanya I think nepo's done all the right
things psychologically he's tricked for
Russia and uh keeping those Queens on
the board looks like a master stroke now
the black queen can switch all the way
over Jan frowning
whose nuts will hold up yeah that's
another question yeah noisy has been
given a chance the move that you're
talking about but it's all about the
follow-up because white can defend that
pawn on H4 uh with the queen jumping on
to F6 trying to keep everything uh
together on the king side but look at
Jan I think from his body language you
can tell that he feels it the things are
shifting and his opponents got only five
seconds to handle it yeah for the first
time in this game Jan is extremely
excited and how does he profit there we
go he's going for White H Pawn defended
now the black queen does a yo-yo back to
the other side of the board attacking
the white Rook one second
he looks so calm though alireza how does
he do it right I know incredible but he
has to find the Right Moves now is that
going to be difficult with that time
difficult this is a really clever move
black has a huge threat of Rook D7 oh is
it a blunder blonde is his Queen Rook to
D7 now wins the game on the spot that's
a skewer of the White Queen and the
white Rook where it has to give up the
queen but black is gonna make a new one
with the a pawn
turn around he better win this queen
versus Rook because the bishop is going
to sacrifice itself for that a pawn
David oh my gosh Deja Vu Tanya that
would just be incredible
surely overnight has studied Queen vs
Rook if that happens again
but firstly
alireza has to recover from the
devastation of that turnaround
and did you see that he just looked away
he couldn't believe what had just
happened completely in control in that
position up upon and a one move blunder
uh has this time run out
he just resigned what happened I think
he was just so disgusted with himself
that he's resigned and we have an
Armageddon yay for the first time in the
tournament we're gonna see Arma get on
you guys this is Jana ponyachi probably
celebrating inside a huge blunder by
farusha in
desperate time trouble there to secure
an Armageddon to fight for the win in
this loser's quarterfinal wow drama what
happened here drama and it was all
because of the clock for Russia panicked
understandably as soon as napoleonishi
was able to apply some pressure towards
the white king and it was here with
white king kind of floating around on a
really awkward Square on F2 that
naponishi created a really sneaky threat
it looks like an innocent move Rook to
B7 but the deadly threat of Rook D7 was
missed by alireza here I think he had to
play an ugly looking move such as
offering a trade of Queens not an easy
move to go for because after the trade
of coins it looks like Black's Pawn is
running but white would have been able
to save the day next move going Rook to
A2 instead he panicked with only one or
two seconds left on his clock he
retreated the white Bishop missing the
main point that Rook D7 is a simple
skewer the White Queen had to give
itself up but that was not enough black
left with a really powerful Pawn on A4
and farouza resigned one win each means
it will be decided in Armageddon these
are the results from the losers
quarterfinals Anish Geary won both games
against mommy in the arrow to knock out
Shakira denish making it through two
tomorrow to face either an apple or
Fusia whoever wins in the Armageddon
they only have a few minutes now to
place their bids for time and then that
game will start but we're gonna be uh
we're joined by Anish giri winner
already against mamiaro congratsanish
thank you thank you very much what a
what a match how happy are you with the
way you're playing these days now
no I was really really happy I just got
very distracted now with this game the
reason I'm trying to understand like
what happened like how it's possible
that he blows up position
but yeah I don't know I mean it's really
like he was not only safe but also I
think he was winning at some point yeah
it's amazing amazing turnaround there so
I was a little shocked still uh
you know trying to digest that game I
just saw here in front of my eyes but uh
my games were uh yeah we're also tense
uh second game was much less tense than
the first as that option is
um well the first game at some point
opening was good then I messed up he was
already back and then again it turned
and I don't know I think at some point
uh the decided Factor was probably that
he was low on time and it was just hard
to defend
um that position yeah now uh in that
game too before that game we were
actually talking about a game from last
season which mom jaro actually described
as his best game ever played it was a
game against you where he sacrificed I
think five pieces and he wasn't a
must-win situation against you in that
game too was that game at all like in
the back of your head because he did put
a pawn up for grabs there uh he did play
a little crazy in that game too to to
get it when he needed no it was a
brilliant game for sure I think during
prelims I maybe it was a must win for
him but I think it was early in the
prelims as far as I remember so it was
not in the match I did lose some games
to him in matches we played a lot of
matches there were a lot of back and
forth matches
and I was expecting of course a tough
fight and he tried his best to stir up a
mess actually last season I had a good
results here and there but mainly I did
have this couple of brilliant losses so
I lost a very pretty game to Shah
and I lost also a very beautiful game to
do that I was quite uh does it hurt less
when it's beautiful
yeah no it was quite remarkable both of
these games they were so pretty
um
you know it happens when you sort of
Defense kind of not too badly but just
not good enough
and then in order to break your position
the
uh mundane sort of the normal methods
don't work
um but the pretty ones sort of do and um
it's it's like it's not so bad if you
lose to a masterpiece it means that okay
you put up some resistance because if
you play really bad you just get smoked
without the opponent helps you sacrifice
anything it was not too bad but it was
those are really pretty games I mean
there's also one game I lost to Magnus
which
super views that are there was some kind
of queen side but it was a really bad
Queen SEC and just uh somehow I got out
played in the later phase because I
messed up right after but uh the yeah
this game is gonna do that and Mom
Jennifer indeed uh beautiful losses and
actually there was like I think there
was sort of a best game price thing a
few best games yeah and I had some nice
game too but then when I lost these two
games I knew that okay I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna be able to compete with uh
with that luckily today no beautiful
losses from Shakir
is still to win and he's two wins for
you incredible
yeah I was lucky lucky well
Anish congratulations uh 2-0 yesterday
against sagaru and two two today against
shock some great chess as you were
saying about the yeah match crazy crazy
finish in that one and I want to get
your thoughts on this upcoming
Armageddon very often in the studio we
talk about this momentum shift that
happens when a player wins that final
second game as a player uh do you do you
think that plays on the mind is that a
factor
you would think that would be a huge
factor and
um indeed the player who came back you
know from from the dead should be
feeling great but we have seen so many
different matches over these last few
years in the tour that I'm not sure the
math confirms that I recall a lot of
matches when uh decided that it was
given this Lifeline would lose anyway
for example I recall uh some matches of
Magnus
um I think with Wesley I recall some
match like that I recall my own match
with Prague I would come back from the
dead and I would lose Armageddon anyway
so as
the NEPA would have a huge Edge now but
somehow I'm not sure the math uh we
would say so I think it's going to be a
sequel and as exciting as um you know as
as if these two games were drawn also
you have to take into account that the
side that got lucky sometimes feels like
you know the opponent played sort of
better or like there is also you know
it's a double-edged sword it's not that
you necessarily feel so great that you
you know that you came back and like of
course you feel great but well still
wrong long road ahead and Jan of course
knows also that okay played very well
um and yeah still a tough uh tougher
marketing for him but certainly amazing
that we get to con to witness this uh
this show and you know I'm a big fan of
the of watching the tour myself so I'll
I'll be getting my popcorn as well and
see who won my opponent will be
and an issue would you rather face
alireza or Yan
I think in the movies when you get the
choice of blue and the red pill there is
usually you know it's kind of more it's
easier to choose than than that I mean
it's really like Fire or the frying pan
it's both quite quite bad I guess it
would be kind of more interesting to to
face alireza because I played Jan
already in this tournament uh I lost to
him and that's why I'm in the losers
bracket it's not like I'm you know more
scared of yandereza I'm equally
terrified of both but uh sort of just I
guess diversity you know is a spice of
life or whatever so you you prefer to
lose to more people that you just stand
alone
they are fighting to face you tomorrow
and the losers semi-final lineage
congrats on some great chats and great
results today
thank you thank you we'll see Anish
Geary back to tomorrow he is still also
in contention for that final spot to uh
grab a ticket to the tour finals in
Toronto and uh so is
he is ready for the tour finals but nepo
he will have to win in the Armageddon
now to have a chance to stay in the
tournament Anish giri is now already
ready for losers semi-finals that will
be played tomorrow he will face either
netball or Ali reservous and the winner
there will go through to the losers
final to face the losers from the winner
is final that will be played after the
losers for the finals today we are
desperately waiting for the armaghetto
bids from nepo and alireza but the
action continues we're gonna take a
break and when we come back hopefully we
do have those bids
[Music]
thank you everyone loves playing chess
and everyone loves chess club
but there's also a time and a place for
playing all your favorite games hey
we're trying to have a lesson here you
need to get out of here recently more
kids have been playing chess than ever
in school but sadly we've learned that
they may not always be playing chess at
the most appropriate time
while it might be sometimes okay to grab
a game between classes or if your
teacher gives you permission and hasn't
given you an assignment it's not okay to
be playing chess in school when you
aren't supposed to and chess should
never come between you taking your study
seriously and cooperating with your
fellow students and teachers
just over the board or on the phone is a
great way to spend time with friends but
let's make sure that this school year we
don't let too much chess happen in the
classroom focus on your school because
chess.com will always be there when
class is over
[Applause]
[Music]
can we get some other letters please
what's wrong with it
[Music]
welcome everyone we are here with Judith
Polgar the legendary chess player one of
the greatest chess players of all time
[Music]
and I went my next move I said no I'm
not moving my queen I'm not moving my
Bishop but actually I'm going to give
Checkmate or winning great material and
I went 93.
foreign
it works only that way if your attacker
you sacrifice something go all the way
until the end don't chicken out in the
meantime at some point because many
times there is a point there is no way
back it's only forward
[Music]
[Applause]
how is it to play with casparo when you
saw him personally
he really had this incredible energy
shoot it thank you so much for being
with us and I hope you hope you're ready
to to dive into the past with us oh
absolutely I'm very happy to share with
you some of my most memorable games
thank you
it's getting very close the first
Armageddon and the AI Cup nepo against
Ali Reza we are waiting for their bids
David what do you expect when it comes
to the bidding in this one well usually
it's just a case of how low can you go
usually we see players bid around seven
or eight minutes because they're
desperate to get the black pieces and
draw odds uh where a draw is sufficient
to progress but this time Tania and I
were discussing in the break and we're
not so sure there were two decisive
games black actually won both which is
the style with which they've been
playing maybe we'll see players go high
and take white what do you think Tanya I
agree I think it's going to be a battle
for getting the white pieces and not
getting the result odds with the black
pieces we've seen two decisive games
we've seen alirez are really low on the
clock uh my prediction is that Jan will
have a high bid he will try to get the
white pieces and he'll try and play on
alireza's clock Armageddon we definitely
will have a winner of the match after
this one it's uh 15 times 15 minutes no
increment and they do bid for time the
winner of the bed with the player with
the lowest bid can choose to play with
usually the black pieces but these two
think maybe they now will choose to play
with the white pieces and the player
with the white pieces
to win the game the player with the
black pieces will go through with a
drawer or a win we do have the bids you
guys let's take a look at what the
players have been for time
going to 11 minutes and 30 seconds are
going as low as 8 minutes and 58 seconds
and he chooses the black pieces actually
are you surprised then David I'm
surprised but I'm impressed by Tanya she
knows Jan extremely well he goes high he
takes white he takes the extra time and
um wow he's really backing himself here
yeah once the man I've commented on his
two World Championships
for the white pieces uh and I think for
Yan he knows their style of clay one we
can't exp we can expect aggressive
combative play which means there is a
big chance for decisive chess uh and
also the clock has been such a big
factor in this match and he starts with
a big time Advantage already and here we
go
oh ferrugia has to play quicker than the
two games we've seen from him so far
today where he was way way down on the
clock early On and Here starting the
game with six minutes less than his
opponent it's going to be an uphill
struggle we see the nimzo Indian defense
or transposition to the ninja Indian
defense where black brings out a bishop
to B4 very early and Jan just developing
really classically here uh not going for
any early exchanges this is good wisdom
in a must-win situation he can play on
the board you can play on the clock and
he's trying to keep pieces on
yeah the main aim with your Armageddon
if you're playing with the white pieces
you've got the time Advantage your
opponent has the result odd is to try
and keep as many pieces on the board all
you're aiming for is a long game because
flagging is a really big part of
Armageddon so the more you can delay
critical decisions the more pressure
that you just keep on the board the more
tension you keep on the board the more
it favors uh White in this case
yeah and we started with one of the main
lines the ultimate main lines of the
nimzo Indian that seems to be in every
single top player's opening repertoire
especially with the black pieces but
this last move will have shocked veruga
will have surprised version and look
he's already pausing for the first real
time in this game White's Rook lifts up
and then it will try and slide across
the third rank towards the black king
this is a typical theme but this early
Tanya
yeah be a surprise he's got to be
surprised and he's been surprised in the
last two games as well David we've seen
him come down to two minute a minute on
the clock with Jan having this huge time
Advantage but in those games there was a
three second increment in the Armageddon
there is no increment at all so alireza
really needs to keep an eye out on that
17th piece the clock and a big decision
already to be made Jan jumps in with a
knight to the center of the board you
don't want to think can you really
capture either the Knight or the pawn
David both decisions look very
questionable to me yeah already a pawn
Sacrifice from Jan and his time
Advantage is only growing he's going on
the attack remember the white Rook wants
to slide across and towards the black
king uh I don't think you should take
this white knight look the bar it would
slide up here because Suddenly It's a
double attack hitting the queen hitting
the Black Knight and no matter where you
go uh for example if the Black Knight
enters the center of the board to block
that hit on the queen suddenly the king
is defenseless no defensive pieces here
the white Bishop is threatening to take
this Pawn it's going to be a devastating
attack against the black king this would
end in Checkmate instead he dodges this
I think the pawn on D4 was poisoned as
well if you had taken here then the
White Queen would simply move this would
be a nasty pin on the Black Knight in
the center so he does play a good move
for Asia but it cost him a lot of time
and after the pawn steps forward
suddenly we see White Center nice and
safe black white now is ready to slide
and go for the attack
I like all your colors on the analysis
foreign
it is a fruity type of position as well
Rook to H3 he's lining up for the
sacrifice I call this the Ferocious
sacrifice actually anything landing on
H6 giving up a piece for some pawns to
open up the enemy King and Jan's trying
to do it against the master himself here
just it looked like a preparation he's
still got 14 and a half minutes against
just six whoa no increment this is
already in the danger zone for black
yes and the idea that you pointed out
whether it works or not is not even the
biggest question the point is that it
forces alireza to think about it it
forces him to burn the clock a little
more and he says I'm not going to have
any of it jumps in with the Knights or
reinforces his defenses on that 8-6 pawn
again I think the dream here for black
would be to try and trade off as many
pieces as possible but it's not so easy
to get that going in such a position
yeah it's not that easy I love Persia's
last move though just bringing all the
Black Knights kind of nearer their King
Kings always feel much safer they sleep
better at night when they have nights
around as protection but the problem is
Jan's just playing quick easy moves and
still with 14 minutes The Rook in the
corner we talked about parties earlier
in the corner of the boat The Rook is
going to join the party in the center
and okay far Asia jumping in with his
Knights if he can trade off pieces Tanya
as you mentioned he's going to be happy
so maybe this is quite a logical move
yeah he's threatening to trade off at
least one of them and the Knights are
jumping onto the center of the board
white still has one piece that hasn't
joined the party David that Rook on A1
needs to find a move to come in but
there is so much attention right now
with this bishop threatened on D2 you've
got these ideas from that night on e4
going back to G5 attacking The Rook I
like what Jan's done he just simply
brings all the toys into the nursery
yeah just quick Pace as well from Jan
he's not letting up the speed here still
with almost an eight minute time
advantage and is it time to trade pieces
that's the big question there we go
another trade a set of minor pieces
leave the board and white Bishop pair
has gone that could be an important fact
for later the queen uh kind of trade
here Queen to G5 Tanya is that possible
what is black going to do next it's a
big big moment some tactics in the air
potentially but the problem is you can't
calculate you don't have that luxury of
time on the clock if you're far Asia
yeah
and that's been the big time advantage
that Ian has he needs to use it to his
Advantage I like your suggestion to
really try to neutralize the pressure
Queen G5 wow that's a big decision he
gives up material and he gives up the
bishop wow he's currently the exchange
down a rook for minor piece and he gives
up his Bishop but this is predicated on
the fact there will be a double attack
there will be a hit on the white king
let's just do a rewind we saw Rook takes
Bishop luring the White Knight note how
it's on an undefended Square now and uh
this move looked like it was winning
hitting the night going for checkmate
but white could have retreated the
Knight defending this square and then
after a trade defending on G2 instead he
flicked the move order he switched it
around he took this Pawn first that's a
good tip for everyone at home tactics if
they don't work one way around often
they do work with a kind of inverted
move order and now after the king took
this was the double attack the check
after the king stepped back Queen takes
Knight so right now material count a
rook for a knight and a pawn white
slightly ahead but white king slightly
Airy yeah doing the math that's five
points for The Rook four points for
black but that King weakness also counts
for something in this one so definite
compensation but how impressive was that
by alireza quickly understanding the
Dynamics of the position and realizing
he has enough compensation and then
going for the decision not burning the
clock too much that was that was amazing
yeah incredible Vision that alertness
with just five minutes on the clock
showing zero nerves whatsoever and
actually here I think I would prefer
Black's position Black's Knight is like
a statue here it's like a granite statue
that can never really be removed unless
at the cost of one of White's Rooks and
say for King easy plan very hard for
white to come up with anything while the
Queens remain on the board Queen trade
favors white but other than that black
doing well and he offers one which I'm
very sure that alireza will not go for
the end game will be really quite an
uphill task to defend whoa as I said
strange decision there but the bar
approves the bar says it's not too bad
but black now has to be extremely
careful if the white Rooks ever find any
open Line uh it will spell danger right
now the white Rooks are stifled they're
just staring at uh defended pawns the
white king needs to somehow dot towards
the center maybe ferocious got just
enough control I think if he didn't have
this draw odds he would never have
traded Queens he would have kept the
Queens on the board queen of Knight
great attacking Duo but he wants to play
Safety First chess will this rebound
will this back Fair yeah that's a big
question right because for Yan he can
play this position forever now he's the
one who's on the hunt here he's got more
material he can start shuffling around
with the Rook uh and we are going to see
this being played out till the end
alireza will have to earn his draw in
this one and it's not going to be easy
with no increment
yeah far from easy and that that
point you alluded to there Tanya the
fact that he can play on forever people
often associate end games with a draw
but that's far from it often we see uh
games go on and on and on 100 Move games
and with no increment on the clock that
could be vital
even if it's a dead draw even if it's
Rook versus Rook you can play 50 moves
there and milk a lot of time on the
clock
or ferrugia and suddenly he's spending
20 seconds on not a critical decision he
brings his Knight across the white king
I'm expecting to Dart towards the center
soon White's Rooks alone will not do the
business but White's King
uh in the middle of the board might be
able to help out
eleven versus four on the clock are they
both sort of uncomfortable right now
alireza with the clock Napo knowing he
has to win this game yeah definitely I
think discomfort is the right way to put
it right now and no easy plan for either
side that's uh the other thing it's one
of those positions it looks like white
can't make progress if you push pawns
you'll lose pawns black can't really
come forward because then opening lines
uh would help the white Rooks yeah the
bar goes slightly after this work move
yeah looks like a good one looks like a
healthy move black is actually aiming to
bring his Rook across and go for White's
isolated a pawn but the engine there
Tanya suggests an incredible move
actually giving up another Pawn for
weight just to open up lines and that's
the whole point right when you've got
Rooks you need the lines for activity
and I love that suggestion by the engine
move by the engine but that's the thing
once the engine points it out it makes
all the sense but here
and he does find it's C4 on the board
he's inviting to move Rook takes Pawn
the Rooks will be off the board and the
other Rook will find the entry into the
enemy camp and it's all happening look
at this he's given up his roof amazing
this is genius Pawn to C5 just ignoring
the threat on the white Rook because
look at the Black Knight is just too far
away it can no longer control the white
Pawn from running this is a winning move
I think anything else and black would
have been able to keep the game going
but Pawn to C5 black has to Simply get
rid of this potential Queen and then the
white Rook is going to go hunting and
this is exactly as I missed this move C5
is the line that yeah she saw before he
pushed that seep on giving up the Deep
on I was thinking it's all about getting
that Rook to The d-line Rook C1 Rook D1
you try to activate but actually The
Rook doesn't even have a good Square to
move to anymore night folks all around
C5 uh this could be the move of the tour
so far wow yeah just the vision as well
he saw it just three moves back before
he played C4 just giving up uh the pawn
in the center giving up the Rook now and
to play C5 to calculate that your Pawn
is running through to Glory uh this is
just genius and farrusion now it's
losing on the board losing on the clock
simply no way to keep this black apron
alive much longer and it's all about the
white apron this innocent looking Pawn
it's gonna become a queen in the near
future this is heartbreaking for alireza
you know he finds this incredible tactic
of sacrificing The Exchange giving up
that Bishop for the G2 pawn and creating
these Dynamics and then missing this
final tactic in the end uh
he's confident now he knows he's done
the job how nice is it to play a move
like that it's so satisfying it's so
rare as well to kind of go for a
tactical shot a uh unexpected sacrifice
that the opponent doesn't spot
especially at this level
um and to do it so quickly Jan this is
where we talk about Armageddon and the
clock ticking and speed chess in general
it's all about sharpness seeing these
two three move tactics and for Asia oh
yeah heartbroken I mean you can just see
it on their cameras uh alireza he looks
resignated
just leaning back he looks so happy with
himself right now that is so cool what a
move by Anna popnachi you could the
contrasting emotions we don't even need
the board if we're just watching the
cameras we know what result is incoming
and Black's night could not find a
stable Square to defend the a pawn so he
gives it up for here but where's Black's
counter play Black's Pawn Mass the four
versus two advantage on the king side
far far too slow black king can never
really come across without losing all of
his pawns either
um this one's over Tanya it doesn't
exist we've been talking about just how
strong a piece the Knight can be how
tricky it can be combining defense for
the king an attack with its own Queen
but against the air Pawn against a flank
passer like the one that Ian has it is
quite helpless and I think uh alireza
knows that every move he's burning 30
seconds on the clock it's just coming to
terms with the fact that these are the
last few moments in the AI cup for
alireza but he is ready for Toronto
still oliveruza you will definitely see
him in uh the tour finals yeah and now
it's going to be fascinating assuming
Napoleon she wins this game
Jan against Anish for a spot potentially
in Toronto and uh remember in the
winners bracket Maxim vashilograph also
needs to win the tournament it's going
to be Magnus against the rest as he
tries to prevent them qualifying from uh
for that finals in Toronto that is such
a nice move such a classy move but yeah
just moving the king back to H1 not a
square that many would consider because
you want to move forward with your king
but it sidesteps any checks any bond
movements coming in with a Tempo and the
apron is going to get the job done he
doesn't need the king in this end game
yeah really good point there Tanya if
you're worried about night folks anyone
this is how to place your king with two
squares between the king and knights and
farrugia he resigns because this white
porn is about to promote
Within
with a genius genius move he may makes
it through two the loser is
quarterfinals to face Anish giri
tomorrow no celebration outside for yawn
he looks a little tired but even with
fatigue he is able to play what Tanya
described as the move of the season was
it that great that move I loved it and
it's not just the move itself but it's
the vision it is having seen that move
in advance because that's the only way
that you can afford to give up that
Central Pawn so finding it in seconds C5
sacrificing that Rook it gets him a
really important win one of the best
moves I've seen this season wow paint us
that beautiful C5 image David yeah we
need an action replay of that one moment
and actually alireza may be regretting
trading Queens just a few moves previous
to this here he brought his Rook forward
what could be more logical the black
Rook may be going for a check against
the white king the black Rook may be
going hunting for White's lone isolated
a pawn here but he was hit suddenly with
a surprise Porter C4 and he should not
have taken the bait he did take this
Pawn but it turned out to be poisoned a
trade of Rooks meant that the Black
Knight could not fight against the power
of white spawn and White's Rook here not
reacting to the threat on the white Rook
simply ignoring this and pushing the
pawn 4 to C5 this was the genius idea
behind the earlier sacrifice if Knight
takes Rook then the white Pawn simply
runs through two squares from promotion
the Black Knight too far away and as we
saw in the game the pawn was traded off
but whites were super superior to the
Black Knight and it was soon game over
with the white pieces
he had to win that game and that's just
what he did to make it through to the
losers uh semi-finals tomorrow knocking
out Ali reservous he will face Anish
giri who played two great games against
mom and yarov and didn't each say that
he's already played against Yan so he
might be uh wanting to play alireza
Maybe oh we got a rematch of that one
got a rematch and Jan did win 3-0
against Anish on day one of this event
so that's gonna be fascinating yeah and
he must be feeling confident after what
happened today Jana from yachi
congratulations first of all of uh on
making it through
turning on the lights as well there we
have it yeah and congratulations on
making it through in the tournament
yeah hello thank you and we have to talk
about C5 Tanya called it the move of the
Champions Chester season David Collett
just genius how nice is it in a must win
situation to play that beautiful move C5
I don't know maybe Tanya should watch
more chess
I don't think a lot of people watch more
chats than Tanya I think I think she's
doing this pretty much every day but I
think it's quite a topical breakthrough
and that's actually was my my more or
less only trick in the whole position I
was relying because yeah I mean the C4
and C5 breakthrough so basically if I
get space for my Rooks uh
I'm pretty much winning yeah especially
when okay a pair of Rook is gone and
there is only one night
uh as we all know night is not so good
like holding both kingside and queen
side so yeah I guess after Rook before
it was pretty much over but uh I would
say if he would just like play C4 like
group D7 I think it's nothing special
yeah I think it's yeah I'm better but
I mean yeah I could I could press a
little bit uh you know especially on his
clock but
it didn't help so for too much
how happy are you though with the way
you played today looking maybe away from
the first game that you lost but making
that comeback and also a must win in the
Armageddon
well happier than uh in case if I would
lose this yeah the first game uh I mean
it was just completely disgusting so
uh first of all found myself defending
this war same game and secondly in a
very very not well-known position I just
like forgot to play like um a rookie
free like at a very topical side attack
of uh of the person born when it's like
a rook porn it's you can have a promotes
because of this little trick but I sort
of like Blitz it out king G3 and then
okay I thought okay well just what did I
do
yeah so this was um painful although
in the second game yeah I think I didn't
do anything special but uh yeah he got
into time trouble and I don't know I
don't know so I was pretty pessimistic
but yeah still Queen on A1 maybe it's a
little bit hard to deal with yeah it's
being protected by his own phone
so perhaps he should have played like
Quincy frequency one like civilizen
would easily go through but um yeah I
would like him
and uh Jan you've played a lot of Chess
this week firstly winning the very
strong levitov tournaments and now
making it deep into the AI cup how are
your energy levels yeah
sorry how what how are your energy
levels right now ah my energy level is
miserable
I do see some suitcase behind you as
well are you on the move as well
no no no uh I stayed here in Amsterdam
probably uh because uh for example
chakra he has like
I don't know I think she has like four
six six hours to
uh to reach his uh Baku or something
yeah but in my case it's like now like
15 hours at least to when I'm traveling
back to Moscow uh so yeah while I'm
playing I'm pretty much stuck here but
maybe not not such a big place to be
and yeah no congratulations not only on
today's win but again on the levitar of
week performance great chess uh all
around I'll still say C5 was a stunning
move especially having the vision to
sacrifice D4 and then to find this it
was great to watch and commentate on uh
I want to ask you looking ahead you will
be playing against Anish you won one
match against him here uh tell us about
your thoughts fighting against him he's
also in great form
well during cover match I didn't uh
notice that he was in a great form
basically maybe maybe this match uh
I mean surprisingly for me it was very
one-sided and I think it really
motivated him for for the next couple of
matches yeah at least so he I think he
he won all his games yeah since uh since
our our match so yeah best of two is
always
pretty much
until the first mistake yes I'll try
uh you know try my best but the good
news is okay today it was like a such a
short day like only three games because
previously like the day uh
uh the day before yesterday and
yesterday I had like eight games every
day so yeah wow
I mean that's that's a lot that is a lot
but yeah as we all know and it also has
a lot of things to do but yeah it's
quite uh quite nice the time like still
being here in Netherlands and uh yeah my
my only probably way to face a niches
that just come directly yeah
but still yeah you could actually yeah
meet up and and play the games together
[Applause]
consider but you should also ask Anish
if he's
wow where we are excited about that
matchup and looking forward to it and
the other matchup that we're looking
forward to is coming up with the Magnus
taking on Maxime in the Winner's final
and yeah and we'd love to get your
thoughts on that uh Clash uh how do you
think that will play out
uh I would say
um
you know I would say that in Rapides
they wouldn't uh the Commandments as a
like huge favorite because he's maybe at
least a bit too focused on like faster
time controls
uh at least uh well I mean okay I'm not
taking into account for yesterday's
match when it was like
um you know pretty much pathetic from uh
from both players yeah but uh
yeah this man was played one a good game
like in game three from start to end
from start to finish
but I didn't really follow what Maxine
was doing but uh as far as he's going
through the Winner's bracket I think
he's in good form and I would say like
uh and in popular opinion I would uh you
know pick maximum
wow all right some cool predictions from
you there young congratulations so much
on your win today and some fantastic
play even if you talk down we're going
to talk about that move is pure genius
thank you for joining us
okay you have like all evening taking
the talking about the C5 movie
you know come up with some detailed
analysis yeah C5 beautiful thank you Jan
and good luck tomorrow we do have some
stats from janaponia's match against Ali
Reza
uh we do see brilliances and blunders do
you think Brilliance is that C5 move I
think for sure yeah maybe C4 setting up
C5 just a few turns later either way
just high quality chests from both I
think that's the whole point right it's
not the move in a solitary self it's the
whole idea and playing it out in seconds
so instructive that the Knight is not a
great defender against the passer and
you can't afford to sacrifice material
uh with these tactics so some amazing
stuff there but also an amazing
prediction by Yan go Maxim he said
definitely
all right
um we are looking forward now to the
winners final uh but first uh these two
have also finished their match mom
Madeira of Anna Niche giri it was Geary
winning two games to make it through to
tomorrow's loser semi-final where he
will play janapo miyachi
here it is the bracket so far this is
day three in the AI cup tomorrow's day
four will consist of the loser
semi-final with giri nepo the winner in
that match will go through to the losers
final to face the loser in tonight's
winners
final and that match will start very
shortly it's Magnus Carlsen against
MBL that will be an exciting match
coming up very shortly first we have to
remind you about this one it's the
Photoshop contest you can win an
exclusive secret lab Titan Evo
Champion's chest torch here it's very
cool you see Magnus Carlsen sitting in
it if you edit a photo or video of Danny
wrench wearing the pawn suit tag secret
lab chairs and posted with hashtag
greenpawn on x
uh or on Instagram it's open until
October 8th
that cool that chair is so cool uh join
in on the competition we have to take a
break when we come back it's winners
final
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
we are getting ready for the winners
final it's Magnus Carlson against his
longtime friend Maxim
he is in a fantastic chess player but he
is a man of many talents he is also
someone with a degree in mathematics
I was born near Paris
and I've always lived either in the
suburbs with my parents and my sister
yeah I grew up like in uh you know in a
house with Garden you know normal
neighborhoods Maxine vashilograph was
introduced to Jess when he was just five
years old my father taught me the words
and basically everyone in the family
started playing for
for a year or two but then then it was
all for me
at six years old after only one year of
playing the game he showed signs of
being an exceptional chess talent I won
my first French Championship underwear
that year the Paris Rapidan Blitz
then I continued playing continued
winning this year's events when I
started getting medals also
with competitors from all over the world
it was their I had the chance to
to go further
such a good intuition I'm very resilient
uh normally speaking so I always try to
create some trouble
for my opponents where when I'm in a bad
shape then I'm very good at spotting uh
quick tactics besides from being a top
10 chess player Maxim has been able to
study and get a degree in mathematics
this way I could socialize I could keep
on getting having a life outside the
chessboard and it also felt more secure
to have
to rely on should I stop playing chess
well I've loved playing chess from the
start so for me it's all about the the
games the playing part so I
I'm not so fond of studying and of
course it's necessary but what I like is
playing games having fun
you know even playing a Blitz game being
able to trash talk a bit and to you know
be very casual and then of course the
competitive part where you know I I want
to win the game I want to
to be the best player I can be and to
beat to beat everyone basically
is definitely capable of beating anyone
a fantastic chess player who's been in
the field for a long time he is born in
the same year as Magnus Carlson that
golden 1990 generation with obviously
that big one the Blitz World
Championship in 2021 and now he is up
against Magnus Carlsen for the first
time this season on the Champions
Chester uh how is maxim in in the rapid
format obviously being a blacks world
champion uh Maxim is great we heard Jan
allude to it maybe Magnus uh these days
he's more focused on Blitz and bullet
but uh Maxine he's been up there in
World rapid championships before
um he's done it against Magnus BTM and
speed chess uh in the speed Chess
Championship 2022 so yeah he's he's
capable um I wouldn't say his ceiling is
as high as Magnus but he's very stable
and he does pressure his opponents on
the clock he's so quick at calculating
maybe thanks to his master's degree uh
that's he uh can put pressure he can
hustle his opponents on the clock yeah
maybe this is the format for mvl to beat
Magnus Carlsen in a match and let's take
a look at the tale of the tape between
these two players who are ready to fight
and the winners final here in the AI cup
and quite uh one-sided though Carlson
leaves 14 to six does that make him a
big favor do you think Tanya any game
Magnus plays Kaya he's a big favorite
yeah but that said this event itself I
think we've seen certain shaky Moments
by Magnus at games where he's missed uh
missed quite a bit in his own words he
hasn't been very happy with his farm
meanwhile every match that Maxim has won
he's been really convincing he's not
only been very precise with his play but
also being again able to calculate
deeply and uh take those difficult
decisions keeping the clock in mind he
is a speech specialist and given his
form in this tournament I think he's got
a good chance today yeah and he's also
very motivated for that spot in Toronto
yeah definitely he is now one of how
many we still have four players
incontaine contention for that final
spot in Toronto MBL is one of those
easiest path to do it is to just win the
AI cup but he's uh gonna want to win
against Magnus in the winner is final
today because the winner in this match
goes straight through to the Grand Final
gets a free day tomorrow
and can rest before that Grand Final on
Friday let's
take a life
we have a surprise coming in
oh here is Emil go it's a mosquito
aha well we were talking about earlier
today
bothered by mosquitoes two years ago and
here we have Emil maybe struggling with
the same thing let's haul mosquitoes do
not ruin his chances to beat Magnus
today that we will have a big fight in
the winners final and in the winners
final we have best out of four rapid
games 15 minutes plus three seconds
increment after every move if they are
tied after those four rapid games then
it will be decided in Armageddon and the
winner goes straight through to the
Grand Final the losers the loser is not
knocked out of the tournament but is
knocked down to the losers bracket
to play in tomorrow's losers final and
what is it about for mvl today if he is
going to beat Magnus in a match with
four games what is the most important
factor for him I think the start really
matters he has to make sure that uh from
the very first game itself things are
under control and I think against Magnus
at least what we've seen in this event
so far also the game that Yan was really
close to beating Magnus it's about
bringing Magnus into these complicated
messy positions and those are the ones
where also Maxim really thrives in the
big question David for me will be will
Maxine be successful in getting a Magnus
in those chaotic positions where things
can get a little more random uh because
if you just try to play the Strategic
slow battle against Magnus how do you
and where do you win yeah and actually
most of those victories that Magnus has
had we saw the head-to-head score the
reason it's so one-sided is because
Magnus triumphs in the end game against
mvl as soon as the Queens are off he
tends to weave his magic there but uh if
Maxim especially with white where he's
extremely strong if he's able to attack
able to play play on the front foot
magnet's been playing a bit risky uh
then yeah Maxine has some chances but I
do worry his black repertoire which he's
kind of revamped refreshed recently for
Maxine it has suffered against Magnus in
the past he has been on mvl to play one
opening and one opening only but that's
changed over the last year it's really
shifted especially over the last few
months and Maxim also had this
phenomenal performance of the Tata steel
chess India recently where he played
everything except his beloved night of
except his beloved grunfield so he has
been switching it up getting a more
Universal approach in the opening a bit
again Kaya I think it's going to be
about trying to get Magnus into that
Mikhail tal Forest of complication where
the part out is narrow enough for just
one yeah and we did see Magnus yesterday
miss a mate in three is that sort of a
sign of Magnus not being 100 I think
definitely a sign Magnus himself he's
his own uh kind of harshest critic he's
very honest about these things he knows
in terms of Dynamics in terms of tactics
he wasn't his uh kind of he wasn't in
top form and if he isn't in top form
today Maxine will be able to punish him
uh that's where he suffered he nearly
lost a game against Yan yesterday Magnus
a bit up and down but here we go here he
comes Magnus Carlsen has he just woken
up yeah maybe I mean it's late in Norway
it's eight o'clock for Magnus Carlsen
when the Winner's final start he will
have the white pieces in this game one
first player to reach two and a half
points best out of four rapid games and
Magnus will make the first move here we
go and it is a sicilian not the night
off not his specialty fascia degrath
where he has been quite predictable
historically throughout his whole career
instead it's Knight C6 and with two and
Magnus doesn't go for any open Sicilians
he plays the more positional the slower
uh Bishop to B5 and actually we're more
used to seeing colors reversed I've seen
battles between Carson and Ashley grab
in this position uh with color switch
with Magnus taking on the black side of
this opening
fascinating start to this one Tanya not
his usual but still an area of expertise
yeah and Bishop B5 the rasa Luma a very
solid approach against the Sicilian now
Magnus wants to break in the center with
D4 but when there is a recapture on D4
you want to take back with the pawn to
keep control uh off the center this was
an opening David that was made so
popular in the 2018 World Championship
Match as a fight against that Knight C6
move that we saw from Maxime this is
game one of game four so the players are
also feeling the opening the Rhythm out
right now and I think for Magnus he
wants to check a little bit is Maxine
going to stick to the old guns his usual
repertoire or does he have something
special planned yeah uh he definitely
feels like he's had something special
planned so far vashilograph really
impressive speed to the opening and look
at this all four Pawns in the center
it's a really rare situation this kind
of Mexican standoff neither side wants
to Blink uh or Flinch here but you have
to break that tension and it looks like
black is ready
wow yeah this is a bit of a Face-Off in
the center and uh Magnus decides to
capture the E5 Pawn hitting that Knight
so black has to recapture on e4 the
other Central Pawn now that pawn on E5
David is a bit of a weakness it is it is
a target for black is it time to trade
off that Knight on C6 it might well be
black has a clear plan a clear Potential
Threat just to take this Pawn uh either
you have to kind of take defensive
action and actually this might run into
some tactics I was going to say maybe
you just defend this Pawn with a move
like Bishop to F4 but suddenly bang
knight takes pawn and a double attack
another theme of the day hitting the
king and uh this check will pick up
White's Bishop next Black will have won
a pawn uh interest in this uh little
position in this little transition so I
think you'll move pretty much force
Tanya here Bishop to F4 would be a huge
mistake first just eliminating this
Knight not just that but getting rid of
this hanging Bishop
I think he has to play it Magnus pausing
though oh he finds another way he finds
another way okay
he's getting rid of this threat against
F2
yeah he doesn't want to give up to
Bishop so easy now you can't take that
pawn on F2 the tactics that you pointed
out because that white bishop and B5 is
defended with the Knight on the other
hand Magnus himself starts attacking the
center uh the black Central Pawn on D5
it was hard to find Knight C3 but of
course Magnus does it and when he does I
kind of like it more than giving up that
Bishop yeah definitely he is Wrecking
his own Pawn structure slightly Magnus
Carlson if we see a trade of knights
isolated pawns do come back to haunt you
potentially in future but uh right now
it looks like White's activity White's
dynamism more than compensates for that
the bishop comes out to F4 very nice
square or G5 hitting the black queen and
uh Magnus looks sleepy what's going on
with him Magnus arrives at the game
looking like he's just woken up and has
he gone into a bit of a power nap uh
mode here
I know how he feels it's been a long day
of Chess but uh oh yeah Magnus yeah this
is strange this is maybe it means for
optimism
do you think he has the camera on seeing
Magnus so sleepy like this and I I think
for maxim if he does that's a good sign
because once you get this feeling that
your opponent your
um your opponent your arrival is not
fresh enough it's time to strike early
you can start looking for those
opportunities and very often Magnus in
his interviews has actually said that
his opponents don't take advantage of
that early opportunity of that early
momentum so if Magnus does become a bit
sleepy or give those chances to Maxim he
needs to be up for it but yeah wow
what's going on with Magnus there yeah
the sudden reaction very strange
Behavior here uh maybe not liking his
position maybe it's not the fact that
he's tired maybe it's just a lack of
enthusiasm for the position because
fashion degrath came so well prepared
but either way I think your point is
really essential here you have to strike
Magnus early was that a yawn covering
his eyes here I think he hates his
position this much
yeah something's up with Magnus yeah
dude you're his good friend do you know
something that we don't no comment Tanya
but uh either way black has a good
position and uh the fact that Magnus
isn't enjoying it
yeah really surprising you have to hit
him hard though you have to hit him fast
before he wakes up before he perks up
and uh starts kind of going up the gears
getting into top form if Magnus takes
the lead in this match I do fear for
Maxim's chances Maxine doesn't have the
kind of must win opening repertoire that
some of the other top players have
potentially but he does play the move
Queen to B6 so similar to an idea we
pointed out this hit on the F2 point and
some tactics some tricks in the air
white has to be a bit careful here yeah
because you're hitting that pawn on F2
but not just that you're also hitting
that Knight on C3 which is a key
Defender for that Bishop on B5 so a
multi-purpose move and the first natural
response that came to my mind uh David
was to develop that bishop and C1 get it
to E3 to stop that threat of Queen F2
but I think the problem here is that
black has the Intermezzo of capturing on
C3 instead of running away with the
queen and after all these trades that we
see with white cap ring the queen on B6
black recapturing the queen on D1 you
actually end up with an X rupees and it
all works out in
Black's favor after picking up that
Bishop on B6 so Queen B6 does require
Magnus to slow down and calculate a few
lines uh the first question how do you
fight this threat and Magnus answers it
develops his Queen to E2 not only
defending the F2 Pawn but the bishop on
B5 yeah anything black can do white can
do as well black attacks two pieces with
his Queen the F2 Pawn the B5 Bishop so
White's queen says okay it's time for me
to start work and defending F2 defending
B5 uh multi-purpose move there I'm just
wondering when this Pawn is going to
drop off the board I don't think it can
be captured right now because white has
a big threat of Knight takes D5 so black
either has to eliminate the attacker of
that pawn by trading knights we said
this maybe favors white because suddenly
Black's most active pieces disappeared
uh or black has to just up sticks and
bring his Bishop out and
defend this Pawn in the center so keep
the tension or break the tension that's
the Dilemma for maxim bash of the graph
I like this I like the concept of
keeping the tension also Maxime his
middle name is chaos is nerves it's
actually bashia but it could very well
be chaos because we've seen the kind of
Chess he plays but David just looking at
this natural developing move that you
pointed out Bishop to E6 it would mean
that you have to calculate all these
lines where what happens if white was to
trade one set of knights on e4 then the
other set of Knight on C6 but instead of
going into any of that he chooses a
different approach of defending the D5
Pawn With The Rook but the question
Still Remains What happens if white was
to capture on e4 then the Knight on C6
and then the pawn on e4 yeah it does in
essence look like a pawn sacrifice uh
just to follow that variation you were
mentioning Tanya Knight takes Knight
here the white Bishop now has to take
the Black Knight there's no time to take
this Pawn in the center remember because
the white Bishop would hang the White
Queen needs to defend its bishop and if
we follow this line right to The Bitter
End then we would see a trade of queens
and at the end black would give a check
and the problem for white is yes you can
stay a pawn up you can move your king
off the back rank but but you're tied
down Forever on the first rank weights
Bishop is pinned to The Rook I don't
think you can ever break this blind
Black's Bishop will come out Black's
Rook will come to attack and maybe even
win this bishop and uh the alternative
the only alternative would be a sad
Retreat or upon a trade of Rooks would
allow black to regain the pawn and we
talk about the might of the two Bishops
quite regularly uh at top level because
it is decisive here Black's Bishop is so
strong on this diagonal soon joined by
its counterparts on F5 and I think the
might of these two Bishops for example
um okay I'm not going to lose a pawn but
let's say in a position like this it's
just overwhelming White's two pieces
cannot fight especially on the light
squares and black would have a decisive
Advantage so yeah long variation Magnus
uh will realize it's a wrong variation
right now going for all of those trades
but what else to do maybe it is time to
develop this bishop still sleeping at
home because with that last move that
Maxim just made now it's a big track to
actually capture the pawn on E5 he's
defended his own Pawn on D5 so 95 in the
air again two options right you develop
your dark Squad Bishop to F4 to defend
that E5 Pawn or do you give up your
light Squad Bishop on C6 I do like
Bishop F4 I like my Bishop Bear yeah me
too Tanya I'm very biased towards the
Bishops one of my strengths but also one
of my big weaknesses in chess and uh
Bishop takes Knight would give a healthy
position but it would also part with the
bishop power let's allow Magnus to
decide on this strategically do you feel
he's woken up he looks slightly More
Alive on the camera Tanya
well he needs to wake up because there
are threats on the board and he has to
counter them accurately and when you're
playing against the player like Maxim
you really can't give too many chances
because Maxine will be on top of uh of
any opportunity that he gets in this
game yeah leaning back there max if you
were talking about Bishops versus
Knights since this is the AI cup doesn't
AI really like one of them and I don't
remember which one at least Alpha zero
loves the bishop pair when they're
together I think Bishops versus Knights
alone it depends on the pawn structure
but when it's two Bishops together
computers uh very very biased
and you know Magnus he's biased towards
Knights he loves his Knights and he
hates his opponent's night so he does
decide to actually give up the bishop
for that Knight on C6 but I think it's
in modern chess general principles uh
more than that it's about the concrete
position you have uh you know in general
if it's an open position you want the
bishop bear if it's a block position
Knights are considered better pieces
because they're shot range pieces they
can jump around easy land on those holes
but Bishop needs uh long range pieces
need more space to move around uh and
it's also personal preference vishyanand
also known for his love for nights oh
really yeah uh-huh but so you're saying
the general rules can only get you so
far in chess you have to be a bit
flexible yes you need to know the
general rules tools uh as well so and
then play around with them yeah and then
you need to know the rules before you
break the rules that's the that's the
key in general well well said David
Howell but I think it's a stylistic
thing Knights are favored by attacking
players Dynamic players tricksters the
Bishops are favored by old men
[Laughter]
and okay a trade of a set of nights and
now it is the bishop pair against bishop
and Knight so we will find out the truth
uh at least in this exact position this
specific scenario with this structure
Magnus wants to conquer the dark squares
black has a light squared Bishop
unchallenged you'll uh most likely
control that color complex but if you
can trade off the dark squared Bishops
white does have a queen and Knight combo
watch out for some attack
Magnus slightly low on the clock but I
think he's starting to be happier with
his position yeah and uh you can see why
right you're pointing out all these
ideas of white actually neutralizing the
bishop pair on his terms either with the
move Bishop to 86 or Bishop to F6 and
either of these trades could actually
give white a lot of attacking chances
and then coming to your point of
stylistically Magnus with his Knight
having the Queens on the board uh I
think this is why you start smelling
that you know there are possibilities
there are dynamics that exist and you
start getting a little excited about
your position the Nitro Mastery can also
land on D4 a nice little spot you really
want to provoke black to push that C6
Pawn to C5 to try and kick that out
because then that gives you weaknesses
in the center of the board with the well
pawns that can be targets yeah
definitely and one of the most typical
mating patterns uh especially kind of at
the lower levels would be for example
let's give black a uh let's make a
slightly strange move it would be for
example allowing a pawn to F6 this is
the one thing black cannot do uh cannot
give away access to the not squares
suddenly this Pawn acts as a protector
of the G7 square and for example the
queen jumping in uh this is the kiss of
death Checkmate if I remember correctly
uh where the queen will come in and
deliver Checkmate to the black king so
the one thing fashion has to watch out
for therefore he does clear the uh the
sixth rank so he controls F6 but Tanya
you mentioned that this Pawn might be
vulnerable it looks like a gift here
from Russia the graph what is the plan
we're talking about Maxim he's all about
the initiative and the position and we
also mentioned how the bishop has long
range pieces love open diagonals Maxim
is actually voluntarily giving up a
Central Pawn here so that he opens up
space for his light squared Bishop once
the bishop comes to B7 you can really
imagine the power of these two Bishops
uh gets a lot of counter play the game
of course goes on and the valbar says
that White's doing absolutely fine but
it brings in the kind of dynamics that
Maxim is looking for really concrete
nice approach there instead of just
sitting still and going passive against
a pair like Magnus yeah really
fascinating and I once commentated with
Magnus on an event and he said any pawn
that is lost or that you blunder means
open lines feel pieces so you've got to
look on the bright side maximum
sacrificing a pawn here but only opening
lines up for blacks Bishops four blacks
Rooks do you think Magnus is going to
take this oh he's reluctant when his
opponent so willingly throws a pawn at
him Magnus
I don't think he wants to take the bait
but maybe it's just the best move after
all it is a pawn is a pawn as they say
take the material and cling onto it and
we've got their valbar telling us right
that you're absolutely fine after
grabbing that pawn on D5 but when you're
playing the position and you see the
black Bishop jumping into this powerful
spot on B7 with a Tempo against the
queen also x-raying that Knight on F3 uh
you've got to be reluctant about these
decisions yeah how materialistic would
you say you are Tanya Kaya in chess and
in life I am very materialistic I just
dread losing anything
oh that's such a heavy question
especially the one about life but I
think on the chatbot I'll be honest
David if this was a position in my game
I don't think I would take on D5 I would
probably try and look for ways to
actually trade off those dark Squad
Bishops so either Bishop 86 or ideas
like Queen to F4 and insisting on Bishop
F6 uh yes of course I've we did see the
line and the eval bar approves the queen
D5 but I don't think I would go for it
in a practical game
um yeah what about you uh I would have
fake Nepal because I'm a greedy anything
free I like NHS Bishop F6 Bishop F6 yeah
he's trying to give the pawn rather than
take the pawn here Magnus Carlson
anything you can do I can do better he's
saying and he's trying to go for this
Checkmate plan that we mentioned uh
let's show the idea here we thought that
the black queen had cleared the sixth
rank now to cover this square but Magnus
insists he drops his Bishop in and now
taking this bishop would be highly risky
for black notice how the Rooks stare off
at each other blacks Rook temporarily
undefended if we see a Trader Rooks and
blacks well the evaluation bar jumping
and if Black's Queen now does feast on
this Pawn then it would end in disaster
White Queen only now takes and suddenly
this Rook is pretty much trapped The
Rook has to slide across the B8 but
white conquers the back Rank and I'm not
sure what the killer blow is here but
white is winning maybe just take the
spawn going for checkmate against the
king so instructor and so much to learn
from here because I was talking about
how I want to trade off the dark Squad
bishop and trying to defend that square
but Magnus Carlton shows the way he says
you can just calculate the line and with
based on tactics make these uh
positional decisions I really like to
move Bishop to F6 uh countering the
spawn sacrifice that Maxim offered and
now if you can't really take that pawn
on F6 well he does take the bishop
and he's just going to develop his own
Bishop defending that Rook on E8 yes he
does it yeah connecting Rook so I was
going to say the most satisfying move in
chess is a move your opponent thinks
they have stopped and then you play it
anyway and they're like whoa that's not
possible but maxim of course recovers
very quickly and he defends now the
threat is on to take this Pawn he's
covered his back rank always cover your
back ranking chest any chance that white
very far Advanced Pawn will survive if
he can keep it alive he might deliver
Checkmate yes
that's that's a dangerous Bond on the
board and also things work out for black
hair because another mating pattern as
you said kiss of that Queen on G7 is
Queen and Knight combining to give a
mate on H7 but the good thing for maxim
is that if white actually jumps to H6
right now you can capture the pawn on F6
because like Chief David is met by the
queen coming back and defending the king
side keeping everything together
yeah the king and queen a queen is the
best defender if she's able to
participate in the defense and this
would end in disaster for Magnus Carlson
so his fractured Pawn structure at this
Pawn we talked about on F6 is either
very good or it's very bad uh so Magnus
has to maybe just keep it intact I don't
know if you should uh maybe just defend
this pawn and keep it alive for future
attacks but either way I started to like
Black's position as long as he doesn't
fall for any of these tricks that we've
been pointing out uh Magnus slightly
lower on the clock as well getting
dramatic it's
and one gets the feeling that if this is
a long strategic battle then black does
have the trumps with that F6 Pawn as a
weakness in any end game uh that would
arise black would get chances but Magnus
he either needs to trade that F6 Pawn
for the central D5 Pawn but I like your
idea of keeping it alive Queen to G5
would be the first move that I would
consider here David uh because to me F6
as long as Queens are on the board feels
like a strength and wow tactics again
agnese is not from G5 but I'm going to
defend my Pawn from F4 because now that
pawn is Untouchable you capture on F6
you win a pawn but you're gonna lose
that Bishop on F5 yeah in direct defense
of the F6 Pawn this is really uh really
sneaky stuff cunning played by Magnus
Carlson he looks like this queen and
porno kind of disconnected the
connection between them broken here but
as he points out Tanya cortex Pawn walks
into a pin you win the pinned piece the
bishop because the queen behind is
attacked it is undefended as well so
Queen F4 what a move these top players
they're just surprise us on every single
turn Queen F4 not an obvious one but
Maxine doesn't of course have to take
this Pawn yet he can play around the
problem is you are facing the kind of
idea of the pawn coming up to G4 hitting
the bishop
stuff is happening on the king side
something is brewing here
uh how does Maxine Vaseline grav
continue to defend so accurately does it
feel like a game that will end up with a
winner
that way at the moment a draw is still a
kind of a distant dream for both players
any end game would favor Black because a
bishop is better with pawns on both
sides of the board we saw in the last
game between janapanishi and ferrugia
that a knight struggles when their pawns
on both flanks black with the Superior
Pawn structure as well if the Queens
disappear there's no Checkmate and black
is very happy
so long term Maxine can be happy but he
needs to get to that long-term situation
uh Magnus really interesting idea that
you pointed out for him David with that
jeep on advancing forward G4 G5 and then
that F6 Pawn is safe forever and we can
imagine the queen landing on to that
eight six square from that age for a
point
so things are getting tricky end games
are far off and I agree with Kaya that
uh I don't know in who's favor again but
I think a decisive result is most likely
here and these two I mean I remember
them playing against each other 20 odd
years ago I mean I sound like an old man
there but uh they always seem to have
these really fascinating battles where
both sides seem to be playing for a win
they never play with the reverse gear on
they never play solid kind of boring
drawish chess uh sometimes it is a draw
but that's because chess has that nature
sometimes but it's always Dynamic and
wow attacking the White Queen jumping in
we see a trade taking back with the pawn
this is really clever kicking the White
Knight away and where does this white
knight run to
not an easy decision this Knight has
five or six very logical squares this
Magnus gonna jump forward jump back jump
to the side of the board
Maxime he's just trying to trade off
pieces now to solidify his King
Dom position still Tanya what do you
think here really complicated and the
more you look at it the more you realize
how difficult it is to actually make a
decision with the Knight the most
natural looking Square E5 you want to
get to the central of the center of the
board but I think that there's a problem
with that David because once you put
your knight on E5 it might be possible
for black to actually capture the pawn
on F6 because now your knight on E5 is
hanging in several situations and also
notice the tender Pawn on C3 so if you
go G4 with the initial idea black and
start targeting that Knight on E5 with
the move Rook to E8 you take F5 I take
E5 if you move the Knight away my queen
gets out of the pin with the temple
winning the C3 Pawn yeah and uh okay
maybe maybe not grabbing the pawn yet
just because of Rook to C1 hitting the
queen then taking the bishop but I think
your exact idea is correct uh here Tanya
there might be ways to finesse this at
the very least you get out the pin Maybe
by uh hitting this Knight it's just
complicated and I think both players are
calculating this exact variation right
now because as you mentioned Magnus
would dream of putting his Knight on
such an active Central Square that's
where Knights belong in the Middle where
they control eight nice uh squares there
but tactically if it doesn't work you
just cannot get away with it and then
you might have to retreat for example or
might have to land on the edge of the
Border uh something slightly less
desirable
yeah and Knight D2 Knight H4 not as
desirable the other move that I would be
considering is Knight to G5 again to try
and continue the attack but it does feel
like there should be tactics working for
black uh do you see anything here David
after Knight to G5
yeah it's not an easy question and I was
expecting the eval bar to drop really
low because Knight G5 feels loose but
maybe it's it's still fine you're
consistent you're going maybe for
checkmate in the next few turns
um this does look pretty scary and again
it all rests on the fact that whether
black can take on F6 eliminating the key
attack at that pawn if white steps
forward now then
tactics here no I was thinking Queen C3
but I always forget that you've got this
move Rook to C1 hitting the queen on the
bishop yeah next move
Bishop maybe it's just again like you
said earlier a counter-attack against
the White Knight and now if the Knight
just drops back takes this Pawn for
example oh what next maybe Queen to H4 I
mean this is crazy just pinning and
Clinging On what a position this is yeah
this one could go either way these moves
are not easy we're having to pause here
we're hesitating because it's so uh
tricky these tactics are unique very
rare these types of patterns and that's
why Magnus now dropping down to three
minutes
he's less than he Maximus got twice the
amount of time on his clock struggling
to say things here but uh for Magnus he
has to take some takes a big decisions
under three minutes and it's quite a
messy position I think for maxim it's a
bit of a dream start
definitely if he continues to keep this
High Pace whoa Knight to E5 we thought
this was really risky but yeah Maxine
keeping this High pace and calculating
so well so far using that master degree
working out all the tricks tactics
will you dig on F6 I think he will
what's he gonna go for if you don't then
suddenly white does whip up quite a
promising attack maybe you could start
by bringing the blackbrook to the center
and then try and take that poor next
move but he goes for it and look at the
speed David with which he took he's just
calculated everything and Magnus has as
well because he immediately responds
with Knight G4 that does invite black to
capture a second pawn it does Magnus
used this move Knight to G4 yesterday in
his successful win against uh Yanda
pomnishi in a different scenario of
course but now he's attacking the black
queen Amy for some tracks we talk about
Queen and Knight as a attacking combo
but is it worth two Pawns I think he's
got to go for this let's jump in again
uh right now there is tactics there has
Chaos on the board this one is far from
a draw because black could go two pawns
up hitting this rook in the corner as
well I don't know if white moves The
Rook I guess you can you can also flick
in a night check first but most likely
you have to defend the rook and gain
time against the black queen this is on
the board right now the black queen can
choose a bunch of different squares if
she centralizes White's idea is to check
and next move take this bishop and we'll
get a position such as this one you're
calling it out it's happening on the
board Queen D4 play at night eight six
Maxine will step up with the King and
that exposed King will give Magnus
enough compensation the dream would be a
rook lift to get into the attack but
notice how the black queen controls key
squares for uh the white truck not to be
able to do so aha yeah centralized Queen
covers everything look how strong she is
she might even defend later on along
this diagonal so Black's Queen keeping
the white Rook caged white can give a
check but it would be enough the black
talking just running and black is still
a pawn up even if white takes on F5 next
move why is maximum tanking here good
question Tanya
is he what is he considering I think
he'll move his King up but he might be
just sliding it across to f8 uh yeah or
time to start thinking maybe he's just
looking deep into the future and okay he
eventually does play the move we were
expecting and Magnus will now capture
this black Bishop before the opportunity
uh disappears good air quality for
Magnus at least he's perked up it feels
like he's uh slightly less lethargic
than he was a few moves ago and King to
h8 nice hiding spot
now the F7 Pawn is hanging because of
that check that Magnus just gave forcing
a Maxim's King to that h8 square so
Queen F7 is a threat and not just the F7
Pawn the C5 one as well weak who would
you pick here Tanya
I like White's position despite being
down upon I think it's time for maxim to
find a way to just bail out to safety
here and I think he's trying to do that
well don't grab on E3 right now F takes
E3 would be a huge blunder after Queen
takes Pawn you're gonna end up losing a
rook yeah double attacks do not take on
E3 if you're Magnus Carlsen or anyone or
anyone but what else to do how does
Magnus guide this game towards safety
remember he's still a pawn down and if
you can't take this pawn it might
continue advancing down the board
yeah the I don't know who's playing for
a win or who's playing to bail out over
here anymore yeah I love this uh comment
from the twitch chat it feels like
Magnus has been preparing traps of
course but vashi the graph setting traps
too
both players just playing really high
quality uh chassis at the bar despite
how complicated it's been it's barely
moved yeah that's true it's been in the
center the whole time
really high accuracy I bet from both
players and fall into E3 on the board
that's such an instructive moment but
Maxim to play this move to make sure
that you use this opportunity to open up
your opponent's king for that counter
play also he can think about getting
that Rook from a to G8 at the right
moment to build more on this attack but
E3 right now Magnus touching the one and
a half minute mark
and he's got a big decision to make at
this point I must be uncomfortable also
with that black queen just eyeing up
everything in the center of the Border
that's that's awesome Kyle yes I would
be very uncomfortable with the white
pieces here
he's burnt more than half of his
remaining time on this one move he's
about to drop down to around one minute
and I think he might have to let a black
porn sit on the second rank this black
porn of course is taboo you cannot
capture it so you've got to let it
advance
how to escape here with a draw he takes
the F7 pawn and what happens next is
this black pawn going to continue
marching down the board look at the
interest that's been peaked by her by
this last move in vashilograph suddenly
head in hands calculating uh mood and
pawns E2 or do you take on F2 I think if
you take on F2 you're just releasing a
lot of tension I think Magnus is hoping
for that decision but if Maxime goes
through E2 he's going for more that is
ambitious play and that's the big
decision what does Maxine want right now
after E2 Queen D1 is a huge threat on
the board you want to try to clean that
pawn with this uh Tempo so I think white
will be forced to bring the Rook to the
defense to the Central Square of E1
notice how black screen is also tied
down to defending his own her own King
on h8 controlling that diagonal but this
gets really complex so moves like Queen
E5 keep the tension here yeah Queen E5
defends the pawn keeps this diagonal
covered so no checks still and next move
the black Rook is coming and defending
this born
to me this is quite attractive for black
it feels like white maybe is able to
make a draw but white at least has a
passive Rook so why does the one
fighting for equality uh he's going to
go for E2 you think he is it's going to
happen David play for the win that's
what we want to see Pawn takes porn here
would allow the White Queen to recapture
and most likely here we would see a
drawn end game uh for example if black
moves The Rook uh Rook B8 rook f8 and
this game would likely end in a draw
after the Queens come off on the next
turn but vashadograph can be more
ambitious here and he's got half an eye
on the clock surely
push the pawn Maxim play for the win
entertain us
and it just feels like not just playing
to the galleries but also a move that's
very objective in the position you keep
that pawn alive you keep your chances
alive and this is the thing right when
you're playing against Magnus uh you've
got to take these gutsy decisions for
those opportunities and I think uh
Magnus right now probably hoping a
little bit that Maxine bails out with
Ponte spawn hmm
so that's what we're looking for now
yeah it's all about that black people
and we're expecting it to move if it
moves down one square to E2 one square
closer to promotion that means Maxim is
all out for the win if he trades off a
set of Pawns most locally this game will
fizzle out but the only downside for
maxim is the black king is so open so
weak the temptation to get out of the
game with a draw must be high but he
plays for the win he keeps the tension
but
but David this last move Rook to G8 wow
okay so you still can't take on E3
because then you just lose the Rook or
end up getting checkmated well Rook G8
he is ambitious it's not E2 but he keeps
the tension shows the nurse Magnus leans
forward and he's now down under a minute
on the clock about to tick down to 30
seconds because he Maxime has played a
move that Magnus was not expecting wow
Magnus was looking at the two moves that
we were discussing there either Pawn
takes Pawn or Pawn to E2 but a third
option was available and Magnus 20
seconds now oh he plays a good move I
think just of forcing this black pawn to
make a decision finally but it cost him
a bulk of his time and we we've seen
today what happens when the clocks sit
down even in the most simple of
positions uh blunders do occur so okay
he's trying to force the black pawn to
trade off
maybe it's still safe enough for Magnus
this last move was key
yeah because now there's just really no
way to go E2 anymore and that's a nice
trick because I and I think we should
show that David you can go E2 setting up
a trap of your own that if white was to
capture on E2 you've got Queen D1 check
but the reason that eval bar stays level
is that white has got a Perpetual with
Queen F6 Queen f8 at the very end so
it's really not possible for black to
get ambitious anymore with that pawn
push and I think Maxime has taken a
decision the other one of simplifying
with capturing on F2 and most likely now
this game should fizzle out towards a
draw still some imbalance because white
has a two versus one advantage on the
king side whereas black has a pass Pawn
uh on the C file but now we go we see
Queens forced off the board Rook f8
forces uh Queen trade due to this pin
and who is going to profit from this end
game it feels very very level here and
uh we are expecting two end game uh
greats like these two to get a draw
eventually
but what a first game though it seems
that this will be an intense battle
between two fantastic players here in
the winners final this is only game one
out of four rapid games in this matchup
to decide who is the winner in the
winners final and go straight through to
the Grand Final to be played on Friday
is there any chance for a win here for
any player or is this just gonna be a
draw it is an end game it is Magnus but
it's also Maxim it's also Maxim and
especially in end games where Maxim can
calculate or he can wear his kind of
very mathematical where it's forcing and
it's kind of very kind of clear
objective evaluation he knows exactly
what to do if it's more maneuvering kind
of type of position slower type of
positions maybe that favors Magnus but
this one is just a dead draw with Rooks
on the board level number of Pawns
should should be a draw I say it quietly
because I should but do you see in
Maxim's play and this is just a general
question then about my Sims play but do
you see in his style that he is a
mathematician definitely I mean I've
been playing him since I was nine years
old and I just cannot survive these
positions where it's pure calculation
there's an a point there's a kind of B
Point C point and he can just work his
way there it's so hard to keep up with
him to keep up with that level of
accuracy that he uh has and he's so
quick about it as well that's why he's
so good at speed chess he sees things
instantly but if you get him in a maybe
kind of more theoretical position where
it's
yeah less straightforward then sometimes
you stand a chance
but Magnus is keeping this game going
Magnus is the only one who uh can hope
for a win here but not easy not easy and
that's a really nice way to keep the
balance the one that Maxim has chosen
because white really could not have
picked up the D4 Pawn with either The
Rook or the king if the king would have
snapped it up then the black Rook just
jumps back to the spot where it came
from gives a check and let's just show
that uh wins the G4 Pawn on the other
hand if the Rook which I would have
captured the default Bond then you lose
the A3 pawn and that's basically a draw
for so Maxine finding a really good
resource to keep the balance
yeah and uh he's put his Rook behind the
passport very logical maybe trying to
push this Pawn later but Magnus keeps
the tension and uh will we see a dance
between the Rooks the black Rook now
going after this weak white pawn and
next going after this weak white porn it
feels like this game should still be a
draw but wow Magnus is he going for the
black H porn he is he's really gambling
now Magnus Carlson he's allowing the two
black passports on the queen side to
live because he wants his connected past
pawns on the other flank and suddenly
this is not an obvious draw anymore
seconds on the clock for both players
now this is getting into spicy territory
gives up his Rook if the white king
takes the black Rook now Black's Pawn
would have made a new Queen suddenly
Magnus has got to be really careful to
save this but maybe he just goes around
with checks and that's if he wants a
bailout he can just start checking the
king uh Maxim can come back with the
King controlling the d8 square so Magnus
doesn't have that still can't take the
Rook
Magnus is playing for more Magnus once
more look at this he's gobbled up the
remaining black pawn and he's gone
around the G and H pawns are connected
White's Rook is really passive though
this should still be a draw but not easy
anymore Maxim
to show accuracy I think Maxim has shown
accuracy so far but he needs to keep it
up every move it does count a lot The
Rook comes back if the king moves
towards the Deep Pawn blackstroke will
start targeting white spawns
he keeps the pressure on and it's all
about the fact that white can't free up
his own Rook for activity and I think
he's done it I think he saved this one
are we in grinding mode now we're in
grinding mode but the problem is there
aren't too many plans remaining you
cannot maneuver around forever here if
you're Magnus Carlson you have to make a
decision if you go for black spawn you
lose your other uh pawns the white pawns
vulnerable and I think we will see the
drawer there we go
what a game long one but it ends with
the draw the first game and the Winner's
final maximum had the black pieces and
then this one and then pull some
problems for Magnus Carlsen but it is a
drawing he will have the white pieces in
the next one
put some ups and downs there David can
you take us through some highlights some
real ups and downs and it was a real
fighting draw to the end to the bitter
uh end there and after Pawn to E3 I was
impressed by both players here Magnus
Carlsen of course didn't fall into
Maxim's trap of uh taking this Pawn
allowing a double attack against his
King and Rook instead he grabbed the F
Pawn and Maxim rather than going for a
draw rather than bailing out here to
safety continued the fight Rook to G8
now Magnus had a really narrow path to
equality but he found it he knew this
Pawn could not be allowed to March any
further he played the move Rook to E1 we
saw a trade and after the Queens came
off a drawn Rook end game but both
players testing each other setting those
traps and at the moment canceling each
other out
seems like this will be an intense fight
in the Winner's final between Mel and
Magnus still three rapid games to go in
their match up
we want to tell you guys to join the
brand new variants Community series we
are looking to Crown the best players in
chess variant starting with the King of
the Hill so you can enter weekly Arenas
each Thursday tomorrow is a Thursday so
that's the first chance for you to join
and to prove your skills in King of the
Hill and book your ticket to the
championship at the end of the variants
cycle King of the Hill I hear you
talking about that a lot David King of
the Hill one of my favorite variants
yeah the goal is to get your king to the
center one of the four Central squares
as quickly as possible before your
opponent E4 D4 E5 or D5 is it a favorite
of yours as well Tanya as much as I
watched a bit of it it is very
entertaining and uh you know I was just
wondering watching this last game that
we did as you said it's going to be a
big fight and we set the tone for that
what will be the accuracy of this player
of these players because it felt like
such precise play from both Magnus and
from Maxime and we're getting an update
Maxim with a 99.81 accuracy and Magnus
99.5 whoa I mean how incredible is that
in such a long game as well these guys
are good super good wow they are playing
some very accurate moves Magnus and
Maxim they are definitely sharp today in
this big fight in the winners final it
continues after a short break
[Music]
September Bots are here and it's time
for a Monumental Clash this Barbarian
might not Crush you on the board but he
certainly can Crush you with the board
speaking of crushing this giant is a
living Siege Tower usually found in
groups goblins are fond of sharp pointy
objects and other people's pieces
battleheart in Valkyrie might give you a
game once she's done arm wrestling a
Golem
this hog rider and his Noble Steed might
give you a headache or two skeletons
adore her though fear her you'll need to
bring your A-game if you want to be this
witch yes that probably is a rabbit up
his sleeve or a huge Fireball with your
name on it we hear Wizards are pretty
good at chess
not just a killing machine Pekka loves
tiny butterflies but you're probably not
a butterfly so watch out
the Archer Queen thinks highly of
herself and for good reason she is a
skilled tactician deadly opponent and
your worst nightmare play them all on
chess.com
anyone who has played even a small
amount of Chess especially online is
familiar with the concept of an opening
trap we've all fallen for one at some
point or another in many cases a failed
opening trap will leave you with a
terrible position but not always we've
compiled 10 opening traps that are not
only guaranteed to work but if your
opponent doesn't fall for them exactly
you'll still have a decent position
number two legal's mate this opening
trap if your opponent cooperates can
lead to one of the most beautiful and
famous checkmates in chess named after
sir de legal it dates back all the way
to the 18th century it occurs in an
Italian game and in this position we
play Knight C3 black might play Bishop
G4 pinning the Knight to White's Queen
and we can play H3 forcing black to make
a decision about the light squared
Bishop if they retreat with Bishop H5
this allows the brilliant Knight takes
E5 where a free Queen is off offered if
black takes the bait and grabs the queen
can you spot the famous mate in two
that's right Bishop takes F7 King E7
which is forced Knight D5 mate so if our
opponent does not take the queen bait is
this a dubious position not at all
Black's best response is Knight takes E5
allowing white to win the light squared
Bishop with Queen takes H5 and after
black takes the bishop on C4 white can
win the piece right back with a queen
check on B5 picking up the Knight on the
following turn no matter what Black's
response is white is up a pawn with
control of the center a great place to
be out of the opening
[Music]
we're getting ready for game two between
nvl and Magnus Carlsen and the winners
final before that happens we do love
puzzles and before this tournament David
traveled to London and challenged people
on the streets in some very nice chess
puzzles hi everyone here we are today in
Sunny London where I'm going to be
approaching strangers on the street to
figure out whether they can crack this
code and solve some difficult puzzles
today we're going to be looking at three
positions if you solve the easy one you
get five pounds Medium Level 10 pounds
and the hard level for 15 pounds James
Richards London do you play chess I do
play chess it's a little bit of a
giveaway behind yeah favorite Chef's
website be careful
uh yeah good answer wait to play and
mate in one
[Music]
okay Bishop to A6 okay nice
way to play in mate in two this time uh
Rook H3 Queen H6
and then and then Queen G7
are you sure no no just ignore all of
that ignore all of that we can just cut
that right I don't know just put me out
of my menu
okay the answer is Queen takes H7 check
s and then work slides across
how mean am I being on a scale of one to
ten
all right wait to play and mating two
I'm gonna do important takes
A7 not sure yeah unfortunately that's
not the right answer okay
it's Rook to A6 oh that makes a lot of
sense you did solve the easy puzzles
yeah I'm here for my fiber so you did
win five pounds there we go thank you
very much what are you gonna do with it
go towards like a quarter of adjustment
nice one without one solving your uh
your easiest chest puzzles
yeah I say easy it's all relative right
yeah and uh yeah a lot of the players in
London did very very well I say players
I mean we were approaching bystanders uh
members of the public and everyone's
into chess these days yeah yeah and
puzzles uh I always talk about them like
they're super fun for you Tanya being a
chess player as well are they fun or is
chat uh puzzles only homework for you no
it's a lot of fun I think it's a fun
part of the homework and I think it's a
great way you of course got to work on
all aspects of the game but this is
probably the most entertaining so even
when I'm commentating here every day I
try and get a puzzle Russian oh nice
survival mode very nice very nice and
actually in the tour finals last season
in San Francisco we did have a very
difficult puzzle that also the players
wanted to join in on solving
uh White to play made into this is a
puzzle for our viewers let's see how
quickly you can get it I'm gonna start
the timer now okay
not so easy yeah yeah
so imagine choose you can usually find
by processor of elimination
um okay let me see is there is it zuck's
wrong
that could be
there's it's sometimes this in these
cases
so
let me try and
trying to think yeah
I'm assuming first of all
no that's
[Music]
the terms that I'm that I can't solve
this is usually because it's a it's uh
it's a check on the first moment it
didn't didn't occur to me
oh wait a sec wait a second
[Music]
a minute down a minute down yeah usually
time pressure no no
I just wanna I just wanna solve it
I don't I don't really care about the
time
if it's any consolation David said this
is one of the hardest mating twos
okay is
it
okay so I gotta consider every
where together
[Music]
are you sure
no but I mean once I saw the move I
started
it's hard to be yeah but Queen D4 takes
away the D4 squares of rookie 3 is made
otherwise it's not D6 or Knight C5 is
that it is that your final answer
yeah that is my final answer well done
you got it in about less than two
minutes not bad
he didn't solve it in the end he's so
competitive yeah but that was you said
it David one of the hardest or maybe the
hardest made into you've ever seen yeah
some chessboards was a lot of fun but
also frustrating and how challenging
they are and uh he got it eventually he
got it eventually Magnus Carlsen solving
that puzzle now he has to solve MBL they
are tied after one game and the winner
his final game two is now about to start
and MBL will have the white pieces in
this one Magnus Carlsen up against the
player that used to play only one
opening but now he mixes it up is is it
more difficult now to play MBL after
he's changed his strategies much more
difficult than Maxim I don't think it's
any coincidence that he's had some good
success just in the last year or two
especially in speed chess why uh kind of
while mixing and matching his openings
he's keeping his opponents guessing he's
not a sitting Target anymore especially
with the black pieces and his results
reflect that and okay a Sicilian and
will we see a sicilian night off Magnus
meanwhile snacking uh wow on the board
David and this is Maxine vashilograph's
specialty when Maxima has black well at
least it used to be Magnus using his
opponent's weapon against him oh
psychology
uh so much Dynamics when you do that
because one would think that your
opponent's strength you don't want to go
into that but uh it can also play in
your favor by disbalancing your opponent
it's something that Maxi might not have
expected although we've seen Magnus go
for the night off uh so it's going to be
interesting I'm still thinking about the
near perfect game that we just had in
game one yeah a 99.8 and 99.5 accuracy
perfect chess and when you have perfect
chess it's to draw guy you said Magnus
has to solve the puzzle it's not going
to be an easy one yeah yeah when Maxim
plays
99.8 I mean that's that's a close to
perfect as you get right I I start
wondering what one move wasn't the
accurate one yeah I think we'll have to
do a deep study into that one move that
both players played that were inaccurate
or naughty naughty but uh yeah even the
chess goddess Kaiser I don't think she
could play 99
accuracy uh like those two did in the
last game so F3 and still a well-known
position Magnus is pausing here there
are various ways black can approach this
position but I like the fact that again
it's another fighting opening the
Sicilian is the most counter-attacking
opening in chess uh it's an imbalanced
Pawn structure likely we'll see opposite
side castling and
um really really promising another great
fight ahead it's going to be harder to
be accurate in this game I will say than
the previous one because it is one of
those wild positions that will
yeah we'll rumble on yeah Magnus has to
solve mvl is a feature chat he's going
to be stuck on this puzzle for a while
and this last move by uh Maxim F3 also
hints at uh this move I was just about
to say you want to start advancing on
the king side with your pawns G4 once
again the Frenchman with three names he
makes his intentions clear he is going
for those messy chaotic positions I
think we are going to see the opposite
side castling I think it's very likely
now Maxima's basically declared that the
white king is not costling on the king
side yeah it never will now that he's
thrown uh pawns forward on that flank so
the white king is going left it's going
to the queen side and Magnus can start
preparing an attack on that flank but
how to deal with these pawns flowing
forward uh it's slightly surprising to
me that Magnus would choose the night
off basically playing on the opponent's
home territory and then pause this early
and still relatively well known Waters
okay he brings his Knight forward
clearing a square for the other Black
Knight to use potentially Maxine
advances the thing is Right Maxine plays
this with black which means that he
knows this with white also really well
because of course when you're preparing
at that level uh the kind of opening
preparation that these players have
Maxim knows the ins and outs of night
off so where does Magnus plan to get his
Advantage here
yeah um to me it's surprising when I
prepare for my opponents when I study my
opponents I look in the database I look
at all of their games I build an opening
tree and I see okay here is their
favorite opening here is the opening
they score strongest in and then I avoid
it at all costs but Magnus he's pretty
much done the opposite
um for example if my I know my opponent
plays the French defense themselves as
black I will never play it as uh black
against them because I know that they're
familiar with all the little details the
nuances
yeah Magnus going against conventional
chess wisdom yeah when you're playing
against Maxim don't play the French
unless you're Magnus Carlsen
is that psychological though because
that that would be the normal strategy
mvl knows that most players won't play
that opening against him and then Magnus
does just you know showing him I don't
care I will beat you in that opening as
well true it's the Mind Games it's the
kind of fight for psychological
dominance if you can beat your opponent
at what they know best then you really
break their Spirit yeah yeah so imagine
if Magnus wins this game yeah this would
be huge but that's far off right now uh
and I think it's Maxine with the last
two moves that he's indicated that he's
going to go for uh for the king and
that's pun intended Black's king and the
King of Chess here as well Knight D7
falls back with the knights and I think
it's time for white to step up with the
queen get that King to safety and then
look at Harry the H Pawn advancing a
down the board to assist Gary there
white has already made attack you called
it Tanya a very logical move now white
king is ready to jump over to safety uh
hiding behind those white Knights on the
queen side it's going to be very
difficult for black to whip up any type
of initiative on that flank I don't see
where the black king really wants to
hide either do you hide behind uh could
you kind of Castle into it as we say
hide behind your pawns on the king side
but white has a ready-made attack there
I've always been terrified of these
types of positions my entire career just
because they are so uh kind of
irrational it's so hard to get a grip
every move is just kind of living life
on the edge for both but here the stakes
are higher for black yeah every move is
a high responsibility move in this kind
of a position and this kind of an
opening and Magnus really burning the
clock so a little bit more unfamiliar
for Magnus than it is for Maxime it's
sort of been his bread and butter his
whole life the night off for Maxine
Russia La Grave and this is what Magnus
has up his sleeves so David you said
black skin has got no safe ground and
because there hasn't been a shot Castle
he strikes uh in that flank right now
asking Maxine what he wants to intend
you would love to go H4 but let's point
out that there is a pin along that
diagonal so it really doesn't help after
a move like H4 black can actually just
capture on G5 because you can't
recapture with the pawn yeah and
magnus's idea is to force the opponent
to capture it with a piece and here he
will happily offer a trade and actually
long term here black is doing pretty
well because this Pawn is isolated so if
it ever gets to the end game which is
far from a guarantee then black will
have weaknesses to stare at and actually
his idea is very opportunistic because
he does also rely on the trick that pawn
takes Pawn is met by a queen check
suddenly just before the white uh King
uh kind of scoots over to safety on the
queen side it gets checked and uh of
course you can't Castle when you're in
track so you have to block or move the
king and for example if you block with
your Bishop suddenly The Black Queen
just Retreats takes this pawn and same
issue for white this is long term a huge
weakness in any end game
especially if the Queens disappear and
of course black has conveniently offered
that trade of Queens note how the
knights defend each other as well so
White's Bishop can never really take
this knight uh Magnus yeah he's really
kind of showing uh that he's flexible in
these types of positions I don't know if
this is opening preparation he spent a
bit of time but H6 it's very rare to be
able to play this as black and he's
found the correct moment and for the
first time forced Maxine to think yeah
I'm very concrete player and Maxim has
slowed down now that we've discussed
these ideas you don't want to take on 86
because of the check you don't want to
go H4 because the pin doesn't work out
in your favor I think Maxime has to
think about long Castle get your king to
safety and I think he's played the move
and David now the point is you want to
play Bishop to E7 wow Magnus does it I
thought this just loses the D6 Pawn yeah
he's willing to sacrifice a pawn just to
get into the end game here Magnus
Carlsen Bishop takes Bishop now does
allow the uh D6 Pawn to drop it's only
defended once it's attacked twice and I
think we're headed in this direction
we'll see the Queen's traded off black
will most likely step the king forward
forcing the black the white Rook back
and then he's going to try and stack up
his Rooks against this weakness it's a
whole Pawn here I'm skeptical I think
objectively White's doing pretty well
the evaluation bar slightly in White's
favor but Magnus we all know his
expertise in the end game he's just
playing for his type of position having
been maybe out prepared in the opening
but surely when you're down upon in this
position you're just trying to hold this
one
yeah it is Magnus you never know first
he gets an equal end game well he first
he starts with the worst engine then an
equal end game then he wins that's how
he rolls yeah he's got this incredible
ability to not only uh convert winning
positions flawlessly but somehow win
worse positions as well uh so Magnus
right now this is our live board and
Maxine vashir lagrav still thinking if
he wants to go into that end game and
challenge Magnus where Magnus really
does thrive but I'm expecting Queen
takes Pawn right now because if not that
what else yeah Maxine has kind of burnt
his Bridges uh he's not going to get an
attack now a direct attack at least
against the black king
so why not grab material you have this
slightly worse Pawn structure for white
on the king side so you might as well
suffer for something
often that's just how top level chess
works these days someone gives a little
bit of material whether it's a pawn
whether it's a piece and then they have
this long-term compensation in return
and it will be a theme of the game white
extra porn versus Black's kind of
control on the king side and fashion
graph is clearly reluctant he knows it's
a Magnus type of position I think uh
maybe he's just scared of the opponent
here understandably but eventually he
will surely go and grab this Pawn who
can resist free material
Maxine can and I really like this move
David I was actually thinking about this
because you want to come in with a Tempo
and the B7 Pawn is so much more
important than the D6 Pawn which is a
lifelong weakness in the position of
that because the D6 Pawn guy will always
be under Fire it's not going anywhere
the queen and the Rook are lined up
against this but this is tricky because
Maxim is inviting Magnus to actually
jump in with the Knight to defend that
B7 Pawn but that's the whole point of
this now when you grab D6 David the
Black Knights are disconnected and after
this queen trade suddenly there is
pressure on that V6 Knight which is no
longer defended by its own friend the
other night yeah suddenly white would
have a decisive Advantage there's no
time to evict the white Rook like we
wanted to earlier like Magnus wanted to
earlier because Rook takes Knight and
white would win material instead you
have to play really ugly moves like
retreating to the back rank suddenly
white is a pawn up and this Knight looks
really beautiful actually uh putting
pressure here Black's Pieces Just
discombobulated as Simon would say and
uh just unable to really fight back and
as you mentioned Knight takes Pawn a
huge threat you actually want to win
this pawn and then the D6 Pawn in that
order only so how does Magnus first
protect this one safely
I mean Rook p8 is a very ugly move you
never want to make a move like that uh
it's possible but not an absolute
disaster yeah I think this is last
resort for Magnus if he finds nothing
better he'll defend his Pawn with his
Rook but nobody likes to make their
pieces passively you said ugly and
that's the definition of ugly Rook to B8
on a really passive square a whole night
three points is tying down a rook and
pawn with five six points together and
okay we get engine suggestions just
below the board and we see some moves
King to C8 there it says that means
Castle's Queen side uh being the best
actually by quite a distance Black's
best move here is to Castle into the
firing line not fearing any attack and
just saying okay we can go for an end
game and then the black king is actually
pretty decently placed defending the
pawn on B7 Black's second best move is
your uh move there we've both turned
that ugly here Tanya wrote to B8 but
everything else gives white a huge
Advantage it's on the board he goes for
it I think this is more human castling
Queen side feels a bit risky that it
would have been a really Airy side of
the board lots of holes around so we can
understand magnuses vision and it was
only these two moves right whatever you
do you have to defend the B7 Pawn that
collapses the position collapses so it
was between these three moves and as you
said from a human perspective long
Castle just looks extremely scary so a
Magnus going for Rook to B8
I might be tempted to actually not trade
the Queen's hair because now Black's
King is just stuck in the center forever
yeah stuck in the center and this Pawn
isn't running away anytime soon so you
can snack on it later let's see what
Maxine brush the graph decides to do uh
yeah really tense position here Magnus
is basically just sitting and waiting
and saying please take the pawn and he
does so we're headed into the end game
now
Black's King is surely going to advance
kicking away that white Rook there we go
and it's all about how weak are white
kingside pawns he's a pawn up he what is
dominant on the queen side long term
he's going to win that but uh does black
have cancer play Tanya and David the
counter player that you were pointing
out earlier with blackstroke Rooks
doubling up on the H line we see another
point of Maxim's move with the Knight to
A5 that now the queen side Rick is
actually tied down to defending that B7
Pawn so not that easy to create play
against the H2 Pawn of white on the king
side which actually frees up Maxine's
Rook on H1 yeah I mean I would take
white hair every day usually I prefer
the compensation in terms of kind of
long-term strategic trumps but I don't
see how black looks at least speedily
gets any initiative going here I don't
think Magnus is enjoying this position
that much he's not and Maxim's played so
confidently he's also up on the clock
here he's up upon right now Magnus still
has to neutralize uh White's edge here
has to prove his compensation for that
backbone and I'm curious is there any
way we can check the accuracy levels up
to this point I have a feeling Magnus uh
his accuracy levels may be a bit lower
than maxims
oh if you yeah I think we need our
viewers to tell us check on chess.com
events and yeah let's check out those
accuracy levels which are just through
the roof so far in this match Magnus
does move his Knight away right now it
says 100. oh wow
yeah but I'm wondering if this is not
updated oh wow we got an update on that
I mean it was close to 100 in that game
one and Maxine has been on fire this
last these last couple of months but of
course Magnus has just been Unstoppable
this whole year yeah Magnus has been in
beast mode boss mode throughout the year
so far it's the final boss yeah he is
that big boss in order to beat him well
in order to win any tournament you have
to get through him first that's the
issue and Knight to F6 a nice move
there's actually a trap in this position
it looks like white can trick black but
actually would get tricked in the
process uh one move not to play would be
a very tempting Bishop takes A6 it looks
like you're deflecting away the black
pawn in order to land a devastating
night Fork a night check uh forcing the
black king back and then feasting on the
Black Brook but trixes get tricked here
Bishop takes Pawn would be met by a
skewer the black Rook moves across you
can take as many points as you want but
you will lose peace in the process so
some sneaky tactics here Magnus has said
a trap which of course
boxing won't fall into and he does just
shift his Rook to G1
what's the idea here is he going after
this one
I think so uh and it's so tempting as
well right because it forces black into
the defense of that Bond it's on the
board uh David Maxim going for all the
weaknesses here uh does Magnus now have
to fall back with the Knight because
losing a second Pawn just uh would be
disastrous here yeah it's not pleasant
this choice for Magnus either he has to
retreat this night go back where he came
from this Knight was on this Square just
two moves ago he's lost time Magnus or
he has to retreat the other Black Knight
and uh this one doesn't look great
either you've lost some control over the
D5 Square I'm wondering if white can
ever trade Bishops now the more pieces
you trade uh the more you can kind of
accentuate highlight the fact you're a
porn up feels like it's turning in
Maxim's favor valuation bar slightly on
white side uh too and his accuracy is
99.3 mvl Magnus is 98.9 he's down to 98
Magnus slacking yeah slacking
unacceptable yeah
wow the just the level these two are are
on today it's incredible really putting
up an amazing fight in the winners final
this is gonna be I mean obviously it's
gonna be super hard to just get in a win
today yeah and that means maybe we will
have Armageddon
yeah this match very well could go down
to the wire and we've seen Magnus have
this fantastic year he seems absolutely
Unstoppable but even for Maxine One
feels like it's been sort of a
Resurgence for him these last few months
the kind of Chess that he's been playing
uh I mentioned the Tata steel as well as
in SCC making it to the semi-finals he's
such a speech test specialist this is
going to be a close close battle it is
rightfully the Winner's final oh amazing
yeah MBL proving that he belongs here in
the Champions chest tour it is uh very
nice to finally see a match between
these two this season two players so
I've grown up together in that golden
1990 generation with you as well David
what do you remember of Maxim growing up
and competing with him as well yeah and
actually Maxim is one of the players I
knew the best when I was young
um I played him in these I think first
time was in the world or was it European
under 10 championship and then I
actually had a match against him when we
were both 9 10 old I went over to France
I flew over to France we played an
eight-game rapid match wow and he beat
me the score was five and a half two and
a half and I remember even back then he
was playing the Sicilian night off he
was playing the grunfeld every single
game he stuck with those openings for
what was it 25 years and
um very successful with them and I just
remember every time it got down to a
calculation type of position he would
see deeper than me and uh
yeah it's been an uphill struggle for me
against him ever since he's always been
one of my kind of uh kryptonites oh
um but yeah Magnus as well I met very
young and of course pretty decent player
too but yeah these two have had some
great fights throughout the years it's
always been epic it's always been very
very close and I think the fact that
they're the same generation means that
they know each other very well as well
and Maxim knows uh that Magnus there's
only kind of two scenarios where he
struggles either you attack him and you
catch him cold and you kind of Checkmate
Magnus or you frustrate him that's why
Magnus I think walked away from World
Championship matches uh because he
didn't like these long grinds where it's
very level very drawish margin for
errors so small and I think that's what
he's doing now he's frustrating Magnus
it's like 99 percent accuracy it's so
close no blunders if you avoid black
blunders against Magnus you have a
chance
and uh Maxine playing this uh very very
strong brand of Chess right now
yeah these guys are amazing we agree
with you Andrea
and the bar is slightly up for and yeah
what do you think right now in this game
do you think is going to be a drawer do
you think we'll have a winner in it
if anyone's playing for a win it's got
to be Whitetail you're up upon you've
done everything right after winning that
Bond you've tied down Black's Rook to
defend upon on the queen side so that's
uh that's really one piece that right
now at least Magnus is playing without
you manage to take out your own pieces
you're also trading Black's most active
Bishop in the position uh trying to take
control of the lights Quest it's a big
fight for that D5 square and Maxim has
managed to offer a trade with his own
light Square Bishop so I really like
what Maxim's done again feels like a
game for two results I think most likely
will end in a drop but Magnus will have
to prove that
to prove it and we can see in his body
language he's not enjoying the task he's
just got to sit still right now black
and kind of wait for Maxine to come up
with a plan does Maxine go direct does
he kind of continue slow playing it
maybe start pushing some pawns on the
queen side
um yeah Maxim's at least burning some
time so Magnus will be optimistic about
that it's not easy it's not 100
straightforward to find a product Ive
plan for white it's really not and you
you've got to sort of be patient here
you know you were pointing out this
tactics with the bishop Tech spawn uh
we're getting that C6 Square now with
Black's Rook that has jumped forward
after Bishop takes Bond black actually
can't recapture the bishop on A6 because
now Knight C6 will win the game the word
Magnus is relying on instead of
recapturing on A6 is actually just
sliding with the Rook on it lining it up
with the bishop and the Knight so this
uh tactical blow still doesn't work but
it's always in the air
I think that's the main reason Maxim is
hesitating from Trading Bishops he wants
to at some point land this trick he's
always been so efficient since a young
age at finding these tactics and he does
play the move B3 so if Magnus is kind of
careless and allows this trap it could
eventually be winning for white doesn't
work quite yet but I love his last move
as well getting ready to improve his
King slightly then he'll improve his
Pawn slightly put every piece every Pawn
on perfect squares and then go for the
action meanwhile how does Magnus break
out this tension on the queen side that
you pointed out Tanya is so frustrating
you can never ever push your Pawn
because Knight C6 will always be a nasty
nasty Fork so you'll just tied down
forever and Magnus
he's the one to pause this time because
no obvious moves for him if he takes
this bishop off the board white will
happily recapture with the Knight and
this white knight might even come round
to a nice outpost on D5
no tempting options here for black you
just have to continue sitting passively
and hoping that white can't improve
it's sort of like a slow waiting game
and Magnus doesn't wait any longer he
does trade off the bishop and now the
plan that you're seeing it really wants
to be played right you reroute your
knight and you try to get to that D5
Square which is such a central point in
any uh in any Sicilians that we see 93
Knight D5 the C Pawn starts moving up
the board the king joins the party and
and the whole aim the idea is that you
have to be slow and steady but create a
passer on the queen side for winning
chances and Magnus is playing a game of
distraction here he's trying to remind
white that he has a weakness Maxim's H
Pawn is all alone and isolated right now
is he threatening to take it that's the
question and Maxine does he have to go
passive of course the answer is no if
you ask any top player do you want to
put a piece on a passive Square to
defend a mere Pawn but sometimes you
have to and there we go Maxime decides
he has to keep the material advantage
the rest of the board not quite in his
favor yet yeah it's all about playing it
slow and taking it slow right you want
to reroute your pieces but first just
don't lose out on that material
advantage that you have black can step
up to the H3 Square also targeting the
F3 Pawn but then white will simply slide
up with the rook and keep everything
defended the plan is clear after you've
saved all your pawns you can fall back
with the Knight land on D4 and
eventually because David let's not
forget even Black's Rooks are stuck on
the king side right you've got your army
that wants to Target the weakness but
that means that the queen side play is
free for white uh King comes in Pawn
start rolling and that's when we'll find
out whether this Advantage is going to
be enough or not yeah right now it's a
pawn Advantage but it's quite kind of uh
murky but it could become something much
more tangible if white does indeed
eventually land at night on D5 I
wouldn't Envy Magnus right now as you
say Tanya just broke here it looks like
the only active possibility but easily
shut down white covers all of the
weaknesses and then it's one-way traffic
on the other flank
Magnus needs to weave that in-game magic
how is he gonna achieve this four
minutes against five minutes accuracy
level is still pretty high I assume but
that could well turn in the next few
moves do you think he'll save it oh I
I'm okay I'm gonna back max seem here I
think Maxine big favorite actually to
win this game how about you Tanya
no Bush Maxim's gonna push I I think
it'll end in a draw I think Magnus will
find a way to survive this one uh but
it's gonna be it's gonna be a big big
uphill task I don't think anyone in the
world I would bet against Maxim in this
position but I think Magnus with his end
game touch
oh it's going to be a big fight and look
at that Magnus goes for very direct play
on The Queen side but this might give
Maxim more targets there with the pawns
moving forward well Knight anyway wanted
to land on that E3 Square Knight E3 what
Magnus wants to do is bring his own
knight from D7 to B6 to control the D5
Square
and Kaya you need to break the tie what
is your prediction
I'm gonna well I'm gonna bet on a win
for maxim he is you know the expert in
the opening that Magnus uh chose
and uh I think that was a mind game by
Magnus Carlsen because he thought well a
draw is the most likely if I win it
that's going to be a huge disappointment
for MBL so I'm gonna do the night dwarf
but I think Miel will be cold as ice and
win it I actually think if Magnus would
have would win with an idol
psychologically that's match over yeah
but the position that we have on the
board it's not going to happen
we're so influenced by who is playing
who because if Magnus was on the white
side I think we would all say he's going
to win this one porn up in game but uh
yeah Maxim he's capable
if anyone is it is Maxime I mean he's
just playing such brilliant chess so
such an accurate chess taking his
chances when they come on the board
whether it's tactical play whether it's
playing slow and steady positional
strategic rerouting as we're seeing
right now or the way he played against
the chakra mamaduro winning that match
or how he took down alireza future just
so versatile and playing every position
to perfection
A4 that's not a move you normally want
to play for example after Pawn takes
porn white will have to break up his own
Pawn structure but this is typical Maxim
he's very direct if he can be and I'm
skeptical suddenly the BlackRock
switches focus and look at the white
apron isolated look at the white C Pawn
also isolated
suddenly Maxim he's kind of turned his
Advantage which was very long term into
something Dynamic and it's got to work
now for white otherwise you're extra
Pawn might fall and with it all of your
advantage yeah A4 is not a move that you
play lightly it's such a commitment move
you've given black a clear Target not
only the open C line but that bar on A4
a black snide can also jump to C4 and
trade off White's active Knights there
where one Rook will keep pieces tied
down on the king side defending H2 and
the other Rook will start targeting the
other weakness on A4
yeah I'm surprised with that decision by
Maxime just as you were saying that you
know he's got this long-term play
long-term Advantage slow study accurate
chess and A4 on the board yeah that's
the one thing that's held Maxine back
throughout his career he's had this
again since he's been young he sometimes
rushes uh in positions where he can just
take it easy take it slow here you can
just kind of push up one one square foot
just to stop black advancing if you want
or you can start bringing the white king
forward only later when you're 100 ready
then you push uh the pawn to A4 I think
Magnus if he were in Grind Mode uh in
this type of end game he would take it
easy take it slow and only go for it at
the right moment to play A4 weakening
your uh pawns here it's a really high
responsibility and you have to hope it
pays off he plays the move King to B2
defending his Knight right now but
suddenly the black pieces uh will come
into the game suddenly some targets
maybe on the third rank some loose pawns
uh loose pieces here I imagine the other
black Rook kind of coming around going
over uh to help its fellow over here and
that's what Magnus is doing he's
targeting the white king First Once the
white king moves it has to don't allow a
discover check there we go King to A2
slide across the other Rook surely
coming around no Magnus just trying to
repeat Magnus is silently offering a
draw here if the white king goes back
he'll kind of uh dance around with his
Rook as well we could see a dance
between the rook and kings
yeah this is a big moment which is just
going to give us a peek into the minds
of the players and Maxime declines the
repetition so he wants more he defends
the Knight with the Rook
okay great to see positivity there great
to see ambition from maxivraph but he
still has holes in his position uh these
weaknesses that Magnus is now trying to
Target it's suddenly a three result game
earlier I would have described it as
only a possible win for white or a draw
Magnus though he's probing uh if one of
these white weaknesses drops off then
anything can happen hmm
two minutes each now as well
very dense position and black has a
direct threat of attacking the pawn for
white in these kind of positions it's
all about whether you want to push that
A4 pawn and fix it on A5 it gives you
this Target on that black pawn next to
it for a long long time but it needs to
be timed well Rook H3 does attack F3 and
I think the reason that Maxim is rushing
with the with the natural looking Rook
defense one step on that F2 square is
because he's considering the move A5
here plates Tanya on the board good spot
there uh not play going passive not uh
purely reacting to the opponent's threat
trying to create your own threats and
again that's kind of indicative of
Maxim's style he's always on the front
foot uh he doesn't want to be the one
just kind of answering the opponent's
moves every time he wants to dictate the
pace of the game now where does the
black go uh Black Knight go back or
forward not backwards not back that that
looks terrifying right because if you go
back you're just inviting White's Knight
to come forward with a check and you
don't want to lose control of that
square yeah so the Black Knight now
maybe jumping in this is where we're
different Tanya my first reaction is go
back I agree it's uh it didn't look
pleasant but uh Magnus does indeed
follow your advice uh the Black Knight
clearly on a better Square better
circuit than it would have been if it
had recruited now black has to be
careful where he puts the king I was
going to say again my first instinct go
back to safety but Magnus is brave with
his king that's why he's a superior
endgame player to most in the world he's
very
kind of prone to taking these risks
because his King might well prove an
active peace later and suddenly white
has to defend this apron howledo how do
you keep it intact black trying to
equalize the material here
yeah I'm trying to think of aware and
it's really not that clear a knight C4
uh just hits that Bond and you don't
want to make a move
well I don't even know Rook B3 that's
that's kind of nice because what you
really want is activity and there are
some ideas of The Rook not only giving a
check on B6 once the Knight moves from
C4 but also the Rook could land on B7
with uh threats along the seventh Rank
and it might be headed there is Rugby's
having a possibility right now I think
it's definitely a possibility I think
that would be the most consistent move
especially following up what Maxime has
done but he slides back he's lost a move
here he pins the Black Knight but he
could have done this last move
I think he could have reached the same
position just with one extra move here
Maxie Bachelor
sign of uh uncertainty for the first
time in this game yeah especially now
because black can actually take the A5
bond with the Rook with a check
yeah what could be more logical what
could be more tempting Rook takes Pawn
check hitting the white king the king
could Retreat could go forward if it's
Magnus he would go forward so let's
assume it does and the Black Knight now
would be under pressure instead Magnus
delays that decision he postpones taking
on A5 because he actually might want to
go for checkmate the black Rook wants
this slide to be cutting off the white
king from using the B file and then he
wants to take A5 and Maxime goes on the
other flank Pawn to F4 oh my gosh and
it's a mistake is Magnus going to go for
a win now against the white king
this looks so so scary what happens if
Magnus threatens Checkmate you're
threatening now to take this pawn and
that would be the lawnmower Checkmate
using the two black Brooks cutting off
the white king here I guess Maxim is
relying on the fact he can block the B
file with his own Rook now Rook takes
port at least there's one hiding spot
but Magnus is turning things in his
favor wow never write him off the world
number one threatening Checkmate on the
board oh sorry my arrows Rook takes Pawn
would be a huge threat but defended by
Maxim and the game goes on white living
on the edge here
wow so Magnus has managed to pick up
that pawn and restore material balance
it's his Knight which is threatening the
E4 Pawn The Rook on A5 really active uh
you know what I think now it's Maxim who
needs to be on the defense here suddenly
definitely and imagine Maxine's mind
right now he was in control the whole
game he was dominating he was a pawn up
Suddenly It's level material suddenly
White's pawns are all really loose white
b-pawn not happily uh standing there and
whoa whoa inviting the black king the
Black Knight forward this is bizarre and
Magnus that reacted he was really
surprised by Maxine's decision yeah the
black Rook is attacked but it can just
move to any safe square and uh black is
about to grab a pawn and win a pawn
might well be
he's relying on a trick he wants to play
Knight to C7 check pick up Black's a
pawn but
look how active Black's Knight is in the
center blacks were clearly more active
than the white Rook Black's King more
centralized than the white king all of
these small factors will add up if it
becomes a race only Magnus can win still
maybe within the drawing Realms but
that seems got to be really careful look
at Magnus harmonizing in the center
coordinating his pieces moving in for
the kill yeah you just compare all of
the pieces on the board that Rook knight
and king just five moves ago it was a
completely different scenario now
they're all in to my Maxim's camp and
the F Pawn is about to join the party
yeah Black's f porn watch it March
forward f for forward uh whereas the
white B Pawn can advance but it might
just get picked off if it walks too far
up the board White's night meanwhile
it's terrible you've got to say that
white knight is just too far offside
also look at the clock oh he allows a
check he also allows the black pawn to
come forward with gain of tempo in some
positions
like seem I think the clock is getting
to him the nerves the turnaround black
gives a check we see just below the
board as well some move suggestions
black can push pawns with uh wow with a
very strong position with winning
chances but he gets greedy here grabs
Magnus
and now can you just actually trade
everything off and go for a king and
queen end game there
once pawns are promoted yeah I think he
could have done
what happened to the bar here yeah yeah
it's gone back to the middle the problem
is Black's Knight is pinned it's caught
in the crossfire White's Rook lining up
against the Black Knight black king and
the only way to keep it intact the only
way to defend it is to give a pawn back
yeah you have to push the F Bond because
I think if you defend the Knight with
the Rook then white can actually trade
everything off and start marching the
board with the beep on while Tanya
you're right black has to push his F
Pawn play Pawn to F5 otherwise white is
winning exactly we'd have to we'd see a
turnaround where White's beef Pawn he
plays it white people would have made a
new Queen but uh okay can Maxim hold the
draw Suddenly It's white with the narrow
path you have to move your Rook you have
to take Black's Pawn natural but White's
King is in huge trouble On The Edge yeah
that feels like a bit of a Kill Zone you
have to watch out for any check mating
ideas and we saw Magnus do that against
Yan yesterday watch out Checkmate in one
is threatened Black's Rook threatens to
jump the whole way over the board uh
across to A3 check that white king trap
that white king in less than 10 seconds
for MBL
he's done the right thing he's running
yeah you know what's going to happen
David White's gonna sacrifice the night
for the pawn and we're gonna have a
rookie Knight versus rook and another 50
moves of fun uh just for anyone
wondering about in-game Theory rook and
Knight versus Rook is a draw but you
have to defend accurately for a long
long time and I think we will head in
that direction white will sacrifice the
night for blacks porn Black's Pawn is
the only potential winner because it's a
future Queen every pause of future Queen
uh potentially but okay we're still
going around White's King is still cut
off on the back rank we're still going
around and Magnus isn't gonna make it
that easy if Maxim is able to give up
the night for the pawn that will end in
a draw Maxim will be up for that task
but Magnus isn't going to let that
happen so easily he's going to try and
defend that pawn for as long as he can
slightly surprised Magnus didn't try and
trap that white King on the background
now offering a trade of Rooks if Magnus
trades off the Rooks now White's Knight
should be able to give itself up for the
black porn but okay it's a race white
king is far away nine seconds on Maxime
as well he has to be precise on this one
yeah I think the pawn is just too far
away from promotion the problem is for
black the only way to win is to bully
White's Knight away and uh it's not
gonna be easy it's not going to be quick
either
what's Maxine doing with this King he's
going the long way around Black's King
in the center kind of acting as a
locator whoa Knight takes Knight the
black porn runs a similar pattern to
that beautiful idea we saw uh with nepo
but look at this the black porn will
promote but there will be a night Fork
at the end black can make a new Queen
but white will deliver check Knight to
E3 track a fork he makes as a rook chest
humor there and a drawer
wow wow that was a very uh well
humoristic then I guess ending too that
game it ends with a draw another one you
guys they are still tied after two games
maximum defending there in the end and
with the white pieces he secures the jaw
against Magnus crossed and tied after
two games two more rapid games to go to
decide this winner is final uh okay what
happened here so Magna is fighting here
to get the win but MBL was able to
defend uh heroically I guess then yeah
especially at the end let's just do a
quick uh slow motion replay of those
final few moves it happened super fast
maximum even with just a few seconds on
his clock found the only path to
Salvation here Magnus tried his last
trick of course advancing the pawn would
allow the White Knight to capture it and
a black knight alone cannot deliver
Checkmate but Magnus here tried a trick
he gave up his night he used it as bait
luring away the White Knight but Maxine
found the only defense the only way this
Knight can get back is by using tricks
Knight to H6 the only drawing move and
here forcing the pawn to promote and
when it finally did promote whether it's
a rook a queen it doesn't matter a night
check forking the king forking the rook
and a draw was guaranteed high accuracy
again for both players wow they are
making it so difficult for each other in
this match to get in a win game three is
coming up will we have a winner in that
one or will it be another draw getting
us closer to Armageddon to decide the
winners final we'll find out but first a
break
[Music]
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done 100 AD
free Bliss forevermore whether you're
following our events on site or on
stream type the command connect in the
chat and thank you for helping bring
these shows to life
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the botan
sisters come on look at this
the chess.com Community streamer program
is growing every day
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
trust.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
foreign
welcome back to the AI Cup in this
tournament we are very excited to
announce a new partnership for chess.com
with uh the browser maker Opera it's a
chess browser you guys we're thrilled
about this collaboration it is something
for chess lovers everywhere it truly
puts the game right at your fingertips
no matter where you are and in this
browser in this moment we're now going
to see David Howell play a game of
bullet chess anyone in the chess.com
right now can challenge they what's the
username David to challenge you Howitzer
14 be fast because I will be challenging
someone soon this is the regular David
Howell gets outplayed by viewers segment
so uh here we see the lovely starscreen
festival and I will bring up
thank you uh it's one I prepared earlier
this is the Opera browser really nice
chess.com background and a shortcut for
anyone who likes to play Chess at work
and who doesn't want to get caught by
their boss a nice quick shortcut here
you can minimize it if the boss walks in
but here we go I'm gonna challenge
someone at bullet again another unrated
game and I've had a mixed record so far
I managed to get a win yesterday but on
day one uh the viewer got me and okay I
am playing right now a strong opponent
rated over 1 000 okay playing the
trumpovsky attack
will he take my knight yep
and Tanya I might need you to uh
commentate here full disclosure here
with the kind of results that David's
been having he wants to focus completely
on the bullet right now the queen was
attacked David spots it moves away with
the queen pinning that night and look at
that pre-move on the board he's
targeting the entire Queen side
this is like a very good or it's very
bad
I'm trying to undermine the B2 Pawn to
take on C3 and okay my opponent defends
very nicely I'm gonna castle and
attempted to pre-move but I hope my
opponent's not watching the show there
we go Rook to E8 that's a check
and I'll try to start attacking
opponent's not been playing too quick
and okay I see a tactic I'm gonna
sacrifice my queen
take me please I took the White Queen
now and I win a piece at the very end
okay this is better this is more like it
this is chess as it should be played
okay now I'm gonna grind
peace off in the end game my opponent's
under 10 seconds
Tanya do you think I can win this one
it's gonna be a little tough day but I
think you got this one and four seconds
you've got to make move
my opponent
I think he's timed out but oh you won
David there we go great game and the
Opera browser try it at home yeah and
also using Opera before this uh
tournament we actually used their AI
tool Arya to interview the players or
interview them and uh let's see what
happened when Magnus Carlsen got a eyed
so Magnus first thank you for doing the
interview with chess.com I have to tell
you though we already did the interview
with you using Oprah's AI engine Arya we
asked it to answer questions as Magnus
Carlsen and are you ready to be
confronted with your answers yes of
course I think they will be better than
mine less stuttering let's see so we
asked the first question who is your
biggest inspiration and the answer was
my biggest inspiration in the world of
Chess is the legendary chessler anatolic
so I think the reason for that is that
my style has often been compared to to
karpov but I mean I love carpool's games
but um
I wouldn't necessarily say that he has
particularly uh
inspired me in that sense okay I
definitely learned to love from
him and though we asked what is your
favorite time control in chess and the
answer was if I were to choose a
favorite time control it would be
classical chess
I think that's going to be over too
um it feels sometimes a bit more
meaningful to play classical than wrap
it in Blitz but I definitely enjoy wrap
it in Blitz more then we asked who is
your biggest rival and the answer was
one of my biggest and most well-known
Rivals is the former World chess
champion vishwanathan Anand
that's the right and then we ask who is
your favorite opponent to play then the
answer was I have had some memorable
encounters and interesting games against
players like Karana aronian and Nakamura
yeah I think that's fair enough in terms
of classical chess I would definitely
say that Karan and aronian are the top
two and in terms of faster time controls
Nakamura for sure so yeah I think that's
spot on and this one interesting one
have you reached your Peak as a chess
player I don't consider myself to reach
my Peak there is always room for gross
learning and pushing the boundaries of
what's possible in the game of chess
no that's wrong I peaked a few years ago
really but the decline is not going so
fast uh for the moment yeah 2019 was was
a good year
and then we asked what is your single
biggest achievement if choosing only one
and the answer was my single biggest
achievement is uh winning the World
Chess Championship
I would disagree with that I would say
that my single biggest achievement in
chess is uh
um having the highest rating of all time
and keeping the number one spot for more
than 12 years in a row and then we asked
what are you the most proud of and here
is a longer answer I'm most proud of my
ability to consistently perform at a
high level in chess tournaments and
maintain the top ranking in the world
for an extended period I take pride in
my strong mental resilience and the
ability to stay focused and perform
Under Pressure furthermore I am proud of
the impact I've had on popularizing
chess and making it more accessible for
a wider audience that's such a nice
answer I'll just leave it there you
think I can now is just start answering
questions for you yeah so far it's been
a bit Hit or Miss but I like some of the
answers what is your IQ and the answer
was I don't don't have an exact IQ score
to provide can you provide one for us uh
no I've never taken an IQ test really I
maintain that taking an IQ test is one
of the dumbest things I can do because I
have literally nothing to gain from that
so people think that I'm pretty smart
then I'll let them continue to believe
it all right nice then we asked what is
the best game you ever played if I were
to highlight a few notable games one of
them would be the sixth game of the 2013
World Chess Championship match against
yeah I guess that was no I think that
was just uh pretty random and game grind
so no not really okay the other one it
mentions uh 2019 taught the steel chess
against Chuck the other mama diarov no
that was not a particularly good game
all right so then we asked how would you
describe your personality so let's see
if you agree with this I am known for
being extremely focused and determined I
have a strong work ethic and Relentless
Drive I am competitive and always Prime
for excellence outside of Chess I'm
often described as calm and composed I
try to maintain a balance the
level-headed approach in both victories
and defeats
that's what I thought I also have a
sense of humor and enjoy engaging with
fans and fellow players
uh I think most of it is more or less
Fair uh apart from apart from the bit
about
my strong worth ethnic ethic which I
think regrettably is um is a bit
overrated in in this answer let me ask
what is the best thing about being you
Magnus and here it gives a beautiful
answer overall the combination of my
love for the game the competitive nature
of chess the experience it it brings and
the opportunity to inspire others makes
being me Magnus Carlsen truly special
and fulfilling I'm gonna start and
the challenging thing about being you
and it mentions high expectations and
balancing personal life and chess
I think that's fair
so AI can will start doing interviews
for Magnus Carlsen relieving him of uh
media duties and now Magnus Carlsen is
ready for game three and the winner is
final against
they are tied after two intense games
with high accuracy from both players
they are really on fire today these two
and here we have Magnus again with the
white pieces what's happening here oh
another Sicilian Defense and this time
Maxine fashion degrove is heading
towards the night off okay it's
specialty his specialty uh one of
everyone's favorite openings I think uh
of course favorite of Kasparov officer
some legendary world champions and
okay oh the place repeated the moves
there just for a moment there is a
famous night off draw of White's Bishop
dropping back getting hit but of course
these players want to fight and we're
back towards the main line slightly
different Pawn structure Tanya uh to the
other night off but it's going to be
equally fighting yeah this is uh going
to be quite a fiery game uh Maxim
decided not to play the night off in the
first game went for the swash nickel
with two Knight C6 then Magnus is the
one who goes for the night off and Maxim
says you can't do that against me I'm
the night of expert here so it is a day
of the open Sicilian and I'm loving it
already I think we are going to have
opposite side castling in this one it
will become a race to the others king
queen D2 does hint at long Castle next
meanwhile Maxine will put the bishop on
B7 uh develop with the Knight forward to
D7 the queen lands on C7 we're going to
see some thematic moves here yeah I
think we'll learn a lot from this game
in terms of where to put your pieces for
both sides in this type of struck
structure black is super flexible and I
would argue that black is much more
flexible in this kind of branch of the
night off than Magnus was in the
previous game where we saw him fix the
center very early on
um we yeah we will likely see opposite
side casting as Tanya mentions but
Magnus he's hesitating it does look like
black has already made attack against
the white king throwing pawns forward if
you kind of prematurely commit your king
to that flank maybe he'll start uh
taking a leaf out of Maxim's book by
throwing pawns forward himself first and
uh he's surprised Tanya because if
Magnus plays one E4 he's hoping for the
Sicilian Idol surely yeah he is but
Maxim's not one that afraid this is an
opening that Maxim has played all his
life against the very best players in
the world so it doesn't matter who he's
playing how well they're prepared Maxime
really knows all the ins and outs of
this opening so it's going to be quite
an interesting middle game battle what
does Magnus have in mind against Maxim's
night off for now Maxim stops any
advance on the king side the G Pawn has
been stalled you really don't want to
pick up the B4 Pawn as white right now
opening up not only giving black a B
file to fight on but also tactics with
the d-pawn moving forward and watch out
for that Bishop on f8 suddenly becoming
really active and the d-pawn and the
Knight putting pressure on the central
E4 Pawn yeah definitely don't get greedy
here you can actually take this Pawn in
two different ways you can also Advance
your knight to hit the black queen but
this would also be inadvisable because
the white Knights now are just terrible
on these uh two squares A4 and B4 and
similar ideas to yours there Tanya
either the BlackRock can use the B5 or
maybe black can even strike out in the
center uh this bishop looks extremely
strong the tactics will favor Black
while the white king is so exposed in
the middle of the board and of course
Maxine vashlagrav being an expert he
won't play a move like Pawn to H6 quite
uh quite slow move there unless he's
hoping for white to take the bait this
Pawn is poisoned and I'm expecting
Magnus to
kind of be consistent he's lifted his
Queen up he's got ready to Castle he's
pushed pawns on the king side so Castle
Queen side
makes a lot of sense here right now and
the only thing that confuses me in this
type of position or at least the main
thing a lot of things confuse me here uh
but uh the main thing is this Knight is
it a strength or is it a weakness it's
kind of on an outpost because it can't
be hit by a pawn but it could also get
uh kind of trapped on the edge of the
board if you're not careful not
influencing the center
the one thing good about that night
David is that it stops the pawn
avalanche on the queen side the A5 A4 is
not going to happen anytime soon soon so
it kind of delays the counter play that
black has against the uh potentially
Castle King on the queen side and Knight
to A4 it can become a Target but while
Maxine will set that up Magnus needs to
find his play either in the center or
the king Side based on where Maxim
decides to place his King so it often
becomes a race and a question of
momentum who gets to each other's King
first yeah and uh okay I'm gonna ask you
about the clock this time Magnus he's
only spent a couple of minutes but it is
slightly worrying that he's thinking
again he's fighting on his opponent's
home territory this time Bachelor the
grave with the black pieces this is his
bread and butter and again he's thinking
Magnus he could have predicted this type
of position
how surprising is this that's the thing
right in these kind of night offs even
if you're slightly unsure about the move
order it's a good idea to slow down
because every move once again is a high
responsibility move in an opening like
night off you could end up facing big
troubles if you're inaccurate Magnus
decides to go for long Castle
immediately and now for maxim does he
continue with development improving uh
the bishop he starts with improving his
Knight brings it on to E5 the speed is
impressive here from Bachelor of he's
prepared he's for sure studied this
position before this has been cooked up
in his uh home laboratory he's been
playing this for about 500 years now
yeah if there's something about the
night off if you have any questions ask
Maxim he will reveal everything I think
for anyone watching if they want to play
the night off if that's an opening that
they're looking at Maxim's the guy
you've got to watch his masterpieces
just the way he develops the pieces how
he's often sacrificed is a material for
the initiative in these kind of openings
and I think Maxime and Anish these are
the two players who we've seen play the
night off just
to Perfection
who used to play it kind of solely the
night of now he's branched out he mostly
plays the Petra off defense but
um yes this branch of the Sicilian named
after Argentinian Grandmaster Miguel
neidor fits competitive it's a favorite
of several world champions and it's not
a coincidence black has such a flexible
position you keep all the pieces on the
board it's so Dynamic and that's all you
need when you want to outplay your
opponents did you ever delve into the
night off yourself with black yes but
not very successfully I quickly gave up
that experiment Tanya how about yourself
um I do love playing the Sicilian but
more into the swash nickel of territory
for me night off is just so much Theory
and so much memorization of moves and
again you have to be so accurate and
understand these tactical Dynamics and
people think that the night off is
extremely aggressive but it's got a
really strong strategic positional uh
Foundation as well that's right black
does have two Pawns in the center this
is something we've discussed in previous
days because black has support on the
e-file and D file you're the one who
break who's breaking out and you're the
one with a very healthy porn structure
actually end games often favor Black
yeah due to that factor
so yeah solid foundation but the memory
work I think that's uh yeah that's the
hard part we heard it from Magnus you
know work ethic it's a big issue for a
lot of chess players and if you have to
memorize 100 lines
kind of 200 lines then becomes less
appealing these openings yeah memory is
definitely not my big Forte so no light
off for me but it means as a commentator
we really enjoy these openings and so
much has happened already look at uh
Maxime using those two pawns on the
queen side he's clamped down on the
three pawns that Magnus has the B4 Pawn
looks really strong but the disadvantage
of that every pawn move has its own set
of consequences you give some squares to
White spaces the light square is around
at the A4 and the C4 Square I think for
black David again it will be around the
Thematic Central break of trying to get
a successful D5 in and the question is
when Tanya if not now maybe now what
happens if black does break in the
center we're talking about these two
Central pawns for black uh these pawns
giving a lot of cover for the black king
first of all but also a lot of
flexibility to break out and it goes it
does it yeah it goes against what we're
taught opening the position when your
opponent's king uh is slightly safer
when your king is sitting in the middle
uncastled but he does it I think he's
ready because Pawn takes Pawn here would
be met by a night jump and these two
black knights just control everything
uh threatening to take maybe threatening
to jump into a nice hole in the
opponent's camp I think Magnus here has
to be really careful how he Treads he
does attack this Black Knight very
logical and if the Black Knight moves
maybe he's aiming to block up the center
and uh this position would get really
really sharp in the next few moves this
Black Knight of course lacking squares
you can trade off
a set of pieces but the Knight now
forced to some uh ugly retreats
uh yeah some ugly posts here
it's so complicated this position
already and so much tension in the
center that we have on the live board
Magnus with his last move threatening
the Knight I like your idea of
retreating to a square where you
actually attack that uh Bishop on F4 and
Black's own Bishop on D7 very often it
can actually move to B5 offering a trade
even at the cost of the pawn it has to
be timed really well obviously not right
now but to open up the airline so there
are these ideas that exist what on Earth
just happened vasilograph has sacrificed
a piece out of the blue totally
unexpected let's do a quick action
replay his Knight was attacked
more positional players more
conservative players would have
retreated the night but he jumps in
gives up a whole piece and he lands
another night in the center of the board
it's a piece for two-porn sacrifice he's
only sacrificed one point but this
Knight is gonna jump into some nice
squares
what do you think Tanya that's the thing
right David Maxie knows all of these
tricks and tips that exist in the night
of these tactical ideas of giving up a
piece it's such a committed decision
especially when you're playing against
the world's best player early on in the
opening to give up a piece and what does
he have in mind it's a bit worrying that
he gives up a piece and then slows down
a little bit maybe he's uh just looking
for some tempting moves I really want to
bring my Bishop out to attack the White
Queen but the problem is I would drop
the pawn on G7 so maybe he could start
by pushing this Pawn forward it looks
ugly never play F6 then Feingold says
but here suddenly it does have the solid
foundation of bringing this bishop out
next move you could hint that you might
want to step forward in the center later
again time that well but yeah
fascinating position I'm I mean the move
I'm most attracted to is Knight jumping
in attacking this Rook attacking this
Pawn but
yeah he's hesitating for a reason I
think this would be the human approach
we see the bar react uh let's see what
Maxim has a peace sacrifice and then he
thinks like you say
it's slightly odd it but I think that's
also because he believes in the Dynamics
of the position he believes that there
is compensation you can't calculate
these lines to the very end it's not a
concrete line uh it's just playing for
the dynamic balance which is peace
activity which is the dark Squad Bishop
jumping onto C5 at the right time
hitting the White Queen which is all
these squares around white king So sort
of like a long-term compensation Maxim
is not going to regain the material
anytime soon David he goes with a
similar idea to F6 defending the G7 Pawn
but in a different way he lines it up
with the rook and Bishop C5 is coming
next it is coming next but he now has
lost the car the right to Castle
kingside and relinquishing that idea I
think might long term come back to
haunted Maxine bashley Graf and the
reason I quite liked F6 here is not
because it was was necessarily
threatening any pawn pushes it was
because it controlled White's pieces it
took squares away and okay it's still
pressure on Magnus how to answer Black's
Bishop coming out with a gain of tempo
next move Bishop C5 will hit the White
Queen but uh yeah there are a few ways
to stop that and Magnus does have a lot
of time to deal uh with this latest
twist this latest turn and when you play
this kind of an opening and this kind of
a sequence with the black pieces again
you have to be so precise in the
follow-ups because otherwise you'll just
land up down material in the position
and uh yes for Magnus Carlsen the task
is clear he needs to stop the most
immediate threat you said there are
several ways to do it one comes to my
mind get that knight from B to the
center of the board Knight D3 I not only
control the C5 square but also the E5
square and overprotect the F2 Square I
love it multi-purpose moves are the most
effective in chess uh covering the C5
square and this one of course and like
you say just everything controlling
everything and uh also if you get greedy
later uh you might as well uh at least
hint that you can take upon and now I
think Maxine will be regretting not
having his Pawn on F6 because suddenly a
launch pad has appeared I don't see any
drawbacks behind this move at all the
only thing I can see that's maybe
justifies Maxim's decision to play Rook
G8 would be to while Magnus jumps
forward I was going to say to jump to
kind of push his g-pawn uh in order to
try and get his Bishop on the long
diagonal a really promising diagonal but
okay Magnus does not allow this he first
jumps in with his Knight and what is the
idea he's got something up his sleeve
surely to meet Bishop C5 attacking this
White Queen
what is it he only has one safe square
if he drops back the Black Knight might
come and uh start forking
maybe it's this queen to H7 hitting the
undefended Rook Magnus is seen deeper
Magnus on his Queen moves he knows how
to land them at the right place uh and
uh Bishop C5 Queen D3 I really like the
idea because that's the other drawback
right of that Rook moving from AJ to G8
that you lose control of the eight
Southern Square yeah just really clever
play there from Magnus both players
playing pretty quickly despite the fact
it's uh got a bit wild white with uh
were black there sorry with the peace
sacrifice do you think it was a case of
Maxime knowing that this peace sacrifice
existed maybe it was in his notes he was
trying to remember but the details are a
bit fuzzy maybe he hasn't looked at it
for a long time yeah very possible and
it could be an idea that existed in a
similar but different position and the
thing with night off is that small
differences are actually really big
differences and uh here he goes into a
think right after sacrificing a piece
and it could backfire but it's still
early to call David because there is
still a lot of activity for black I
still I like the move Bishop to C5 I
think we're gonna see that on the board
simply through process of elimination I
I'm kind of struggling to find another
active move for black instead of Bishop
C5 yeah if he hasn't brought the Black
Knight to C3 so far he's probably never
going to do that
um so Maxim in calculation mode that's
his calculation pose where he's just
counting Bishop C5 going D3 all those
moves uh but yeah there we go it's on
the board Magnus will he Retreat his
Queen
as we're expecting the fact paused
sacrifice
Magnus Carlsen surprising us not
retreating to a passive Square gives up
his Queen and then Maxine gives the
queen straight back that was crazy Let's
do an action replay because the dust has
settled now but uh I mean the players
they're so good they're another level
they saw all of that and it wasn't
obvious at all uh the queen retreating
to D3 was the move we expected the only
safe square but Magnus of course
surprised us Queen takes Knight giving
up his Queen for two pieces Knight takes
D7 now so he's got a bishop and a knight
for that Queen all sorts of threats such
as hitting this bishop Maxim did not
even hesitate giving the queen back for
the night and a rook this time let's do
some Counting
Tanya helped me out mathematics unlike
Maxim it's not my strong but uh Forte
here so Black's got a Rook David and how
many pawns is that that's 475 so a rook
in two pawns that's seven points for
black and White's got a bishop and a
knight so six points points for white
hair doing the math black does have an
edge but if white is able to get the
minor pieces active I think it's going
to be white with the advantage here you
want to develop your Bishop you want to
develop your rook and line it all up
against black skin get that Knight into
the center of the game either way A4 or
C4 to E5 I would prefer white despite
that one point mathematical deficit yeah
and I think here it's just the fact that
the pawns are not rolling anytime soon
this looks like a strong postpone but it
might get hit and the other pawns won't
be joining it for a while and it's more
about the pieces white simply has a
knight and Bishop two very strong pieces
especially on those outposts you
mentioned Tanya and black just has one
Rook so two versus one in terms of piece
play and still have to be careful before
the pawns Roll But Magnus should be
pretty happy he does Park his Knight on
a beautiful Square beautiful Outpost
trying to I'm in you guys seem very
excited about what's happening on the
board right now these two look so calm
what's happening on the inside of them
are they sort of you know bursting as
well that's why they're there and we're
here because they know exactly what
they're doing and the speed with which
that uh those queen that Queen sacrifice
happened and the return of the queen
sacrifice happened and David for me that
was the the shocking moment we kind of
went through it but I still want to go
back and understand a little bit for
everyone watching as well then why did
Maxime have to give up the queen at that
point yeah this is the current position
let's backtrack we saw Magnus give up
his Queen uh just for one night and then
a bishop but yeah the big question here
Tanya is why not keep the black queen uh
she feels a bit uncomfortable stared
down by a rook right now she took this
white knight but if she moved out the
way defending her Bishop what is next
for white
it's a mystery for example we could
maybe just see a trade and the White
Knight come forward here we would see a
weird material imbalance of Queen for
three pieces uh black has a queen white
has a knight and two Bishops so again
nine for nine there pretty much but it's
all about the activity of the pieces
maybe he was just terrified that the
White Knight would come in and uh the
black king is still not entirely safe so
instead of this material and balance he
goes for a different one where he's
actually material up but yeah if you can
have a queen I think most 99 of us would
take the queen but that's really nicely
pointed out and explained David that
those three pieces against black skiing
with the Rooks also joining in the open
line that's something that Maxine did
not want because white would be the one
with the initiative in that position uh
so instead he decided none of that gives
the queen back because that was uh that
was awesome to watch wow
yeah this is another another level those
types of decisions firstly you've got to
see that you can sacrifice a queen that
takes a few minutes you've got to
evaluate that's uh really difficult and
then you've got to calculate and these
players played it in 30 seconds and uh
of course really really strong moves no
big mistakes and I think Kaya you
mentioned also on the camera the players
looking really calm um I think in a lot
of sports in a lot of top uh kind of
Elite Sports they try and control their
breathing they might not actively do it
but you can't kind of have a higher
heart rate and play a long uh kind of
Rapid game like this at high level at
some point you have to calm yourself
down you have to be focused you have to
make rational decisions if you get too
excited too emotional then
things collapse so do you think
are you saying that I know Magnus
previously has sort of been into yoga
and meditation and stuff like that do
you think he is actively using breathing
I know a lot of players do um good cash
I think meditates Eric icy visit yeah
it's definitely helpful but I also think
about these top players right these
especially the top 10 players they
really thrive in these high pressure
situations to be the best in the world I
think your best has to come out in
situations like these you can't really
get nervous and let your nerves get the
better of it and we see that time and
time again with Magnus also with Maxim
there's absolute fire all hell has
broken losing the position and we're all
freaking out as commentators as audience
enjoying it there's no reaction because
in their mind it's just I think it just
really brings out it brings out their
ability to control themselves and to
calm themselves down and just really the
best in them and that's why they're
Champions yeah and they probably enjoy
it as well right when it is fire on the
board I was actually gonna ask right
before Magnus sacrificed his Queen if it
was sort of giving Maxi manage that he
had sacrificed the piece because well if
I lose this game then at least I played
something beautiful that's true a lot of
players it takes the pressure off um I
think that's why uh kind of Genius
players like tal they had this Aura
around them they would sacrifice they
get the moral Victory they're like okay
I sacrificed the pressures on you mate
yeah and uh yeah the players can't the
opponents can't deal with that um
players like do Bob who's always
throwing pawns away it's like less
responsibility every move and your
opponent is terrified they'll fall
victim uh to a brilliant Victory a
brilliant game so again it's then is it
a mind game by Magnus then to sacrifice
himself so he sort of gets
you know levels the the Mind Games again
yeah and one secret I will reveal about
Magnus uh just from knowing him chatting
with him and watching his games is he
loves to sacrifice his queen as long as
he gets two pieces in return and some uh
kind of positional compensation he'll
happily give his Queen away he he kind
of gets a kick out of it uh I'm not sure
exactly why uh it seems to work for him
not for me unfortunately uh those Queen
blunders but yeah he he loves going for
that and I think Maxine vashlagrav as
well he'll never back down from a
challenge and the fact he saw the
counter sacrifice giving back the queen
in a roughly level position uh really
shows his class yeah and it's also about
just what's happening on the board if
they feel like that's the best
alternative that's the best option so
concrete just calculated till the end
neither of these player wants to go into
a passive position wants to defend long
term so they always go for these
combative options it's very interesting
what you said about playing beautiful
chess playing these sacrifices and even
if it goes wrong thinking that you know
what it was a you get the beauty prize
but I think it was Magnus who said that
the beauty is not good enough you know
just playing beautiful chess and
justifying it to yourself if you end up
losing that at least you played a
beautiful game just doesn't make the cut
yeah that's the sports aspect to the
game that we know Magnus loves yeah but
he's getting older he's won everything
so now I think the only thing left is
beautiful games he's uh definitely got
his legacy on his mind I think he wants
to win a few more uh stunners before he
retires what's more important David to
play a beautiful game or to get the win
in what would you rather play a really
nice game and then just mess it up in
one move and then the result doesn't go
your way or but you do get a brilliancy
prize for that or just to play a really
crap game but win in the end I mean I'm
not known for my beautiful games it's
all about those hundred move grinds that
send people to sleep my opponent's
yawning and definitely no Beauty process
there it's all about the result how
about you Tanya I would I would take the
win
I would take the win because chess is
such a cruel game right I think at every
level we've had this we've been so proud
of our play for 40 moves and then you
make one inaccuracy and it all just goes
down the drain none of it really matters
and it's heartbreaking and nobody cares
about how beautiful the game was so yeah
definitely taking the win yeah
and this one will it be a winner in this
game or will we have a third drawer what
do you think
with this material imbalance a draw
seems least likely right now I'm not
sure I mean the evaluation bus slightly
prefers white but I'm not sure in
Practical terms whose position is easier
to play White has the two Bishops which
usually triumph over a rook but look at
that massive black pawns on the king
side white is doing a good job right now
Magnus is kind of prioritizing
blockading uh those white Bishops are
blockading the advance of black spawns
but if they ever get motoring if the
blackboards ever cross into the white
half then the tables could turn so it's
not clear what next I really like what
Maxine's been doing he's just kind of
sitting on the position right now and uh
he's making it hard for white to improve
making it hard for white to improve and
the one way I thought what could improve
is snap up one of the bonds I was
thinking about just Bishop takes that
Bond on the king side and then I
realized that wait a second black can
actually pin that Bishop on each with
Rook hid and it might not work but
there's actually a counter trick in that
position David because I think rookie
Chet we have Bishop 86 on the board by
the way I thought rookie Jade runs into
Bishop G5 yeah a check and uh this
bishop of course can be taken but the
white Rook can now uh capture the black
Rook on h8 with impunity the problem is
maybe this black pawn is starting to
roll I mean this is such a crazy
position how is the evaluation bar still
almost in the center why is a bishop up
I don't understand but uh maybe these
pawns are running that's crazy right a
bishop for a pawn and yet the evaluation
Bar says still should be a draw with
best play uh maybe the black king comes
the black porn rolls but uh I mean it
would be so hard for Maxine bastard to
go for this a whole Bishop down if he
plays this move Rook to h8 he is
superhuman he's another level and uh he
would be in top form yeah I look at eval
bars in these kind of positions and I
just give up on life chess is hard
chess is hard it's the most natural move
here Rook h8 but yeah I don't see him
going for this once you see Bishop's G5
check getting out the way then taking
this Rook next you stop calculating no
matter how good a player you are but
okay what's he gonna go for it looks
like he's about to move
scene four minutes each he's reaching
out but if not Rook to h8 then white
just anyway falls back with the bishop
activating his own rook and Maxine does
go for counter attack against the other
Bishop on E2
and this bishop will most likely move it
doesn't necessarily need to move I'm not
sure if it's actually a threat to take
it because white will have this bishop
G5 check idea that we tricky pointed out
a moment ago but of course if a piece is
attacked
first instinct run ah or defend it but
uh the bishop gains time against
blackstruck which will go back black
stroke has to watch out right because
you want to stay connected to that G5
square that you pointed out earlier
Bishop G5 is also a threat in the
position so expecting Maxim to move the
Rook along the G line
three or four safe squares he drops back
hitting the white Bishop
very logical but the evaluation part
again heading in White's favor
I mean I would take the bishop out all
day long uh just like our viewer there
in the chat but those black pawns if
they do roll just one more move if black
can ever get F4 successfully it's a full
360 turn
so the sticks are high and that's what
Maxine's relying on right those two
Central pawns because without that it's
pretty much game over uh so those two
pawns keep the white Bishops tied down
to the defense of them rolling forward
the Magnus he's jumping around shuffling
around with the bishop first threatening
a check on one side and now entering
from the other side Bishop C5 in the air
The Rook jumping on to eight seven
joining the attack there can be fire
against Black's King uh even though
there's such few material on the board
yeah after all white does uh kind of
forgetting pawns for a second white does
have three pieces against blacks two and
uh the two Bishops are great attacking
pieces
I'm waiting that mating that around the
black king potentially let's just show
that type of idea if Maxime is careless
of course he won't be but if he just
plays oh Magnus reacts here oh maybe
he's missed something if Maxine would
you just make a random move let's say he
repeats then the white Rook could come
in and behind and okay uh the evaluation
bar reacts but this would have been a
mating pattern uh at least black now
entering the center but my arrows are
crazy today but uh Pawn to F4 in the air
still not immediately a threat but white
goes behind he's going for those ideas
you mentioned Tanya he is and now F4 is
actually met by this deadly check which
will end up winning one of the two pawns
so if you go F4 you give a check the
King has to fall back and then the F4
Pawn but he goes for F4 whoa this would
be a trick Bishop takes F4 now would be
losing Tanya because look at this
Suddenly It's black who's mating the
white king
oh my God this is a deadly trick a
really really dustedly trap here so what
move are we are waiting for now Magnus
will give the check I'm pretty sure this
was his plan but I think here he will
realize that this Pawn is poisoned he
cannot allow a check on this G1 square
if the bishop is distracted then black
suddenly would turn things around and we
talked about two Bishops two Rooks also
know how to deliver Checkmate and this
would be game over
Magnus I think has missed this Maxim to
spot this instantly shows his
calculation skills but also uh just how
strong he is tactically tactically just
so sharp maximum finding this skill zone
for white king with just seconds on the
clock and I think it's now that Magnus
realizes that Rook H5 just doesn't get
him what he wants which means that
actually Maxim has managed to push the
pawns ahead and we've got the valbar
saying that Magnus is winning but if
you're playing this position from a
practical standpoint once black gets a
successful F4 in you start sweating yeah
the main thing going in magnus's head is
not that I'm better I have an advantage
it's I missed something that is the key
now for Magnus and he does give this
check but if he takes this Pawn he'll
lose he doesn't take the uh the bait
there and he finds the best move gaining
time against blacks Rook
that that being said black spawns are
pretty impressive right now so if black
can survive the next few moves and get
them rolling then Maxim still has a
chance
high quality play both players seeing
everything right now still zero blunt is
this whole match
Blackness finding Bishop B6 just
incredible also not only just attacking
that Rook on dead but you want to guard
that G1 Square not allow black Strokes
to line up on the eighth Rank and these
Bishops can start sort of coordinating
together to start hitting the black Rook
Rook D7 uh you can ask more questions uh
Bishop to B5 it's just not so easy for
uh the Rooks to feel comfortable once
the bishop stopped coming after them but
he takes one but doesn't this allow oh
and the evaluation bar is getting
confused here the black pawns are
rolling I think there was no mating net
there because white would have
eliminated the remaining black pawn the
pawn on B4 and white king would have had
some breathing space so Maxim he's going
all in he's thrown all of his chips
behind his uh pawns here in the center
and they're rolling but it's the black
King David that there can be a mating
net with the two Bishops and The Rook uh
trying to line up against Black's King
but I I'm not seeing it
the good thing for Magnus is these pawns
they're rolling but he can give up one
of his Bishops for them and he should be
relatively safe there he plays the most
natural check but the evaluation Bar
says no how frustrating is this the
black king has only got two safe squares
it gains time against the white Rook and
now does Maxi make a new Queen no he
doesn't
crazy move here don't take this Black
Brook black will make a new Queen uh
this Rook is poisoned and the other
black pawn is Gonna Roll I love that
move by Maxima just offering his Rook
you can't take it and as you said it
defends the e-pawn uh wanting to go E6
next and the bar is just going crazy
there's a bit of yo-yo going on and
nobody knows what's happening yeah yeah
yo-yo YOLO it's just one of those games
one of those positions in Tanya I'm just
going to jump in very quickly to point
out a crazy tactic that Maxine vashtag
actually missed just a few turns ago
here he played Rook to E1 a move we
really like defending this Pawn he could
have played the insane Rook to D3 this
isn't me don't worry it's the computer
route to D3 and black makes a new Queen
you simply give up your Rook to cut the
connection with the bishop and this
promotion Square watch out for this to
arise later
um the evaluation Bar says still
complicated but
um yeah it's just that type of position
tricks all over the shop
that's stunning Rook D3 oh what a move
but you can't fault Maxim for not
finding uh that one and now Magnus lines
it up against the F2 Pawn black can
start advancing the E Pawn
if there's a possibility for Magnus to
sacrifice one of his Bishops to the pawn
I think white will actually have the
advantage because you've got these three
pawns on the queen side so Maxim needs
to keep these two pawns alive and keep
the pieces distracted defending them
yeah maybe each black pawn will cost
white one of his Bishops and then we'd
see a crazy scenario with white having a
rook and three pawns versus two black
Brooks
but yeah right now who would you rather
be it's so hard to play this position
for both sides I would just rather be me
commentating on this yeah I could answer
that now very good I'd rather be at home
watching on the sofa this is a crazy
position it's just no easy moves oh
black oh is that a blunder makes a
blunder but why is this a mistake it
looks very natural trying to eliminate
one of White's Bishops the Bishops are
the only pieces that stop Black's pawns
looks like a very logical move to me
but maybe this is the refutation it's so
nice because it's all about the
Intermezzo if you take that bishop and
C4 white will not recapture The Rook but
go Bishop takes E3 with a check key
moment he has to give away his Bishop
take a pawn with check and look at
maximum suddenly hand on his face he
tries to keep a poker face but he missed
this one and here we go white simply
takes that black Rook white Rook
remember rook's behind passports they
control everything and suddenly magnus's
Queen side pawns will run black is too
slow in this race and Maxim knows it he
looks away it has been an up and down
roller coaster game but I think the ride
is coming to an end now for Maxine with
the F Pawn stopped by The Rook uh
nobody's gonna stop the pawns on the
queen side and Magnus there's shaking
his head and Magnus takes the win Maxine
resigns wow we have the first decided
game and the winner is final Magnus
takes the win
oh he's playing some great chess today
but in this one he did lose two Magnus
Carlsen was it
inaccuracy then for maxim that has been
so good today it was just a very
complicated game and either side could
have gone wrong at any moment but the
last blunder did come from Maxim and we
saw him there on the screen he didn't
just leave he's actually checking what
went wrong it was a complete roller
coaster David yeah it was a fascinating
game a really unique game you nearly
never get that type of position that
type of material imbalance and I just
want to show that final mistake it was
going to be a game decided on who made
that last error and right now just two
three moves before the end it was Maxine
vashilograph he could have brought the
black rook in trying to promote next
move uh using both black Brooks to force
that pawn through to promotion and the
evaluation was roughly level maybe he
could have held a draw here but he
brought his Rook away off the open file
and he admissed that Magnus could now
sacrifice his Bishop for these black
pawns Rook takes Bishop trying to
promote next move was met by the really
accurate intermediate move Bishop takes
Pawn check and here Max Maxim resigned
Rook takes Pawn is still threatened if
he tries to defend then the white king
simply marches over dislodges the Black
Brook and the white Rook just in time to
take the remaining Blackboard
they are giving us some incredible
entertainment in this Winter's final
Maxim and Magnus and now Magnus is in
the lead after three games only one
rapid game to go and that's gonna be
must Win For maximum to take it to
Armageddon the drama continues after a
break
[Music]
I've been a member since 1986 nearly 40
years it's just a beautiful building
very nice staff lovely place
my name is Pisa Lee I am 79 80 later
this year I'm won the British Chess
Championship when I was 21 and I played
in the England team for about 10 years
my name is
aged eight my ratings around 1800 and I
won the world's underwright girls rapid
and Blitz championships ladies are
allowed in now but they used not to be
here until 20 years ago would you like
to see a bit of the club
no one under 14 should go in the club
foreign
[Music]
solving everything I do I do I play
bridge as well I do crosswords I do
number games I'm a medical statistician
if I call myself a problem solver
I started liking the pieces and I wanted
to take them and keep them so that my
dad said I could play chess instead
when I gave up when I was about 31 to I
was two three ninety and I've only
played one greater games since then what
did you say you're written 1900s 1800 18
even if you're not not not ahead of me
yet you'll be ahead of me in two or
three years time
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
she played a lot of very sensible moves
did you think you were winning at one
stage maybe slightly better slightly
maybe slightly better yeah you probably
were
[Music]
I just love this story and you can watch
the whole thing on chesscom's YouTube
channel this was only one of uh three
games in our
I'm not going to reveal anything
potentially four games in the
generations match between these two
amazing people and uh well talking about
Generations not long ago Tanya you went
to visit
the great legendary Vision on he invited
you into his home that must have been
such a cool experience it was the best
birthday gift of my life I think it was
a couple of days after my birthday
actually and I went over and we had we
had an amazing conversation I spent time
with Aruna uh you know he's someone I
feel like in India he's God he's someone
we've all grown up admiring been
inspired by whatever Indian chess is it
is because of him and so yeah it was a
very special moment but not just that
the interview was great it was fantastic
but you know what Kyle like right before
that we also went for breakfast me Aruna
and him and that was the best part of
the day because I got to ask him so many
questions and it was just so relaxing it
was just a special day and everything he
said about Indian chess his legacy all
of that just pure gold fantastic and
while we all want to hear some some
things from this interview it was a long
interview but here are some of the
topics that Tanya and Bishi talked about
when they met a month ago
I can think of a hundred things that the
younger generation can learn from you on
and you're on the board chest but also
off it but I want to ask you if there
was one thing that you feel you've
picked up from the younger generation
what would it be it's
um that they
lack some of the foundations that I grew
up with but in a good way
I mean if you grow up with this idea to
oversimplify double pawns are bad then
you stick with it but then somebody
comes along you know for whom my games
are the classics you know to exaggerate
the point and then they tell you no but
here I like this position you say but
yeah but it's a double pawn and they say
no
and you realize well they might have a
point it's not obvious to me so maybe I
have to update my understanding and this
is particularly pronounced nowadays
where
the computer continuously contradicts
everything we once thought
so I
you can quote Robin's time and
capablanca a lot and definitely they
played some very good games but there
are also moves they would never consider
that you have to consider nowadays to
and when youngsters look at a position
totally fresh eyes they're willing to
try some new stuff and so on
you hang out with them you realize wait
this is uh this is interesting it gives
me a new energizes you even you feel
like looking at chess because suddenly
what was forbidden is now permitted
almost and you look at it and things
like that so yes this kind of clash in
working methods and beliefs all these
things
was useful nowadays of course
computers themselves they're not really
contradict everything you you know they
contradict what they said last year then
they contradict what they said the year
before so it's more of a continuous
process now and now you see that people
are willing to play anything
uh
seems almost there are no bad openings
in chess what would you say is the
biggest challenge today for the younger
generation
the speed of Chess it's both good and
bad it's good because they have so many
more opportunities so many more
tournaments
at the same time
I don't know that necessarily that their
careers can be as long as the previous
generation because our schedule is much
lighter when we were playing and
inevitably playing so much
um
you start to see that the retirement age
or the age when you maybe move along
starts is beginning to drop I think the
replacement rate will be much faster
something about the aura of Vision on
yeah I'm such a fan
it was uh Wishy but also the room that
we were in it had all these world
championship trophies and everything
that he's won so far it's his training
room and the story in India as well this
is what happened when you become a grand
master where she actually invites you
over and you get to be in that
incredible space and just have a
conversation with him yeah it was
awesome he's got this presence he's got
this Aura and uh yeah I'm a fan and it's
incredible how he is the first ever
Grandmaster in India and today what
there's like more than 80 yeah
okay it's 83 years if I'm not wrong but
yeah he's the one who started it all
inspired and now he also trains he's
he's the mentor to all these youngsters
who are upcoming and he was our Mentor
for the Olympiad as well and I remember
we'd be all in our training camp Kaya
we'd all be having a good time laughing
talking analyzing even playing some
Avalon on the side but the moment Anand
would walk in it's pin drop silence
the amazing Vichy named maybe he's
watching this matchup Magnus Carlson is
in the lead maximum he has to win this
game four to take it to Armageddon and
have any hopes of winning the winners
finally he will have the white pieces in
a must win Magnus with a draw or a win
will go straight through to the Grand
Final that will be played on Friday here
we go here we go it's another Sicilian
it's been the opening of this match this
time switching it up Magnus no more
Sicilian night off it's a different
branch of the opening and Magnus will be
hoping that fashion the garage shows
slightly less expertise here because
Magnus was in trouble uh two games ago
when he last had black and look at mvl
now looking down away from the computer
screen just trying to pick a variation
here of course he's seen this all before
and Magnus being provocative this line
known to be dangerous for black he's not
playing Safety First chess uh safety
first uh kind of brand here
it's a silver the kill there is no
Safety First brand when it comes to open
Sicilians and uh Maxine taking it head
on he does slow down after this move
Bishop to B7 David I'm not super
familiar with this Theory after white
gets the Knight to E4 you said it's
known to be dangerous for black what are
the dangers in these positions it's
mostly the holes of the dark squared
holes around Black's King and I think we
might see those exploited by Maxine
Bachelor graph or at least an attempt to
get at them over the next few turns Maxi
Magnus had this opening last
months lost Champions chess Tour event
I'm trying to remember the opponents I
think it might have been alarisa farouza
uh but either way it was a complicated
game Magnus was on the ropes there and
uh did manage to survive eventually but
yeah let's just jump in while Maxine
thinks having been surprised by this
last move uh it's all about this whole
especially in particular uh the White
Knight wants to get at it and jumps in
instantly good timing I was a bit lucky
there the black Bishop does remove that
piece though and now the key is this
piece it's locked in Magnus wants to
break out with this Pawn push I think
this is the main move if I know my
opening Theory because you don't want
allow white time to push back this
Knight and then fix a Pawn on the C5
Square your Bishop would be dead for the
rest of the game yeah and that pawn on
D6 would be such a stronghold in the
position not you just cannot get quite
the time to advance in with that c Pawn
so expecting uh black to push C5 is that
super critical and it's on the board so
Magnus does realize that uh Maxim can
still push that night out of the way C4
still in the air
yes C4 still in the air the Black Knight
Will Retreat I'm not sure exactly where
but uh most likely this way and at least
now Magnus does have the advantage of
this bishop
uh being on a great diagonal this white
Pawn as well looks mightily strong but
could be a weakness long term in the end
game so yeah really in Balance position
Magnus not playing safe chess as we
mentioned he's taking risks and he's so
principled he's playing the opponent not
the tournament situation I think that's
instructive a lesson for everyone at
least he has great air quality more
example he's gonna need it to win this
game against the great Magnus Carlsen
and talking about great people we did
see that interview with Vichy Anon I
thought it was so interesting how he
said that the replacement rate will be
much faster going forwards now that that
people will stay for a shorter period of
time in the top now for these two Magnus
and MBL how long do you expect those two
to be you know inside top 20 maybe
depends how soon they want to retire I
expect them both if they wanted to be
especially Magnus uh to be up there for
at least another decade
in the top 20 but yeah I I agree with
Mishi I mean that's just so many
youngsters coming through it's hard to
kind of maintain the energy when you're
a slightly older player especially now
the chess is becoming much much quicker
but uh yeah that mix that blend of
experience and kind of uh energy still
these guys they're kind of managing to
cope at the moment will it be more like
other sports where you're maybe you know
in your 20s maybe it's where you you
Peak mostly and then sort of in your 30s
people start to retire
I don't know about retire but I agree
with you that chess is becoming younger
now and I think computers play such a
big role in that this entire generation
is born on computers they start playing
chess and computers now if you're not a
grand master by the time you're 13 it's
time to start thinking about another
career so things have changed a lot but
for these two for Magnus and Maxime I'm
thinking it's been now over a decade
that they've been in the world's top 10.
so that's already quite a while that is
quite a while I mean can it be another
decade I think could it be into their
40s I wouldn't be surprised I mean uh
vishy he's 54. yeah and yeah he's
playing right up there I think he's
still in the world top 10. ah he's in
and around the world top 10 that's for
sure um good cash is overtaking him as
well uh as Indian number one but kokesh
number eight I believe yeah it's uh it's
scary how strong the youngsters are but
they still have yet to displace uh
Magnus Jan upon Michigan ding contested
of the last World Championship
and they're not getting any younger I I
believe you can kind of maintain a level
for a long time but the peak probably um
Magnus said him itself uh late 20s yeah
I don't know I I don't know if anyone
will ever displace Magnus I think Magnus
himself will just decide when he's uh
sort of done with it it's it's so
difficult to imagine a player actually
overtaking Magnus even for the next five
years to me but if he just stops playing
right that rating will be just insanely
hard to overtake right you know
sometimes I think Kaya that there there
are all these great players right some
of the greatest that the Chess World has
seen and they're all around magnus's age
Anish Maxim uh Jana bom Nakamura and
everyone else in the top 10 there's 90s
kids it almost seems like it's so
unlucky that they're born at the time I
know Magnus Carlton yeah yeah it's like
being a football player in their era of
Messi and Ronaldo no one else really
gets up there and same here I mean all
of these players probably would have
challenge for world championship title
if it wasn't for Magnus and maybe that's
why now there's this entire renewed
thing of fighting for the world
championship title yeah and I think Fabi
very we've seen him perform so
incredibly well just extremely inspired
now uh I think everyone wants to become
a world champion and feels like there's
a bigger chance than there has ever been
yeah yeah it was like in the days after
Kasparov announced his retirement of
course he'd already relinquished the
title he lost that much to Chronic but
kasporov is still the Undisputed number
one suddenly uh Anand topalov kramnik
they were kind of fighting it out for
years it was unclear who the world
number one was until Magnus came along
um so yeah it definitely feels like more
up for grabs now
unless Magnus is playing in your
tournament unless it's uh unless he's
really in the in the mood in the zone
yeah those I think for the longest time
this has been going around in the Chess
World that when Magnus plays a
tournament it's a race to the second
place and that's just sort of so
disheartening for the other players uh
and really I mean exceptionally strong
Geniuses as you call and just all of
them in the top 10 well number two Fabi
well number three Hikaru just all these
guys and then they've got this final
boss to deal with yeah
and that's exactly what MBL has to deal
with right now as well he has to beat
Magnus in this game if he doesn't he
will be knocked down to the loser's
bracket to play the losers final
tomorrow do you see chances in in this
game with the situation on the board for
mvl to get that win definitely some
chances and the fact that Magnus has
slowed down on this last move uh will
make vashilograph feel extremely
optimistic Magnus have clearly prepared
this opening uh this risky line of the
Sicilian that we mentioned but now he
has sacrificed a pawn if I should have
graph happily accepted that gift white
is now a pawn up in this current
position and if he can consolidate it
then white will be winning simply
winning long term black will have no
counter play so it's all about the next
few moves Magnus not looking too happy
with himself he was kind of playing with
his hair looking away from the screen I
think he was trying to recall remember
his opening preparation the line he'd
studied before but he just doesn't look
happy with himself I don't think he was
able to pull that out of the memory bank
and this last move looks a bit past
passive but with an active threat right
you are attacking the B2 Pawn so Rook B2
is something that Maxine definitely
cannot allow uh needs to find a way to
counter that the one move you definitely
don't want to make in this position
David is rooked to be one to to guard
that pawn because suddenly that Queen
from F6 can move over to F5 and there's
another tactic with the double attack
there so Maxime has to counter this
threat but I completely agree with you
that the next few precise moves by
Maxime and he could very well just end
up with a bishop pair and an extra Pawn
on the board but how do you follow this
up because Queen to C3 I I don't know if
the queen trade is good or not but it
looks like you're spoiling your Pawn
structure and giving away quite a bit of
your advantage even if I was to trade
the Queens yeah suddenly this Black
Knight is on an outpost forever and
these two white pawns you might be a
pawn up uh but the Double C pawns give
you no chance uh of ever marching
forward really and we see the best moves
according to the computer just below the
board there and the moves we've
discussed
of course relevant but only one move to
keep the advantage a plus one advantage
though plus 1.2 there according to the
engine significant stuff and it's Bishop
to B4 that's not instinctive that's not
natural uh it's very rare to kind of
retreat a bishop and allow it to be
captured by a knight and the this is
purely to plug the B file the B file is
open for blackstroke you need to block
it uh you cannot push this Pawn that
would be desirable because your Rook is
undefended in the corner so Bishop to B4
will you spot it yes he does Maxi
version of in top form as we've
mentioned this tournament and the idea
is that if black ever takes your Bishop
actually this only improves White's
chances suddenly this Rook has opened up
and white will be able to connect three
by pushing his Pawn forward to C5 and a
very strong formation here
I'm gonna be honest David I did not that
move was not on my radar retreating
moves are hard me neither the bishop to
B4 is so impressive that by uh Maxim and
uh the more you see it the more you
realize that if the a-file was to open
up that gives white a lot of gun to play
so if Magnus really can't neutralize
this bishop on B4 uh White does have an
extra Pawn White's got those healthy
Bishops and that Bishop might just get
even more healthy once it drops back to
C3 another retreating move which hits
the queen and stops any play on the B
line and I'm loving that diagonal where
is Magnus finding his compensation then
he doesn't look happy on the camera
Magnus Carson maybe we need the engine
again to help us out here because it
looks like one more move and white has a
almost decisive advantage and wow it
says that black has to be careful
otherwise the advantage grows that kind
of backs up what we thought Tanya but
the moves are slightly surprising I've
got to say uh firstly a queen check uh
you always look for checks captures and
threats in any position but it looks
like this helps White's Bishop simply
block and uh White now one move closer
to castling to safety the other the
secondary move mentioned by the engine
may be more uh kind of ambitious here
than Knight jumping into the center
threatening a nasty Fork the Knight
would land on B3 hitting the White Queen
hitting the white Rook uh in the corner
Magnus needs to go for something like
this if he's too slow if for example he
just castles then you'll move Bishop
back to C3 attacking the attacking the
black queen next white just moves the
bishop out the way castles safety Pawn
up and a win for fashion and grav
Stakes are high and right now
how do you how difficult do you think
those moves are uh Tanya he plays one of
them he finds it uh Microsoft with Queen
E5 coming in with the check you can't
play Slow moves you can't play natural
moves anymore time is really of the
essence in this position and white has
to block that check
uh expecting
Bishop E2 with Bishop E2 might even
invite the knight jump that we were
looking at opening up that Bishop on the
diagonal putting more pressure on E2 but
David if I was to block it with the
queen then I'm just wondering that gives
black the opportunity to perhaps go for
the B4 Pawn eventually yeah uh what
would
I kind of have lost control over the B4
Square now I'm not sure whether you
trade Queens immediately but for example
if you did then it might make some sense
to try and take this B4 Pawn at least
now Magnus in a name game we know how
good he is in those still a pawn down
still an uphill struggle but uh black
has some level of stability so I don't
think vashilograph in this must win
situation will offer this trade of
Queens uh at least it's not maybe his
style and I'm expecting this move Bishop
to E2 just try and Castle you mentioned
Knight to D4 being Black's kind of uh
key move here the move Magnus is relying
on but what happens if white just steps
back and forces the issue pins forcing
you to trade off the queens and we are
left with an end game opposite colored
Bishops white with dark Square Bishop
black with light Square Bishop but white
is a pawn up and still an easy plan to
throw things forward
Casper with the opposite color Bishop
will it be enough but I think it would
be a dream position whether it's enough
or not uh Maxi will have to show great
technique but just playing for two
results you can take the G2 Pawn but
then the Rook lines up on the G line and
you end up winning the G7 Pawn with a
lot of activity so that doesn't help
magnus's cause so Queen E5 you're
pointing at the move Bishop to E2 Maxim
taking his time right now
actually I'm taking his time we're
expecting Bishop to E2 just block and
that variation we mentioned pretty much
forced and looks pretty promising for
white but will he be ambitious I'm
wondering if he's going to move his King
no surely not but what else could he be
thinking about oh my gosh oh I don't
like it I would never play it but it is
Maxime and he's in a must-win situation
and desperate times cool for desperate
measures oh my gosh
yeah King D1 would be just unreal but
now that you mention it and now that
Maxim's actually thinking about it and
and we all know what kind of a Creator
just how creative Maxime can get with
his play he doesn't go for it we just do
much to watch yeah I think this one is
safe it's logical and it's strong and if
black doesn't jump in with the Knight
now then white is a ready to Castle
ready to consolidate the material
advantage okay wow he trades off he goes
for this Pawn
but okay he's reestablished the material
balance the evaluation boss says Maxim's
just winning now there are all sorts of
tempting moves white has moves like Rook
to A5 attacking the black queen I think
we just have to show what's going on
he's grabbed a pawn Magnus but I think
this Pawn uh was actually the least
important out of all of them the Ruckus
attacks I'm wondering whether you just
shift across it's Magnus banking on
taking this Pawn wow maybe he's trying
to trap this white Rook but has he
forgotten that White's King still has
the right to Castle it still can jump to
the queen side and suddenly defend your
rook and black has pretty much gone all
in on the wrong flank
yeah that Queen and Bishop are actually
misplaced here they misplaced at once
white screen comes to G5 you're hitting
that Bishop you're hitting the pawn on
G7 now you're threatening a mid on E7 uh
and there's just no coordination you
don't even have time to get your king to
safety because shot Castle also runs
into a move like Queen G5 where the rook
and the queen will line up to that G7
Square oh David this can't be what
Magnus is counting on after Bishop takes
G2 I think what he really wants to do in
this position uh once The Rook slides
over is to further put pressure on that
Bishop on E2 with a move like Bishop F3
try and get the Queens off the board but
that doesn't help the cause this is a
pin and now white has some tempting
moves I'm looking at this hit on the
black queen I'm hit looking at this hit
on the black queen just to try and break
the PIN
still kind of a wild position still
really rare this type of scenario really
unorthodox so the players cannot rely on
pattern recognition but it is
effectively good for white Maxine just
needs to calm himself down and he goes
for the other move I mentioned maybe the
more natural move uh just hitting the
black queen first black queen only has
one safe Square to kind of keep this pin
and now Maxine does move his Rook the
bishop drops back
valuation people are not impressed still
looks good for white but maybe no kind
of natural way now to meet all of the
threats suddenly this might be a bit of
a nasty one a check from the back crank
the only thing that explains this will
Rook to A5 because for me Rook G1 was
really natural is that Maxim did not
like losing that H2 Pawn he wanted to
First kick the queen out of the center
of that square uh to make sure that it
doesn't get to the H2 Pawn but in that
bargain he's given you access on the
other side of the board uh Maxime going
for that G7 pawn it allows a lot of
dangerous tracks into White's Camp yeah
we advocate for greed greed is good
grabbing pawns unless the opponent has
counter play and this check is really
awkward for white to deal with if you
block with your Bishop you're eternally
tied down here and black can maybe even
just trade everything off uh oh nope not
that one maybe black takes this bishop
instead and now it starts munching his
supports get greedy Queen takes B2
attacking The Rook attacking the B4 Pawn
which would attack the other Rook uh
this would be bad news so if Queen B1
what does white want to do in that
situation because it looks pretty fast
the line that you're pointing out yeah
it looks like you can maybe force it
this way as well trading the Bishops and
then giving this valuable check and no
matter what white drops back and we have
that same position Tanya I think Maxine
maybe has underestimated magnus's
counter play and the black king which
was vulnerable in those other variations
suddenly safe if White's Rook was just
the a rook just back on A1 none of this
would exist
small differences but they make a huge
diff huge effect here yeah
yeah I'm saying how the position changes
with that one Rook move you try to guard
one side of the board but lose control
of the other side of the board and now
it's all in magnus's hand his own fate
Queen B1 check or First Trade on YouTube
but I like the idea of going Queen B1
first just feels more forcing David
uh and uh wow and Magazine's only a draw
it needs only a draw and that variation
will be pointed out with Black's Queen
jumping in checking winning some pawns
suddenly end games would likely become
safe for black and we all know Magnus
the skills in the end games and can I
just play how bizarre this position is
it's been the story of the day every
game is so weird wacky wonderful and
unique
inaccurate and inaccurate that's the
most surprising thing that the players
are able to navigate their way through
such choppy Waters
uh surprising stuff but impressive stuff
really
means is you know you're used to seeing
the pieces develop talking about pun
structures talking about King safety and
a game take a long turn but each and
every game that we've seen so far and
this one as well I mean what even is
going on the kings are in the center
there's a Pawn on D6 that white has
white truck is already on G7
it's just Madness all across
again it's a bit like yesterday we saw
some games where like players just
Shuffle pieces throw them randomly on
the board and they just appear like this
and Magnus does go for that trade gives
the check takes the pawn as we predicted
I think Max seems winning chances are
dwindling by the move jointly by the
second here problem is his Rooks are
attacked okay there is a checkmating
threat I didn't spot this one white is
threatening to lift his Rook up to G8
check that black king catch it on the
back rank but first Magnus takes a form
of check the white king does it move or
does white block
I think he's gonna get the other bond
with check as well because if you were
to put the queen on D2 then black Magnus
would have the option to give more
checks on the board so Maxim is just
relying on the background trick that
you're talking about uh black can Magnus
can't pick up the other Pawn with the
check the king slides to G1 to safety
and then you've got that big threat on
the board and I think what Magnus needs
to do then is to slide with his own King
over to the king side uh protecting that
G8 Square King G1 King f8 is what I'm
expecting
seem suddenly looks really happy leaning
back yeah kind of stretching is he like
okay I've got a chance really happy or
he's given up
could be either
he is currently two pawns down the
Frenchman uh but he's in the flow he
wants to attack his King is safe and
watch out for checkmate okay the black
Rook cuddles up with its king blocking
any potential checks now it's harder it
takes longer for white to break through
what oh a rook sacrifice instantly from
Maxine Bachelor grave
this is crazy this is genius there's
checkmating ideas all over the place
Magnus has missed this one look at
magnus's reaction
yes it's just an amazing move black can
capture it with the king or The Rook but
Danger's everywhere David I think we
have to jump in with an analysis board
if you take it with the Rook uh go on
take uh David yeah I was just gonna say
look below there's only one move
otherwise white has a plus eight
Advantage the only move is not an
obvious one you cannot actually take
this Rook you have to move your queen to
E4 but that is incredibly hard let's
just show those variations you mentioned
Tanya Rook takes Rook allows a check
only one move to block allows another
check only one move to run and Checkmate
your court if you take with the King
equally disastrous here King takes met
by a check and another check and another
check and a mate finally the kiss of
death
whoa so one move now for Magnus Carlsen
and he finds it wow and he finds it in
less than a minute
key idea is you're actually threatening
a Counter-Strike on White's first rank
that's so so tough to spot and he also
covers any checks if Rook takes rook and
a king takes suddenly White Queen has no
checks to deliver
centralization and
heartbreak from vashilograph he thought
he was winning yeah spotted this
incredible trick and it's poof I
wouldn't say backfired it was incredible
but suddenly he meets with just stoic
defense yeah and I think it's on Maxim's
face he realizes it and David I think
you're absolutely right that Maxine felt
with Rook takes F7 taking that Bond it
was game over and it was it was all all
a Maxime show but Queen E4 just finding
this fantastic move and uh it's all
turned around
this has been
incredible once again by Magnus another
level this is just crazy poor Maxime he
plays a brilliancy an amazing Rook
sacrifice that cannot be captured he's
on the brink of checkmating Magnus and
Magnus finds the only defense and it's
such a hard move how did Magnus find
that and so quickly as well right David
like you would see Rook F7 and you're
playing you would just give up you would
resign you'd think that it's all over
for your king but again in these high
pressure situations Magnus just finding
the best defensive resource and I wonder
if he saw this in advance if this was an
idea that was there in his head already
or did he just find it after Rook takes
Bond I think Magnus is a bit lucky
if white hadn't stopped to this idea I
think his plan was to play this move
anyway so the fact that this move was
probably on his radar means that he was
able to quickly calculate that it
survives it clings on it covers all the
important squares and all Maxim can do
is give a check with that Rook on E7 and
unfortunately that's not the case of
that Checkmate because that's not a
queen and black skin just goes to d8
absolutely safe there sidesteps any
checks and the threat of Rook to B1 on
the first rank is just Unstoppable
there's nothing that you can do with
white to stop that yeah just how is the
evaluation bar still in the middle it
looks like either white is checkmating
black or black is going to bring his
Rook to B1 and win the White Queen I
think I understand David wow okay maybe
I don't hit me with it Tanya what I
wanted to do was uh go Rook E7 check
only move for black double up on the
seventh rank because I have one move and
I'm hoping that after Rook B1 I've got
enough count to play on this wow well
rugby won the most natural move look
like you're winning pinning and winning
the White Queen but this would be a
mistake white can take upon with check
uh King moves to see it King 8 is
Checkmate in one check move to B8 and
maybe I can come back and block oh I
saved the day I cover the first rank
this is incredible Maxim's found an
equally incredible move he's not even
given the check I think maybe he should
have started with this Tanya first he
brings his Rook up the board this is
really flashy Rook takes Rook he will
give a check and it is a sacrifice but
white will give uh this one uh this
nasty check with the queen and now
suddenly the black king cannot move
remember this is a background Checkmate
so Black's Queen would have to dive in
the way give its life to block and this
would be crazy white would now take the
black queen and
what a position we have here queen
versus two Rooks valuation Bar says draw
but this is far from it this is far from
over if Maxim gets this position he's
going to try and play this out because
the D6 Pawn combined with the queen can
set up some mating ideas in that and the
H Pawn can also start advancing down the
board so that would still be a game on
for these players so Rook G7 I like it
it keeps more practical chances in the
position this is true he has set a trap
and that line that we mentioned the most
natural move bringing the Rook down
would lead to that uh kind of
transposition white would give a check
first
and kind of Chase the king into the
corner a check a check a check and then
a block and white would keep his King
Safe Keep His Queen safe and be winning
thanks to this powerful Pawn oh Magnus
needs to be a little careful right now
he has to find the right defense I think
he has to give up his Queen Magnus
Carlson he's done it already today more
than once and he has to do it yet again
one final time he has to take this Rook
bite the bullet and hope that he
survives and he does remember this is
the variation check a queen check and
black has to block with his Queen
throwing the Queen off the board to
survive it still looks scary with the
black king disconnected uh but yeah he
will be
holding on here maybe blocking with his
Rook more accurate
oh let's jump back Magnus Carlson This
Is The Moment of Truth he has to take
this white Rook I mean he found Queen E4
I think he's going to find Rook F7 as
well and it has to be through process of
elimination you know just if you spot
the idea that the white trip can come to
defense on the other line from the C
file that we saw if blackstroke was to
jump in uh then Magnus just goes for
Rook takes Rook yeah yeah
and thinking about it he's really lucky
that Magnus has some time if he played
this when both players had one two
minutes left yeah I think Magnus would
have just resigned or collapsed but the
fact that Magnus has this luxury of
three four minutes this is where time
kind of uh balancing the there we go
Rook takes Rook best move uh yeah just
balancing that kind of accuracy versus
time uh dilemma is so important yeah
time management in these formats is
absolutely critical uh David bit once
again this position I I think Maxine's
going to try uh he has to try well
there's no other option because a draw
is as good as a loss right now Maxim in
a must-win situation he's going to pick
up that pawn on G6 or is he thinking
about ideas of setting up some meeting
uh threats along that E7 Square
usually it still looks so dangerous if
you could pick up the White Queen just
drop her on E7 his Checkmate but the
problem is Black's Rook is such a
staunch Defender here and oh evaluation
part moves Magnus should have blocked
with his Rook what oh you've got to hide
with King the p7 because the King goes
back you lose the Rook on be it but it's
coming at the cost of some pawns which
Queen is going to get greedy here Magnus
saw one safe Square he's gonna hide in
the corner of the board but suddenly
White's gonna get a bunch of Pawns
whoa really crazy position still I think
Magnus kind of dropped the ball there
slightly he could have just uh kept
everything intact but
adventurous with this King as always
it's a crazy position so if you go back
to Ed White actually just picks up the
D7 pawn and then we're talking about a
d-passer and an H boss parser and a
potential drop of the E6 spawn as well
decide really carefully now which
direction to go back in as you say just
to point out your variation Tanya
dropping back to the corner looks safer
but comes with the custom pawns and
watch out yeah watch out for the white
deep one to make a nuisance of itself
but David
enforce this right even if you were to
go to see it you've got this idea of
Queen going to C5 and then giving a
check from C7 and picking up the D7 Pawn
Yeah and we're seeing that yeah we'll
see this on the board at Queen check I
don't know which way Magnus will go back
at least he has the options here but
Queen takes Pawn still
now it's on the board
and maybe that was the difference that
the King on A6 uh Magnus Fields is
better placed than the King on eight and
I believe him yeah I don't know why but
I do
we tend to believe Magnus when he uh
when he goes for something in the end
game and okay he goes for the white
Depot now if this Pawn is captured just
to point out uh on E6 then black is
going to try to surround
the past Pawn on the D file still some
chances white wishes all of his pawns
were connected unfortunately they're all
isolated the Deep horn separated from
the F1 separate from the H Pawn still
some drawing chances
Rook attacking the queen and Maxim not
immediately picking up the E6 spawn
which again just uh gives us such an
insight into his mind right that he does
slow down he's looking at options most
of us would just automatically go for
this move eventually he does
how is Magnus playing so quickly in this
position and
security I mean every move he has five
or six options now uh with black and
Maxine did he smile there he's like I
think he's getting frustrated his
opponent's defending so well and yeah if
any of those white pawns were just next
to each other they could kind of walk up
the board but I promise the black Rooks
on the back rank actually guard all of
the promotion squares uh the two black
Brooks together cover everything and
black does have some counter play
Black's a pawn ready start marching
White's got to get the other two pawns
uh up the board start pushing the F Pawn
and the H Bond right now he's
threatening a big check on C7 as well
well it could be a big check in some
positions so you have to watch out for
that
yeah that's so wild does black have the
time to actually go ahead with that a
pawn already start pushing the pawn
yes we're reveal all
right he will it's it's the whole sort
of going down for mvl to win this game
and take it to Armageddon or you said
they're still
drama here yeah without seeing the
evaluation bar I would be extremely
optimistic uh as white but the clock
situation the fact that uh blackstrokes
are already on the dream defensive
squares
um I think unless objectively he has
some big chances it's going to be hard
to push uh push this one further into a
win and there we go Magnus is the one
pushing this time onto A5 and I feel
like neither of them deserves to lose
this game I have to say because it's
just been so fantastic I couldn't agree
more with that I think this match has
been just incredible to witness such
Fighting Chess accurate chess uh
combative play attacking play by both
these players neither backing down but
in the end there has to be one way yeah
yeah and Kaya also I think the drama
isn't over in this one okay they're
gonna see a lot I'll just lean back and
enjoy the commentary then fantastic what
a match we're having here yeah it feels
like there's still some twists 83 in
like three seconds what happened there
yeah we blinked for one moment and the
porn it looked like it moved three four
squares in forward in one move but the
white king is coming and he's trying to
set up a meeting that around the black
king I don't really see it I've got to
be honest uh but Maxim he's trying to
scare Magnus here and you've got to be
careful when you push the pawn if the
black pawn pushes now then white could
at least take it off the board dropping
the White Queen back
I wonder if Magnus is going to even
plant a rook behind the passport on that
again tends to be
a decent strategy here let's just show
what happens if Magnus tries to rush to
the Finishing Line uh it's a Sprint
finish here if he pushes the pawn then
white could check it's a double attack
and the pawn undefended the pawn would
drop off next still maybe a draw but uh
reluctant to do that magnet he does
indeed try to use the Rook as a
propeller uh for the pawn in the corner
he's supporting it and he's just going
to push till the bit around Maxine
meanwhile going forward with his King
wow
look at this if he pushes his Pawn will
he get mated Magnus Carlsen on the edge
of the board
how is white gonna trap him here
the king's living a Charmed Life if the
white king marches forward black does
have a check to kick the king back and
Magnus he's calling this uh bluffing now
he's going to A4 maybe you just lose
that A2 Pawn now because of the airline
what's happening the king steps for what
you're taking a Checkmate on B4 and The
Rook is hanging he's
he's um The Queen Is Coming forward to
B4 it's Checkmate Checkmate guaranteed
oh my gosh
um Magnus can't believe it and Maxime
flexing again and a smile from Magnus
are we heading to our Marketo the answer
is yes
yes I think we are because there's no
way to fight this you've got Queen B4 a
big Checkmate coming in I mean queen
takes Pawn is also Checkmate two
different check mating threats black is
losing a rook
we saw the reaction from both players
Maxim Miracles happened
we're heading into the
[Music]
into players
believe it it's been such an accurate
match Magnus has played fantastic today
and a blunder to take you to Armageddon
Tanya you called it you had the feeling
just this uh this Instinct that
something crazy was about to happen it
felt like it was building and Magnus
took too many risks he could have
probably looked it down and won this
Pawn in a safer way but he marched his
King to the edge of the board and was
punished that was the best King of the
Hill game that I've seen
Maxine getting his King all the way to
C5 and checkmating Magnus and what is
happening now magnus's clock is ticking
is he just getting ready to resign he's
getting ready for the Armageddon right
now what he knows that this is over he's
getting his uh mindset ready for the
next one I I don't even think there's a
way to prolong this no you just have to
give up a rook you have to check the
white king away but the white king will
happily take a rook and
we all know Queen vs Rook how hopeless
that is bangus allows a Checkmate on the
board and we have Armageddon we have
Armageddon to decide the winners final
mvl makes an incredible comeback
in the fight against roll number one
Magnus Carlsen to take it to Armageddon
they will now have a little bit of time
to place their bids for time for the
Armageddon to decide who goes straight
through to the Grand Final on Friday and
who is knocked down to the losers final
tomorrow this game I just I've been
following the twitch chat everyone is
just going crazy about this incredible
game it ends with a blunder for Magnus
take us through the action here David
what a game it was it ends with a
mistake from Magnus Carlson but Maxine
came up with some really creative ways
to keep the game going and to create
this uh this mating net around the black
king and Magnus had taken some chances
but it was Maxim's maneuver walking the
king slowly but surely towards its
counterpart that clinched it here
stepping forward and Magnus started to
go astray the safe route here towards
the draw would have been to bring the
black Rook across note how it's cutting
across the sea file stopping the white
king from inching close so instead
Magnus continued pushing his Pawn to A2
a check and this was the mistake instead
of uh what he did he could have thrown
this Pawn away forcing the white king to
break the bind uh and walked back with
his King instead he took upon a poisoned
porn and after King to C5 he suddenly
realized it dawned on him two checkmates
and they are unstoppable Queen takes
Pawn would trap the king but more
importantly Queen to B4 also trapping
the king and that's how the game ended
Queen takes A2 game over Maxim Strikes
Back
how would you describe this match so far
Tanya and Valiants minus it's the icon
it's absolutely insane yeah it is
absolutely insane and what should we
expect now David with Armageddon coming
up I've given up with predictions in
this match it's gonna be a wild game
really unbalanced and who knows who's
gonna win but you know when we were
talking about the Armageddon between
we felt it would be about getting the
white pieces getting more time on the
clock I think David switches around in
this one the players are going to try to
get the black pieces uh but it is how
low can you go for the black people oh
wow we could see some super low uh bids
for time everyone just take a break go
grab your popcorn and get ready for
Armageddon we will be back in a few
minutes
foreign
[Music]
loves playing chess and everyone loves
chess club
but there's also a time and a place for
playing all your favorite games
hey we're trying to have a lesson here
you need to get out of here recently
more kids have been playing chess than
ever in school but sadly we've learned
that they may not always be playing
chess at the most appropriate time
while it might be sometimes okay to grab
a game between classes or if your
teacher gives you permission and hasn't
given you an assignment it's not okay to
be playing chess in school when you
aren't supposed to and chess should
never come between you taking your
studies seriously and cooperating with
your fellow students and teachers
just over the board or on the phone is a
great way to spend time with friends but
let's make sure that this school year we
don't let too much chess happen in the
classroom focus on your school because
chess.com will always be there when
class is over
[Applause]
[Music]
can we get some other letters please
what's wrong with it
[Music]
welcome everyone we are here with Judith
Polgar the legendary chess player one of
the greatest chess players of all time
and I went to my next move I said no I'm
not moving my queen I'm not moving my
Bishop but actually I'm going to give
Checkmate or winning great material and
I went 93.
[Music]
it works only that way if your attacker
you sacrifice something go all the way
until the end don't chicken out in the
meantime at some point because many
times there is a point there is no way
back it's only forward
yeah
how is it to play with casparo when you
saw him personally
he really had this incredible energy
shoot it thank you so much for being
with us and I hope you hope you're ready
to to dive into the past with us oh
absolutely I'm very happy to share with
you some of my most memorable games
and I hope you are ready for Armageddon
to decide the winners final between
Magnus Carlsen and maximum vashiella
grow it's been an incredible fight so
far it couldn't be decided in the rapid
portion so it's going to be Armageddon
it's got to be a check mate right I mean
that King has got to go oh there it is
did he just miss that oh my God
everything and that's it not about takes
the armor Garden
[Laughter]
yeah this is just a master class in not
allowing the opponent any activity any
counter play at all
oh my God oh my God he's got it what a
move from Fabiano world class move from
fabianos this is a game-ending move
oh my God
we see a reaction
oh no Magnus Mouse left this black porn
is gonna completely paralyze the white
pieces and I think he's had enough
is the winner just feels like Panic for
Borussia he was the underdog in this
match with his current event the better
player today and the music
in the Army Garden
we had a view armageddons this season on
the Champions chess tour What words
describe the situation we're entering
now Tanya
I think it's a 50 50. I mean the kind of
match that we've just seen right now
it's not just the score line but the
chest that we witnessed by both these
players high accuracy insane positions
on the board it's not been about
theoretical battles it's just been about
all out a blood fight uh by these two uh
guy I think it's so important who gets
the black pieces in these Armageddon you
don't want to close your eyes you don't
want to miss a thing we are very soon
finding out the bids but first the
regulations for Armageddon it's all
about the bids the player that bids the
lowest can choose to play either with
the white or the black pieces usually
they will choose the black pieces that
means you will play with the type you
have bid and with a draw or win you will
win the match the player with the white
pieces will have 15 minutes on the clock
but we'll have to win the game to win
the match and remember there is no
increment in Armageddon and are you guys
ready for the bids oh my gosh uh do you
have them yep we have the bids let's do
it let's see what Magnus and mvl
have been Magnus going down to 8 minutes
and 28 seconds and he has of course
chosen to play with the black pieces 8
minutes 28 seconds what's your reaction
David well that's about as low as you
can go especially against the speed
demon like Maxine fashion it's going to
be tough on the board it's going to be
tough on the clock I think that's a
risky bit Maxine went higher a risky bit
but again I think Magnus just makes his
intentions clear that he wants the black
pieces and he's going to try and shut
down everything uh but again it's hard
when you're playing a player like a
maxim who always finds ways to create a
Chaos on the board it's going to be a
really fun one yeah with 15 minutes on
the clock must win for MBL what will it
be about for him now in this game David
well he'll have over six minutes extra
on the clock I think it's just
prolonging the tension we saw as the
clock stick down there Magnus did
blunder at the end so if you can keep
the game going especially if it's
complicated especially with Queen still
on the board I think he has a lot of
chances I think that's the key don't
trade Queens
okay don't trade queens and also it's
been a long day for these two players
now they have been so accurate but in
the end there we did see a few more
inaccuracies do you think fatigue will
play a part in this game as well Tanya
not for these guys I think they're also
a part of them they're really enjoying
this match the back and forth the
trading and punches that we're seeing
happen here gloves are on and I think
they're really ready for this one Magnus
making sure that he's got some good air
quality as well once the Armageddon
starts he's got the good air quality
opening his window he's got the good
secret lab chair he is getting
comfortable and getting ready Magnus
Carlsen coming from A Loss mvl in a
must-win situation was able to get that
win in game four to take it to this
Armageddon we always talk about momentum
is that on his side now David it's
definitely on his side but then again
there's nobody better in chess history
of bouncing back from a defeat than
Magnus Carlsen you nearly never see him
lose two games in a row I think that's
only happened a handful of times uh
throughout his entire career and okay
we're off and it's a switch-up of
opening no more Sicilians Magnus is
going slightly more solid with the
carry-cond defense wow I'm surprised I'm
kind of tempted to say mouse left just
one step ahead C5 would have been the
Sicilian but uh Caro it is the opening
of choice so Magnus wants to try and
keep things solid David both of them are
such speech as Specialists when it comes
to Mouse skills and if it comes down to
those seconds who do you think is faster
given like 30 seconds on the clock each
oh if it's 30 seconds each depends on
the position but I would say maybe
slightly Magnus uh just because we know
he got to the bullet Chess Championship
final against Hikaru
um he won the speed Chess Championship
which comprises of bullet uh but
fashionograph is of course quick on the
mouse and if he still keeps a Time lead
remember no increment now and then I
think he will fancy his chances
meanwhile uh this opening is something
actually Magnus himself has employed
from the white side uh Maxine
vashilograph pausing still a very
well-known position this inclusion of
each Pawn pushes White's pawn and H4
black spawn on H5 makes it difficult for
both sides to Castle on that flank so
it's more Dynamic and
yeah with this one is shaping up nicely
as well it's really simmering already I
can sense a proper fight coming along
and okay Magnus pausing making a bit of
a gesture there and then brings his
Queen out
nice move you've got a threat in the eye
you are targeting that B2 Pawn also
clearing the way for a potential Queen
side castling at some point if it does
come down to finding a safe spot for the
king uh oh what's that gesturing about
maybe Magnus frustrated about the
opening choice or not remembering his
theory or he's frustrated surprised
about something but as far as I know
this is still kind of within known
territory so what could it be is it the
mouse is it a mosquito flying around who
knows at this point and I was saying
don't trade queens and Maxime offers a
queen trade yeah really surprising
that's not the theoretical move normally
white just advances the queen one square
to cover all the pawns uh but now the
Queens are staring off at each other and
I think this will favor Magnus Carlson
now it will become more strategic rather
than the kind of dynamite type of Chess
uh fashion degrath has been playing and
was successful within that last game and
now that you've put your queen on that
spot you can't really Retreat it because
the B2 Pawn is under Fire so the queen
trade will be on offer but it's about
who trades on who's term if black was to
take it opens up the airline for maxim
and that's what he's counting on for the
compensation of that Queen trade
activity along the a file if Magnus
takes uh if Maxine takes the queen then
Magnus says thank you very much and
captures with the Apon himself but Queen
to B3 I I'm I'm I don't think that was a
great decision by Maxime yeah I would
even go as far as saying I hate that
decision from White just you're playing
Magnus cars and we know how strong he is
in the end game we know how good he is
with kind of manipulating Pawn
structures and now the pawn structure in
the center is fixed Queens are nearly
guaranteed to come off the board where's
the energy was the uh dynamism in your
position now I think it's lacking for
vashilograph I think he will regret this
opening Choice maybe less familiar and
he castles Queen side trying to add some
spice but the queen side castling
doesn't look so impressive with Queen's
about to come off exactly right David
you'd love this the queen side castling
had Maxine just put his Queen on D2 the
square just above from where he starts
from instead of the queen trade offer
because now that the movie The Rook has
moved away from the airline why black
can actually trade destroy Maxine Bond
structure and The Rook finds itself not
on an Ideal Square on D1
they are not an ideal structure at all
for white and you do have more space in
the center but with the kind of lack of
Queens here no attack incoming and it's
only black that has targets let's just
quickly show some of those uh Tanya
firstly the Double B pawns which look
fine right now but they might become
vulnerable later might become weak
Magnus is threatening to wreck the white
porn structure giving another set of
double pawns by taking this Knight and
if for example white guards against that
then black does have a break this Pawn
is slightly vulnerable it's a backward
pawn and I think black can start
profiting from this by trading off first
of all and at the very least if you just
need a draw you can start trading
Bishops
look at these isolated pawns doubled
isolated uh this point of Target as well
it just looks horrible here for white
we've seen crazy positions all match in
the rapid motion and then in the
Armageddon suddenly Maxine decides to go
for this queen trade offer and I'm
thinking about what you said earlier
Kaya uh is fatigue factor is uh that's
what we're witnessing right now with the
play that we're seeing
yeah uh definitely I think it's
emotional as well Armageddon I've had a
few myself throughout my career and you
often make decisions that just are
uncharacteristic you're overthinking
things and I think Max invested growth
was so desperate to get a surprising
against magnus's caricon defense that he
was the first one to slip and now Magnus
is just cynically and effectively
trading off pieces
still looking very very healthy for
Black Earth the clock situation maybe uh
the one thing that could trip him up a
bit later on
actually meanwhile just solidifying
controlling some of those balls we've
mentioned yeah but I like this move
because now it's going to be you can you
can solidify the bonds on the king side
David but now they're going to be new
targets on the center of the board as
well or you need to take a decision to
grab that pawn because there was too
much pressure on that E5 Square the
bishop has to fall back and the black
king can even Step Up on F7 connecting
the two Rooks first Magnus decides to
reroute the Knight to the center of the
board the Knight is coming to E6
so logical so smooth things are flowing
now for Magnus and I think even with two
three minutes on the clock he might uh
even be the favorite here would you say
that Magnus has been very smooth
he's doing okay and Knight f8 I just
want to point out why this is such a
good maneuver he's zeroing in on the
targets this isolated Pawn in particular
in the middle of the board Magnus is
ganging up on it he's got one Knight
hitting it the other night is going to
come to E6 to hit this Pawn as well and
remember this Pawn's Defender is going
to be eliminated in the next few turns
it's just consistent uh smooth play
looking very good for white right now
this pin is awfully annoying
don't see any redeeming factors in
White's position especially in a
must-win situation right now Knight to
E6 comes with power for example if white
just plays a natural move the Knight
lands also threatening this bishop and
uh okay he's recruited his Knight he's
trying to trade off pieces I don't like
that move yeah I really hates that move
but I don't think there are too many
good options he's trying to trap this
bishop at least
but maybe Magnus is going to ignore this
complicated stuff I think if I were just
playing Safety First chess I would trade
off these Bishops just move the Black
Knight into the center you have full
stability you just need a draw that's it
and it's surprisingly Maxine captures
with the other night so he really wants
uh that G1 Knight to come back to the
center of the board a really interesting
maneuvering there uh by the pieces now
in this Armageddon right it's not about
creating an attack or winning chances
directly you have to play on your
opponent's clock as well so as long as
Maxime just keeps enough pieces on the
board continues to put pressure on the
clock I think he will get his chances
I'm seeing so much love for both players
in social media and the twitch chat just
after this incredible match they have
played a lot of people have been sharing
for maxim just to get to the Armageddon
and now it feels like none of them
deserve to lose this much because they
just been incredible today and I think
they've really earned that love today
yeah you know with the play and the
entertainment that we've had with their
chess so I can imagine the fans just not
knowing who to root for in this one yeah
yeah but do send your love and do send
your energy whoever you are rooting for
just uh keep your messages coming we
love seeing them yeah both players
brought their a game and that's why we
love chess that's why we love sports in
general and uh there's no better
scenario than when both players are
firing on all cylinders and okay right
now Magnus is kind of transformed his
Advantage he did have a long-term
structure uh kind of superiority so I'm
surprised he traded off White's isolated
Pawn in the center that weak Pawn he's
given himself an isolated poor now
Magnus Carlson but he's activated his
pieces the Black Knights have targets
and still looks pretty healthy Tanya a
really big Target right on F2 and it's
not a very pleasant uh space to be in to
try and defend that pawn because your
Rook also has to guard the other Rook
you really don't have the time to defend
it so Maxime now relinquishing uh the
control of the A-line Magnus gets an
active Rook on the open file F2 is still
under attack
I do like Black's position and the
clocks are also leveling out a little
bit now they are and that's not good
news for Maxine vashilograph just to
show what white would love to do here is
move his rook and be given an extra turn
to activate his Knight if black did
something silly then white suddenly
would maybe even uh stake a claim for
the advantage by double attacking these
two weak pawns but the problem is you
can't move uh two pieces at once and if
you do take a time out uh to defend this
weakness on F2 then black is first to
strike the black Bishop activates and
there's just too much pressure on the
base of White's Pawn chain the bass is
always the weakest point and right now
it is this Pawn which will drop and if
this Pawn drops the next Pawn will drop
and the next Pawn will drop
that of course will mean The
Disappearance of any winning chances you
did have six minutes advantage on the
clock Gabriella at the start of this
game it is down now to only two minutes
and with the white pieces he has to win
this game Magnus will go through with a
draw and there's that now definitely the
most likely
this case scenario draw uh in If This
Were maybe a classical game or a longer
rapid game the nerves the clock they do
add a bit of spice okay Maxine defending
things controlling the pawns but the
problem is at the very least black can
trade off at night for this bishop and
wreck the white Pawn structure
again it feels like it's fizzling out
and you're pointing out all these
weaknesses in White's Camp right once
the ponds uh do get separated but I
think what Maxim is relying on is the
move the Knight for me to Jumping onto
F4 and trying to Target the H5 and the
D5 Pawn I'm trying to find a way for
white here to create chances and the one
plan that comes to mind is if somehow
you can trade one of the one of these E3
or G3 pawns for the H5 Pawn if Maxim is
able to create a passer on the H line
then we're in business at least we've
got a game in our hands but right now
Magnus in full control
yeah and he'll be aware that he just
needs to shut down this game so any hint
any spark of counter play Magnus will
just try and trade off some pieces and
there we go now saying to White if you
ever land a knight on F4 firstly pawns
will drop but secondly I can just trade
off and Black's Knight in the middle is
the dominant piece right now compare
them to whitesnites lacking uh lacking a
bit of scope but okay going after some
isolated pawns like seem really fighting
here
what will Magnus do will he try and
trade things off will he just
temporarily go passive and defend his
Pawn in the middle
you could start getting greedy right
because if you do uh pick up that pawn
on G3 which is currently attacked by two
pieces and only defended by one piece uh
uh well Magnus takes another decision
but it felt like that should be fine as
well with the black king defending the
H5 Pawn with King G6 at the end of all
of that but instead Magnus is he playing
for more here he goes Rook to C5 defends
that and again a big question to Maxime
how do you fight against the threat on
the board of the G3 Pawn
oh that's really not easy the last thing
you want to do is make a passive move
with your Rook uh defending this Pawn
maybe you have to to keep the game alive
no Maxim doesn't want to play ugly chess
he plays Knight to F4 very active but
okay this Knight simply traded off
immediately by Magnus Carson and what
next is he going to bring his Knight
back around to go for some Pawns
really nice idea and I think white will
have to stop it with his own night jump
to D4 at some point if Black's Knight
lands on F5 that's bad bad news for
maxim but again just compare the pieces
right David a white Black's Rook on C5
not only defending the D5 Bond but an
active place it's an active Defender uh
the plans that we're discussing are on
the board Black's night looking to get
to F5 goes back to D6 white jumps in
with his own Knight to D4 so there's no
more Knight F5 and now that there's no
attack on D5 Magnus reroutes The Rook to
find his own Target
now he's looking for open lines here
open files or maybe backward pawns to
stare at this backward Pawn on E3 is a
severe weakness and yeah really nice
maneuver there I was about to say
Maxim's got the best position he's had
all game but this last move from Magnus
really rubbing salt in the wounds saying
okay I can even switch my focus to the
other side
and okay Maxine meanwhile while uh kind
of Magnus goes for the king side he's
gonna try and aim at the queen side he's
gonna swing his Rook across
doesn't look too effective to me it
doesn't look like there are any clear
paths through yeah but he's trying he's
trying uh and I I think Maxim's trying
as well because he wants to place his
own Rook on the B line like you pointed
out and then you've got a Target on B7
tying down that Knight to D6 again I
think this is going to go on and of
course it will go on but Maxim he's got
ideas in this game as well a draw is not
going to be enough now he wants to come
in penetrate with the Rook to the
seventh rank Magnus meanwhile trying to
win uh the H Pawn wow I'm really
surprised that Magnus is allowed a check
whites Rook will now break through to
the seventh rank that's the most
consistent move at least or maybe The
Rook will come up to C5 to win Black's
isolated Pawn in the center suddenly it
feels like chances it's no longer the
sterile kind of balanced end game that
we were kind of staring at for a while
suddenly it might become a pawn race
Magnus I think is uh kind of going all
in on the fact that Knights are terrible
at stopping Rook spawns A and H pawns uh
that's why he's going for blacks Pawn on
H4 but reacting there Magnus Carson
and often when he makes
a ring it is about his own play very
often so is he now regretting this move
oh I'm not really sure because I kind of
like what he's doing as well he wants to
go in for that H Pawn and I think he
believes in the chances of that H5 but
yeah I'm not really sure what that was
about because you could tell that he
wasn't happy about something in that
moment and has he let go of some chance
or some clear way to shut things down
ah
maybe he's just frustrated that he had
full control and now he's relinquished
that control now it's slightly more
random than it used to be at least with
whites from Rook getting active probably
still holdable probably still uh within
the drawing Realms but
Magnus yeah he's such a perfectionist
that any little detail frustrates him
and not just a one and a half minute
advantage on the clock for maxim but at
least there is an imbalance in the bond
structure and that's the best that Maxim
could have hoped for Magnus jumps in
with the Knight wanting to grab that E
Pawn the more pawns that get traded off
the board the easier the task becomes
from Magnus
yeah he's really trying to eliminate all
danger just going Pawn hunting
and yeah active play by black it's
recommended I've recommended absolutely
and it's probably recommended for white
to get active as well but the problem is
that if you jump in with your knight to
F5 hitting that Rooker then the black
Rook actually lands on the second rank
you can decide to give a check first or
a go Rook H2 directly but there is
another Target in the position on the
queen side the B2 Pawn as you're
highlighting yeah that's the Target
right now in the current position this
is the big Target and white gives a
check but after the black king moves
Professor goes back black can at the
very least capture this pawn and the
danger is slowly dissipating now it's
the F Pawn that is being stared up by
the black rook and in terms of a race
this Pawn is so much slower than Black's
H Pawn uh look how quick Black's age
Pawn is to run down the board so right
now A draw is looking like the most
likely result just not enough though for
vashi degrath yeah just not enough Bonds
on the board left right and like you're
pointing out David that H Pawn is just
so much faster right now uh Magnus
coming in with the rook and the h-bond
will start marching down the board also
notice how the Black Knight is a good
range of the B Pawn of Maxim's Pawn
while the White Knight will struggle to
come close to that H5 Bond because that
F6 Pawn takes away some of the keys
defending squares in the position
and the H Pawn is sprinting now towards
its promotion Square White's king would
love to be on any active Central Square
I think that's the one thing holding
Maxine fashion DeGraw back right now his
King the white king is so misplaced
because he's actually caught the black
king in a mating net the white Rook
keeps an eye on the seventh ranked White
Knight covers any Escape scores for the
black king but you need a third
attacking piece three is the magic
number and you don't have that uh no way
to Checkmate that black king unless the
king comes are we gonna see another King
of the Hill battle here well it's not
about the pawns anymore Maxim once again
going for magnus's King yeah
to do this it worked in the last game
and it has come at the cost of a pawn
but he's running forward if the white
king ever lands on D6 the black king is
totally trapped uh but Black's Knight of
course will have something to say about
that Black's Rook can check from behind
as well
uh depending where the white king lands
now a check might be key there we go oh
and you can't really block it with the
Knight because then you just end up with
a devastating pin which can be doubled
down on and like you said that white
white king is just about being able to
join the party here yeah Black's Rook
doing a great job of cutting across the
D file stopping the white king from
moving across
to more useful squares and white tonight
trying to block that D file trying to go
for some pawns but Magnus he feels feels
like he's on the brink of safety
well the clock plate of factor do you
think we'll see a scenario of Rook vs
rook and Maxine trying to flag Magnus
oh yeah that's such a that's such a
dilemma right even from the from your
psychological and these both of them
such Sportsmen I don't really know what
happens if we get to that point uh Kaya
where you know it's a draw there's
nothing to play for but the flag is that
a an ongoing debate always and chess if
flagging is unsportsmanlike or if it's
just a part of the game certain players
have stronger views
the degradation of flagging I think as
of Vladimir kramnik called it it's not
recommendous would he be super angry
with mvl if they ended with losing and
flagging I don't think so he knows it's
part of the game both of these players
do they are Sportsmen and it is a dead
drawn position we should clarify the
departure of knights Magnus gave up his
extra Pawn to get the knights off the
board means it's a dead draw and Maxine
doesn't try to flag he offers the draw
and Magnus progresses after a huge fight
between two fantastic chess players they
tied the match in the rap rapid portion
it ends with a much loss for mvl in
Armageddon he wasn't able to get the win
he needed with the white pieces and that
means Magnus Carlsen again makes it
through to the Grand Final to be played
on Friday well how will you sum up this
match Tanya it was fantastic it was such
a great fight and even this last
Armageddon it ended in a draw yeah and
both the games that the players won the
decisive the two decisive games just
incredible action all along Fighting
Chess I don't think we could have asked
more from today I've loved every bit of
it yeah I've seen people on social media
just get historical with this much than
talking about it's just one of the
greatest matches uh they've seen David
you've commentated on so many games now
in the Champions chest or where were you
placed as much yeah I would rank this
right up there I think on the tour this
season at least it's been the highest
one of the highest quality head-to-head
matches maybe the most dramatic uh to
head match and it was just great to see
both players in top form and in the end
it was fitting it was a draw it's just
unfortunate for Maxine vashilograph that
it was Armageddon
um just yeah it was incredible it's
definitely ranks up there with one of
the highlights on the Champions festival
and what's been the highlight for you
today Tanya in this matchup I mean if if
you have to choose something
so much to choose from so many positions
come to mind but uh I think one of the
big ones the big moment has been Maxim
finding his chances in that fourth game
queen versus two Rooks marching up with
the King and managing to box up magnus's
game to end that with a Checkmate and
taking it to the Armageddon what a fight
it is I mean anyone who plays against
Magnus Magnus is a huge favorite to come
back against him uh it already feels
like you need a miracle yeah and Maxim
with his uh attacking chess and not
backing down attitude he made that
happen and both these Players yesterday
said that they're really looking forward
to this fight and now we know why
and it is Magnus Carlsen who wins it
making it through his third consecutive
Grand Final in the Champions chess tour
of Magnus it's been an amazing match
today we had sacrifices we had
incredible accuracy have you felt on
fire today
um no actually
uh uh I sort of missed the start of
of the the match because I was just
following falling asleep on the couch
that's hard but uh yeah I think this is
the sort of thing that happens when you
play Sicilians in every game
um
I didn't think I mean I thought the
first game was generally
um a well played draw but
um yeah after that it was was a big mess
like the annoying thing about playing
these openings is that
I know that I'm going to make more
mistakes but that's also you know uh
that's also fun it was it was a lot of a
lot of fun today great match and uh I
thought Maxim
um played it the way he plays when he
plays well like uh giving it a really
really good fight so much to talk about
in in this matcha and you mentioned at
the opening so playing the nidorf
against Miel who is probably known as
maybe the best in this opening is that
psychological from you is that a mind
game trying to beat him in his opening
and to get an advantage in that way
yeah maybe a little bit I mean we've had
plenty of nighters where I'm on the on
the white side but I feel like
I can play Such positions as well I mean
in this case I just decided to play
something that looks interesting over
the world and frankly it wasn't wasn't
very good but um
uh yeah you know I just wanted to uh to
have some some big fights today so that
was um that was fun yeah and then in
game one I don't know if you checked it
but the accuracy for you was 99.6 the
Acura Z4 mvl in that game was 99.8 do
you agree that's simply incredible
yeah I don't know I think uh after a
certain point
um the the moves are like fairly simple
and I think at several points there were
many equivalents moves like everything
was with zeros basically so yeah I I
don't think it was anything special just
uh a generally well played game and then
also talking about game three some crazy
sacrifices and that has commentators and
everyone going crazy now you and mvl you
both seem so calm in those crazy
situations and we were wondering
actually during that game do you have
some sort of breathing methods something
you do to actually stay calm when it is
super fire on the board
yeah I don't know I was just excited to
play
an exciting position so
um I mean I didn't totally expect the
line that he that he played and frankly
like
sort of my knowledge of of the line that
he played sort of ends
around
[Music]
2000 probably 2005 six when topalov
introduced it out the highest level and
I remember there was some you had some
I don't remember if it was to follow or
somebody else but there was a uh Queen
SEC line where in If instead of Rook
Jade it got F6 and I go Bishop D3 and
give up the queen
um I also remember like Knight day four
was an alternative uh there instead so
that that was sort of the only thing
that I remembered I didn't remember the
evaluation or anything I just remembered
that it was was a line and following
like chess back then it was was a lot of
fun to see so I thought yeah let's go
for for that hopefully he doesn't
doesn't know it so well
um
I wouldn't say there unnecessarily
managed to stay so calm later uh because
I did I think missed some opportunities
when I had uh the two Bishops against
his his Rooks but yeah with his pawns
it's always scary
um
but it was um yeah it was a lot of fun
it really was a lot of fun Magnus
congratulations that was a super cool
match to watch and both of you just put
up such a show for everyone and I want
to ask you about the Armageddon
especially the bid around it after these
four incredible fights going into the
Armageddon uh what was your mind set for
the bid and how important was it for you
to get the black pieces
yeah I mean considering his bed I
clearly
um I clearly under bench considerably
because I could have uh
yeah I could have been almost two
minutes more and still gotten the bike
pieces uh it was it was more of a
mindset thing for
for me
um because I didn't want to have to try
and win I just I thought yeah um it's
better if I just reacted I thought it's
also better if I don't think so
um getting black would be good but I
know that uh that makes sense
is a it's a very good mathematician uh
and he he generally thinks about these
things so it has been being so high it
surprised me but I probably have to
think about it till till next time
because he usually knows what he's doing
amazing Mind Games there as well
Magnus what made you switch up to the
karakano for the Armageddon
uh yeah I don't know
um I'd sort of
um had enough of the stupid line that I
played in last game because I'd I had it
once in the speeches championship
against uh Jan as well and I messed up
that one and I messed it up when I when
I played against alresa so I thought
yeah that's probably enough let's do
something else uh but yeah unfortunately
the the opening went really well I think
Queen B3 was
um practically a decisive mistake uh in
terms of him having hopes of of winning
I think after that there's just no
coming coming back my position is too
solid and another great it worked out
well yeah and another great result from
you in Armageddon you've had many of
those uh lately Magnus you seem to
always be in control to get the
controlled result you need do you feel
like that when you head into the
Armageddon that you can control this to
the result that you need
no not really usually
um usually I'm I head into armageddon's
having lost lost the previous game with
black or at least that's what happened
what's happened the last couple of times
so then I'm just bidding to get another
black game with uh
um
you know with uh like eight minutes
instead of 15 and no increments so
that's uh a considerably worse situation
and to be in so like if I felt like I
was in control I should have been in
control in the in the in the last
um rapid game instead but
yeah uh fortunately those have
gone pretty well for me I don't know if
my opponent's mindset change a bit mine
our mind changes yeah I don't know I I
also I've also lost some
it's
uh it goes up and down a bit mostly up
and uh Magnus you've earned yourself a
rest day but after that in the Grand
Final you have three possible opponents
all of whom are fighting uh for the tour
final spot in Toronto in December is
there anyone you would rather play and
also what will you do tomorrow on your
rest day
I don't know what I'm going to
uh to do I haven't made
this particular plans
um no I haven't played Giroud yet this
season that would be be fun and he's
just knocked out two very strong players
but
we'll see
um it's it's a really really good field
um this
this time and I feel like I've already
you know knocked out or not knocked out
but at least knocked down some
some really big names so
whoever I play
I think it will be exciting definitely
today was definitely exciting Magnus
yesterday you said you looked forward to
getting a crack at mvl again it's been a
long time so to sum it up was this just
a great day of just for you
yeah I think so
um like sometimes I'm
really harsh on myself or you know a lot
of the time I am
um today I mean I made mistakes he made
mistakes we both found resources I mean
my loss in the Armageddon was a little
bit unnecessary because I did at some
point like try and force a draw instead
of going for a position with um
with uh the just the two pawns and and
the two Rooks
um sorry it just two pounds in a queen
against two Rooks which I think should
have been uh pretty straightforward draw
so that was a little bit unnecessary but
yeah overall
I thought it was um was it's a great day
of uh of just uh really really good
fights and
um yeah I think I can play even better
but I'm I'm fairly happy considering the
complexity of the positions wow well
that would be interesting with even
better play Magnus enjoy your rest day
tomorrow and we wish you good luck in
the Grand Final
thank you so much thank you for joining
us
yeah he is very often strict with
himself but today Magnus Carlsen has
enjoyed the fight with mvl and here are
the post match stats
that accuracy for Rapid games one
Armageddon MBL actually the most
accurate one in this matchup what would
you say about these numbers Daniel like
almost a similar accuracy at around 94
but I think it's that one extra
brilliancy that we're seeing around for
Magnus uh and two uh blunders there for
uh Maxim so just a very very close fight
I really went down to the wire isn't it
two brilliances one blunder for Magnus
actually zero blunders from Maximum yes
I mean brilliances each two brilliances
each so this this looks like mvl won the
match but he didn't it was an Armageddon
Magnus took it so so what can we say
about mbl's play today as well David I
mean mvl really brought his best he
really Sean he was unlucky it was
Armageddon uh we we have to remember it
was two and a half uh oh sorry what's
the score two and a half two and a half
after all those five games it's been a
long day of Chess and then an Armageddon
yeah so it's just the fact that black
had draw odds I mean he matched Magnus
blow for blow he uh I mean he really
really brought it when the tactics
arrived and he was just unlucky what can
you say when fire meets fire eventually
someone had to win I mean the score line
was leveled right yeah it's just the
Armageddon that's just how it goes yep
wow what a day and it continues the AI
cup is definitely not over you guys
tomorrow it will be a day on the losers
bracket it's gonna be decided whoo from
the losers back it goes through to play
Magnus Carlsen in the Grand Final on
Friday
Geary faces napomniacci and the loser is
semi-final we will start the day with
that match up best out of two rapid
games potentially Armageddon to decide
who goes through to the losers final to
play mvl and the winner in that match
will face Magnus Carlsen and all of
those three players still left in the
losers bracket are fighting to go
through to Toronto to the tour final we
also have Federal Sev in division two
fighting for that final spot is that
something that will be
in the back of their heads at least
Tanya a hundred percent because they've
come so close to it now and all these
three players like you said are the ones
who are yet to qualify uh for Toronto uh
we start with Anish versus Jana pandashi
it's a matchup that we've seen before
but I feel like it's been a niche 2.0
since day two yeah because he took down
Hikaru in this great style two to zero
and then Shakura Mama yarov today just
fantastic Chess By Anisha and tomorrow
he takes on Jan so it could be a bit of
a grudge match there furnish could be a
grush match all the remaining players
they're just in great form uh Magnus is
the final boss though yet again and in
order to bank their spot claim their
spot they have to get through him it's
not to be easy yeah you guys have been
in those chairs for well more than six
hours now it's been a long day it's in
our home to sleep or is at home to play
bullet chess you guys on chess.com I'm
pumped I'm full of adrenaline I hope the
viewers are too it's been a great day of
Chess yeah and it continues tomorrow we
will be back we look forward to some
incredible chats here in the Champions
chess store thanks for watching you guys
we'll see you guys again tomorrow bye
and it's all happening look at this he's
given up his roof amazing this is genius
Pawn to C5 this could be the move of the
tour so far
takes it in Armageddon with a genius
move wow paused Queen sacrifice we have
the first decided game and the winner is
final minus takes the win
s
The Queen Is Coming forward to B4 it's
Checkmate Checkmate guaranteed
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]